hey everyone welcome to this video on
PMP certification full course
we'll begin this full course video by
talking about what project management is
learn about project planning and how it
can be done in Excel you will understand
cost quality communication and other
forms of management the best project
management tools and how you can prepare
for the PMP exam
you will understand the role of a
project manager discuss the crucial
interview questions and much more
by the time we are done you will be well
versed in some of the most important
Concepts in project management
for this training with me we have a
specialist Chandra Mr and ishan together
they will take you through the different
topics
so let's start by answering the question
what is project management
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn
hi
welcome to project management tutorial
from simple learn I am Chandra Mr a
professional consultant and coach in
best practices related to project
management and IT service management
today as part of this tutorial we are
going to learn the basic understanding
about the project management and the
required knowledge for a project manager
to become successful in managing
projects so as part of this tutorial we
are going to look at what is project
management what is Project components of
project management Project Life Cycle
key Focus areas in project management
job roles in project management and
project management certifications so
what is project management now as
defined in pmis pmbok project management
is application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to project activities to
meet project requirements so every
project will have an objective to
accomplish similarly the objective of
project management is to make the final
deliverables in a finite time and budget
this involves having clear understanding
about the deliverables of the project
require resources for the project
resource in terms of Human Resources
Technical Resources Financial Resources
Etc project managers should have a full
picture of those aspects we can call it
as constraints or aspects and manage
those throughout the Project Life Cycle
for which a project manager should have
a full view about a project and what is
that this project has to accomplish that
objective should be clear so as part of
project management the six constraints
which project manager should look at are
scope time quality cost risk and
resources so each of these areas has
very important role to play in project
management the clarity in scope the
clarity in terms of schedule within
which the project has to be delivered
the cost what it incurs to that
particular project once it is finalized
one cannot vary one cannot change
without any proper approvals similar to
that we have quality management which
has to ensure the scope the
specifications what are defined project
output will be accordingly achieved risk
every project is taken up for a specific
reason by organization so organization
should assess the risk associated with
the project and similarly as project
progresses various different risks has
to be identified like Risk related to
project management risk related to
technology area risk related to
resources risk related to financial
things so broadly risk management plays
a very important role so there will be
something called contingency reserve
kept for a identified risk above the
cost what is estimated for various
deliverables from the project so every
projects require resources resources may
be in terms of Human Resources Financial
Resources technology resources
environmental resources so all these
resources are used to produce the output
of the project so these resources has to
be managed with the sufficient
optimization and standardizations
required now let us understand the
definition of a project so what is a
project PMI defines a project as a
temporary Endeavor undertaken to create
a unique product service or result the
temporary nature of a project indicates
that a project has a definite beginning
and end so when I say product unique
product it means every output it may be
similar products you are producing with
the same features and functionality but
the output of every project is unique
because it is unique in terms of all the
six constraints what we just discussed
now now when I say product it is very
easy for us to visualize it may be a
desktop it may be a laptop it may be a
car it may be a machine Etc but how do I
visualize a service now projects output
is a service now it is it's about
building a capability a project by
through a project a capability can be
built to ensure Services can be provided
that's what the output of project is
service for example example if I think
about a taxi services for providing a
taxi services I need a mobile app I need
taxi I need a server I need a data
center so all these are various
different products and services here
service example can be internet service
so combination of all the services and
products builds the capability for an
organizations who can provide the taxi
services so building that capability we
say it is an output of a particular
project which is called service
similarly results can be Improvement of
something Improvement in customer
satisfaction increase in some specific
objectives or specific results needs to
be achieved in performance perspective
so output of every project will be
unique product or a service or a result
this we need to clearly understand so
when we say there is a definite
beginning and end every project starts
at a certain point in time and ends at
certain point in time so it has a
definite beginning and end that is the
reason it is temporary in nature it is
not an ongoing business activity right
so every project will have a life cycle
a beginning and end so when it starts
till end until the result or a service
or a product which comes as an output of
a project project lifecycle is not ended
so interestingly in a product life cycle
or in a service life cycle you come
across many project life cycles so one
Project Life Cycle means one project is
initiated to introduce a product or
Services next project or initiated would
be to enhance the capability of a
service or a product next project
initiated after some time is to optimize
something similarly at the end of the
product life cycle project is initiated
to return that product or services so in
a given product life cycle there will be
multiple Project Life Cycle so what is
involved in the Project Life Cycle it
involves five areas five groups we can
call it as so initiation planning
execution monitoring and closure so when
I say initiation it's up all about
understand adding what is Project giving
the basic understanding of the project
collating the details and having key
stakeholders identified once that is
done one will move towards planning so
here in the initiation it is very
clearly one has to understand is Project
is worthwhile of doing so one has to
check the feasibility one has to measure
that particular investment is making
sense and then confirm yes it makes
sense to invest now next planning as we
have a basic understanding of yes this
project has to be done and a discussion
with the key stakeholders have happened
now that moves towards planning now in
planning one will understand the project
in entirety if it is a waterfall
approach one has to have a clear
articulation of entire project a
comprehensive details holistic approach
now if you go if you're going in a
project in a agile way of approach now
in this planning you may have a big
skeleton as you go in each of the
iteration you may go deep dive into
detailed planning if it is a agile
approach so planning provides you the
clear Insight towards what needs to be
done in this project how it has to be
done and what are the results which can
be achieved out of that particular
project so this involves making that a
clear blueprint of an project objectives
what we are supposed to achieve so this
will become a reference point throughout
the Project Life Cycle then execution as
you have a blueprint of the project as
the direction of that project is set
detailing of the project has been made
one will go ahead and execute the
project execute in a sense
implementation acquiring resources and
implementing it so execution phase
involves the allocation of resources and
making the deliverables as required you
acquire resources you configure resource
you ensure right resources are required
if it is human resource one has to
educate the human resource with the
project required knowledge or details or
one has to provide that assignment in
such a way that skills of that
individuals what what they should have
is acquired by those individuals so that
deliverables can happen and they needs
to be managed the entire team needs to
be managed for that a clear structure
has to be created similarly when you do
technology resource perspective those
components has to be tested configured
then integrated again tested for
unchecked the performances so Collective
action of this results in a deliverable
during the execution so as the
deliverables are happening in the
execution it is quite obvious project
manager has to monitor review control
that particular deliverable and also the
processes tools resources used during
the project even those needs to be
monitored so that they are complaining
to the defined processes so during
monitoring there may be a deviation one
can found during monitoring there may be
the project is running the way it is
required so in this monitoring phase it
involves an action from project manager
to Monitor and control the work of the
project so comparing with the blueprint
of plan and what is accomplished what is
created during the planning phase of
this project and as the execution
happens monitoring and control is
monitoring it and checking is that
activity is what is being done is
according to the plan or not similarly
the deliverables which comes as an
output of your projects are tested
thoroughly whether those have a specific
features and functionality and are they
functioning the way it is required now
project has to be delivered to the scope
what is defined it should not go beyond
that or below that similarly the
schedule what is made for the project
within that schedule project
deliverables has to be accomplished
within the cost what is budgeted for the
project so during the project your
project manager may find there are
certain deviations which are occurred
there are additional challenges which
has come in so for this reason one has
to ensure continued monitoring as the
execution happens and identify those
deviation and ensure Whenever there is a
deviation there is a correct Whenever
there is an additional things coming in
that needs to be considered carefully
whether that need to be involved as part
of this deliverable or should be taken
it separately so this requires lot of
conversation with all the stakeholders
of the project during the entire Project
Life Cycle especially during planning
execution monitoring and control since
they are not the one which is happening
in sequence so planning can also come
back again where there is something
which you may require to modify so may
require to have a change in the
blueprint Itself by adding that new
change which is coming in so you go back
to planning so planning execution
monitoring and control are going hand in
hand so that project deliverables are
happening as needed similarly all the
process work instructions all those
templates what is given are used one is
complying to those requirement it is
very important and project is done
within the scope schedule and time and
the quality metrics defined then as the
completion of the project happens as the
monitoring and control says yes
deliverable has happened according to
the requirement then the project moves
to the closure the closure may be
closure of a specific project phase a
milestone deliverable or a phrasal
deliverable or it can be deliverable at
the end of the project which is the
ultimate deliverable so processes in
closing has to be triggered Whenever
there is end of the phase Whenever there
is a deliverable to conclude and also at
the end of the project to conclude the
entire project so during the closure one
has to ensure capturing all the details
in terms of what is accomplished against
what is defined what went wrong what
went well what is a learning one has to
take to the next level or the next phase
or to the next project and at the same
time a sign off has to be obtained
formally and everything should be
summarized and have a good handshake
with the project stakeholder mainly a
business or customer and also
disseminating of Team means you will
dismantle the entire team and send them
back to their specific units or
specialization and they may get assigned
to new project or or if it is a
functional they can go back to their
functions to do their functional
activities so that was about entire
Project Life Cycle what happens now
while doing this I mentioned there are
six constraints that is scope schedule
cost quality risk and resources so
keeping these in mind one has to ensure
project is successful in all aspects so
to become successful there are few key
areas which has to be looked at so first
six key areas are scope schedule cost
quality resources and stakeholders now
let us look at the scope what the scope
means scope is about what needs to be
delivered what is in scope what is out
of the scope so this refers to all those
deliverable scope all those activity
scope basically we speak about two
things one is product scope and project
scope product scope is all about
ensuring the features functionality of
products are well defined and understood
and signed off and while delivering that
product that is tested against those
defined features and functionalities
whereas projects go focus on all the
activities needs to be done all those
templates which has to be used all the
process which has to be complied with
all that skills which is required to be
applied so it is going as defined so by
doing this activities which is defined
as part of project scope the result the
deliverable will come out which will be
in line with the deliverables features
and functionality which is defined as
part of product scope it is very
important to ensure entire projects
happens within this particular scope
there should not be any deviations from
this schedule perspective for that
specifications what we Define for a
product and a project so these needs to
be done in a specific point in time
means in a specific schedule there will
be start time and time right so one has
to plan how long a project would take
and what are the deliverables should
happen in what sequence what activities
are required to accomplish this so all
these needs to be understood so while
performing the schedule management one
has to look at us specific deliverable
at a specific point in time by applying
a specific set of activities required so
this will tell you the duration of the
project this will provide you the
sequence of project this will also help
you to understand the dependency between
one task to another task this will also
help you to understand how the
deliverables happening in what sequence
which helps in prioritizing your
deliverables third is cost so as we know
to do any project it is very essential
to ensure project happens within that
budget so project cost is estimated
initially then that estimated cost will
be checked checked in terms of is the
assumptions considerations are right or
wrong is that really so much of a
monetary resources are required for the
project and then after understanding the
justification and obtaining the clarity
budget is I mean monetary resources are
allocated and confirmed approved then it
will become a budget that will be a cost
Baseline so these estimation allocation
of budget once it happens that will
become a base and any deviations from
that cannot happen so easily so any
deviations because of additional of
scope that can be handled through change
management but idealistic scenario the
cost should not escalate or come down
organization can also set certain
tolerances at the project level
considering various different scenarios
like scenario of risks scenario of
something which deviated from the
deliverable so to what extent it can
deviate that tolerance will also be set
at the economic or monetary value
perspective that is about cost
now quality as we know quality is a very
important area which ensures the project
is delivered in time with all the
specifications defined by using all the
methods means by following all the
processes work instructions templates
and delivering as needed where it
enables the project to monitor it easily
so basically the requirement of
compliance and standardization and
optimization is to ensure everyone
follows the same steps to the activity
so what quality management focus is to
ensure the intended objectives of a
projects are achieved already there is a
definition done in terms of various
different practices or processes needs
to be followed similarly specification
of each of the products are defined and
from that there should not be any
deviation so quality management should
focus on ensuring those activities are
done as defined those deliverables are
done according to the specifications
what is different it is very important
that way so for that there is a layer of
quality management should be a layer of
quality management where auditing our
control activities are initiated
periodically so that any deviations can
be seen easily and remember a project
manager can become cannot become part of
quality management like project manager
cannot audit project manager should have
a team or take the help of a team who
can able to do mostly the one which is
who is not part of the project is always
better resources now as I mentioned
earlier every project need resources it
may be human resources it may be
technology resources it may be any other
resources which are required to do the
project so organization acquires
resources configured and then deployed
for example in a project you acquire a
server you configure a server you deploy
a server technology resource human
resource is onboarded recruited project
induction is given then at the same time
the skills and capabilities of
individuals are according to the
requirement of project that needs to be
ensured and what needs to be delivered
and how it has to be delivered should be
cleared to the particular human resource
so looking at all the aspects of
resources to acquire to build and manage
it is very important to look at the
resource management so this will help in
carrying out a specific task in a
project in a best possible manner so
interestingly when I say human resource
always there is a possibility that a
conflict can occur so when I say
conflict conflict of interest may be in
terms of what the individuals has to do
conflict in terms of the preferences in
terms of solutions what they are looking
at conflict in terms of using resources
different opinions different preferences
various reasons conflict and come across
so it is very important to project
manager to understand this dynamics of
human resources and manage this
conflicts project manager cannot shy
away from handling conflicts project
manager has to hone and resolve those
conflicts in the favor of project not in
the favor of any individuals so there
are various techniques to look at
resolving conflicts so that is like
compromising problem solving smoothening
accommodating
so whichever helps for that project
scenario for the project objectives that
needs to be applied that technique has
to be taken up so here the resolution is
not at the specific individual's
preference it is with the objective of
other projects as any impact what kind
of impact positive or negative if it is
negative no that's not the direction the
direction should be ensuring project
gets that value through this conflict
resolution so project manager should own
it it's an accountability of a project
manager then as the human resources are
required there are five stages Team
Dynamics are involved so one has to
bring them then educate them about a
project as a education on the project
happens one has to go and do the job on
floor that needs to be observed means
one has to manage by looking at it and
any corrections is dividend that needs
to be guided so it is very Dynamic thing
when it comes to Human Resources
similarly in technology resources
standardization there is no ambiguity as
such but right Resources with the right
configurations should be acquired that
is very important the next stakeholders
so who can be stakeholders every project
will have a stakeholder who are internal
and external to the project so the
internal stakeholders are those who are
part of the project who are part of the
organization who are part of the
customer organization or part of
supplier organization a competition to
my business means my organization's
business all this we can call it as a
stakeholders now every stakeholders will
have a specific interest a power an
ability to influence now through their
position through their distance from the
project they will get impacted at the
same time they will also impact the
project similarly they influence and
they get influenced because of the
project so a project manager should
identify all the stakeholders and
understand this what is the kind of
stakeholder is this in terms of power in
terms of legitimacy in terms of
influence in terms of impact after
understanding that there should be
strategy for handling the stakeholders
how am I going to engage with these
stakeholders it is very important and
accordingly the engagement should happen
and then stakeholder engagement should
resolve in the favor of projects again
so if it is a customer customer should
get the inputs required through review
or periodic updates and the engagement
required with the customer so that
customer is having up-to-date
information about the project if it is a
team continued monitoring and control
and ensuring team delivers the results
what is required so focus of a
stakeholder should be in such a way that
your strategy should enable project to
become successful and get a proper
response from the stakeholder means a
supporting engagement so next few key
Focus areas to mention is communication
risk procurement critical success
factors deliverables and work breakdown
so this list is not exhaustive as we
deep dive into project I think you can
just keep listing the key Focus areas
more than this but whatever we have
indicated are the minimum which needs to
be looked at so when I say communication
communication is basically a
conversation exchange of message which
happens between two entities now
whenever we communicate it is necessary
to understand that it has to happen with
two individuals or two entities there
should be sender there should be
receiver in the absence of receiver if
sending is happening that communication
doesn't make any sense there should be a
receiver and there should be an
acknowledgment from the receiver now
this is one of the most ignored area in
many of the projects even the
communication happens more often more
frequently but what people face
difficulty in realizing that as they
communicate generally informally
formally they just take those for
granted now when you identify the
stakeholder one has to understand what
is the communication requirement for
those stakeholders what is that
communication why is that communication
what is the content of that
communication how frequently we should
do that interactions or Communications
in intent of that particular
communication what is the expected
action or response from that
communication all this needs to be very
very clear and this can be articulated
it has to be articulated so one it is
articulated once there is a picture in
terms of what kind of communication has
to happen it is quite obvious there
should not be any deviation from the
agreed Communications requirements and
whenever there is a need of change to
the communication requirements from the
stakeholders that needs to be updated
for this one has to have a stakeholders
identified so stakeholder management and
communication are very closely linked
and Associated a engagement with the
stakeholder will become successful with
an effective communication approaches
next is risk so every project which is
undertaken by organization that will
have certain amount of risk which
organization will evaluate similarly
within the Project Life Cycle lot of
risk comes up which would have certain
impact to the project now risk refers to
by definition an uncertain event it has
an uncertainty an event which is
uncertain and when it occurs it will
have an impact on the project positively
or negatively now current scenario in
everywhere the projects What You observe
closely people tend to look at the risk
which are threats that is negative only
but they fail to recognize the risks
which are opportunities the positive
risks so another gap which we see when
do the risk management is that is done
in the initial phase of the project as
the project is kicked off someone will
do the risk assessment have a list of
risk identified but unfortunately there
is no categorizations for that risk and
how is that going to impact the project
that is not clear thirdly risk
management or list of risk are created
only once it is not done repeatedly so
risk identification and Analysis and
assessment of that risk has to be done
throughout the life cycle of your
project reason being the risk which
looks as in high impact when project is
initiated as the project progresses the
impact levels will vary Maybe the middle
of the project the impact may be very
high or low so likewise the impacts of
the risk will vary throughout the
Project Life Cycle it may be positive it
may be negative so as you identify the
stakeholder throughout the Project Life
Cycle as I said that is also a dynamic I
cannot just have a list of stakeholders
and I keep it as it is I need to update
that also regularly risk identification
assessment and Analysis should also be
done regularly periodically so that one
will have a clear understanding about is
that risk still valid is that risk is
there still or not what is the level of
variations in terms of impact of the
risks so this Clarity will be there so
that neces organization or project
manager can get ready to face those
risks if it is a negative risk
definitely you should have a mitigation
or avoidance or acceptance whatever the
mitigation plan you have to eliminate
the negative impact of the risk when it
occurs okay if it is a positive risk
it's quite obvious one has to take the
advantage of that one has to enhance
exploit share a positive risk so that
organization is benefited further
procurement so whenever a project is
initiated whenever a project is taken up
the organization who is doing the
project cannot create everything cannot
develop everything in that Project Life
Cycle so organization would take a
decision make a decision stating that
some of the deliverables we make
ourselves some of the products we make
ourselves some of the products we
purchase some of the services we
purchase so to purchase that has to
happen from a specific supplier you
cannot go with every supplier you should
evaluate the suppliers qualify the
suppliers and then select onboard the
supplier and then get the services or
products supplied by that particular
supplier so while doing this one has to
understand what type of Contracting they
need to enter with so three types of
contracts we speak basically one is
about a Cost Plus contract where cost is
fully known to the project manager and
to the organization so apart from known
cost a fee will be paid to the supplier
another one is fixed price where project
manager or the organization who is
awarding that contract to A supplier
will not know what is the cost instead
it is a fixed price but important here
is the scope of work needs to be clearly
articulated and defined another type of
Contracting can be time and material
where the billing will happen based on
the amount of time one is spent on that
particular a higher resource or onboard
resource and retirement material basis
and what is that effort that resource
has been put based on that building will
happen so three types of contracts
depending on the different scenarios of
the project will be signed with the
contractor however before doing that it
is very essential to identify those
suppliers sign off with them and monitor
and manage them so if deliverables are
not there it is very essential to look
at the termination known as to terminate
otherwise one has to ensure instead of
uh terminating should be able to put
some effort to educate them also so that
they come up to the mark So project is
benefited so depending on what needs to
be done that call has to be taken on a
regular basis then critical success
factor so for every project there should
be an articulation of critical success
factor So based on that one can confirm
yes project has achieved its objectives
our project has not achieved its
objectives so key critical success
factor should be supported through the
metrics key performance indicators so
key performance indicators provide those
metrics to say critical success factor
is achieved for example if I to become
successful in an exam critical success
factories scoring or passing the
examination or let me say to pass the
examination key performance indicator is
scoring 60 and above so critical success
factor for me to get promoted is to pass
in this particular exam so to pass in
this exam minimum I should score is 60
percent that is kpi passing in the exam
that is critical success factor so how
will I measure that success factor is
kpi so every project which it produces a
specific product or Services by using a
specific resources and each of these the
resources the processes the templates
the deliverables all these needs to be
measured on a continual basis so there
are critical success factors defined and
those are measured by defining kpis to
the critical success factors so
basically critical success factor
provides the Insight towards what needs
to be measured and when you measure what
should be the focus and to achieve those
critical success factors the indicator
is key performance indicators when you
measure yes the moment you achieve that
your CSF is achieved next deliverables
so deliverables are those which comes as
an output of the project right it may be
a product it may be a service it may be
a result so this refers to the output
within the scope of a project so there
can be one or more deliverables within a
single project so these deliverables may
be the items that are to be sent
externally to a customer or a
stakeholder so every deliverable will
have a defined scope will have a defined
specification so those derivatables has
to be measured tested and one has to
confirm yes this deliverable is
performing as we are intended to have
the performance accordingly the decision
will happen should we accept this
particular deliverable or not if there
any deviation that has to go back for
correction so that's the reason we have
monitoring and control all the control
processes like control quality focused
on the product straight whether it has
achieved that results or not is that
functional as needed or not when I has
to ensure these deliverables has all
those features and functionalities only
then that can be handed over to the
respective stakeholder customer or
operation whoever the stakeholder it is
next is work breakdown structure so when
we say work breakdown structure when I
look at a specific piece of product or
services and have a bigger picture I
cannot even visualize the various
different components various different
actions involved in achieving that
bigger deliverable so if I say a car so
I can think of a body external I can
think of a mirror on that body I can
think of a glass in the front side as
well as the back side and also I can
think of Interiors like seat then
accelerator steering dashboard only
second visualize but since I am not a
technology expert relating to car can I
visualize all those parts which are
working inside for car to move like
engine the battery assembly I don't know
what to say further so all these can be
visualized by an expert so every product
or services should be broken down into
multiple pieces I'm not saying go and
break that product I am saying that
product will have multiple components
which are involved those needs to be
segregated for example if I say cars
exteriors cars interior so cars
exteriors external items you can see
whatever you visualize body body
structure mirror mirror assembly
headlights then tires so likewise
whatever I can visualize I will make it
as a line items under the exterior so
under for example under a mirror mirror
I can speak about mirror glass mirror
cap mirror pedestal and mirror assembly
where it moves where you can move the
mirror so these are the various
components involved in a mirror so I
need to ensure by breaking down the
product into multiple levels the Depots
decomposing it to multiple levels I can
able to visualize the product very
clearly what is there in detail so once
I have the details I will articulate
those what is that particular work down
element is product breakdown element is
then I will look at what skills and
capabilities required for that product
and I will assign the resources
accordingly so once activities resources
everything is assigned automatically
this will become more breakdown
structure further after creating our
breakdown structure one will go on
sequence the activity look at sequencing
will happen based on in what priority
deliverable should happen What order
deliverable should happen then once the
sequencing is done it will be checked to
see whether anything can be optimized
anything can be done in such a way that
smooth flow of the project can happen
there is no dependencies which will make
project to delay like as the flow
happens smoothly so you would find the
various techniques like critical path
method Network diagramming critical
chain method so all these are used the
floats of an activities are checked then
leads and lags of the activities the
relationship between activities so
accordingly full visualization in terms
of how the project will flow and how in
what order the deliverables are
happening can very easily visualized so
that is the reason first activity is to
do the product breakdown which would
result in work background structure so
those are the points till now whatever I
mentioned are the basic understanding
one should have about a project and
project management so as you deep dive
into various best practices like PMP by
PMI prince2 by axelos scrum Master agile
scrum Master similarly you have
certified scrum master so many agile
practices so when you look at any of the
best practices that will tell you
clearly articulate what should be the
practice for you to adopt and adapt that
practices so that your project can
become successful so any of those
approach you touch upon all those refers
to these basic things in the absence of
these basic things none of those best
practices discusses the project
management now typically in the industry
there are a lot of job roles to the
project management which we have seen so
based on that this information is
captured here on various job roles in a
project management so some of them are
like project manager senior project
manager Project Lead resource manager
pmo that is project management office
analyst steering committee member so not
necessarily all the project management
roles are limited to this so these are
the roles which commonly you see and we
are trying to capture that to give the
Insight right when I say project manager
the project manager is the owner one has
to take an accountability for the
project right so project managers takes
the project according to the plan and
plays a lead role in all the steps of
the project management right so
responsibility should be managing
reviewing and prioritizing the task
wherever necessary looking after risk
management stakeholder management and
project communication management some of
the salary what we found while we were
doing the survey the success ratio of a
project depends majorly on the project
manager so the demand for project
manager is rapidly increasing in the
market so accordingly uh seventy five
thousand four seven four per year that
is a USD in INR it is fifteen hundred
thousand so this is what the salary of
an approximation what was found next
role we look at senior project manager
where senior project manager is ahead of
the overall project management plan the
role demands in-depth knowledge of all
the project aspects on a specific on the
specifics of the project the
responsibilities would be planning and
coordinating complex projects visiting
project sites to check progress and
handle complex issues so salary looks
like one not four thousand dollars per
year here twenty ninety two thousand INR
per year so the role of senior project
manager is one of the highest paying
roles in the industry as we have seen
having several allowances and bonuses
because of the criticality involved in
the project and the accountability level
of that particular individuals in the
organization next role Project Lead so
project leads are the one who leads the
people throughout the project and
provide them with all the information
required throughout so responsibilities
involve motivating the team when it's
taking care of their needs and paying
attention to what they feel ordering or
controlling the project team since the
project lead has more freedom than the
project manager salary Project Lead
makes sure that project gives the best
possible outcome and is hence the demand
for the project lead in a company never
reduces so in USD 82 000 per year
whereas in INR it is one million 269 000
per year next roll I will look at on
resource manager so resource manager is
the human resource needed to make the
project success right so one has to
manage those resources responsibility
involved assigning the right people to
the right projects at the right time
managing employees currently and
determining hiring needs depending on
the Project's requirements so salary
would be around 64 000 USD which comes
around 966 794 in INR project management
office analyst for this role the project
management office analyst works with pmo
means project management office and does
not look at the project or manage the
project directly instead does most of
the data driven work which required for
a project to have our project to get
supported by that so that project
managers will have better Insight
analyzing and interpreting the data
concerning the project figuring out the
future risks to the project finding new
ways to advance the idea of the project
management so salary would be one or six
thousand two fifty three per year in USD
whereas 449 thousands 337 in INR per
year so steering committee member so the
steering committee members are the
members who do not work on the project
themselves they are there to help the
project manager like providing inputs
during the development of a project
advising on the budget and evaluating
the project strategies taking regular
feedbacks on the project managers and
asking necessary questions so salary
would be around 68 000 497 dollars per
year so those were the various rules and
that is not that list is not an
exhaustive list various different roles
we come across but these are the basic
roles which is seen in the industry
these roles are being recruited now
there are various project management
certifications which are offered as I
mentioned earlier so those
certifications are PMP that is project
management professional from PMI agile
certified practitioner that is PMI ACP
again from PMI then certified associate
in project management so difference
between capm and PMP is like capm would
act as a basic level of certification
for those who does not have a sufficient
project experience project management
experience whereas pmps for those was
some project management experience
similarly PMI sap is the one who is
aspiring to look at agility in project
management and they can go for it
certified scrum Master yes it is a scrum
Master certificate which will explain
the role of a scrum master in detail
similarly prints to a certification from
axolos which also speak about all the
aspects of the project what we discussed
and provides the framework for project
management axillos also provides
Princeton certification in agile also
agile prints to a certification so we
will look at each one of this certain
details which are required for us to
know so project management professional
as I mentioned is most acknowledged and
value the certificate value what it
carries which has resulted to the
certified Professionals in landing up in
highest paid jobs in the world so
certified managers gets 20 percent more
salary than the average salary so to
take up an examination one has to go
through the formal training of 35 hours
that is one of the prerequisites and
there should be some experience of 4 500
hours of project managing project by
Leading rovery's activities of a project
and once the person becomes eligible
with that prerequisites personal become
register in the pmi's website becomes
member and then go for exam Nation so
examination fee for PMP would be 4.5
dollars for the members who are
registered with PMI and for those who
are not registered as a member with BMI
it is 555 the duration of the
examination is four hours and the number
of questions will be 200 which are
multiple choice questions so each each
questions carries one marks there is no
negative score now prerequisites one has
to have 4 500 hours directing and
leading the projects that experience has
to be filled in while filling the
application if a person is a bachelor
degree holder and along with the 35
contactors of PMI PM education now
prerequisites for the one who is not a
graduate who may be high school or
diplomo is 7 500 hours of directing and
leading projects 35 hours of PM
education so those are the prerequisites
before one will go on appear for
examination so once an individual passes
PMP examination that certificate is
valid for three years so now after three
years if the person has place to keep
the certificate continued they need to
produce 60 pdus professional development
units which has to be acquired during
those three years how to acquire one has
to go through additional learning one
has to contribute towards project
management knowledge base so those needs
to be evidenced and then renewable fee
estupid and certificate has to be
renewed then agile certified
practitioner as we saw for PMP here
agile certified practitioner
demonstrates that one has relevant
experience in education to handle and
Lead agile projects the organization has
started shifting towards agile as we
know in today's industry which makes
this certification fast growing in the
world so examination fee would be 435
dollars for PMI members 495 for non-pmi
members duration is three hours and
multiple choice questions 120 questions
prerequisites is 2 000 hours project
management experience with 1000 500
hours agile experience and 21 contact
hours of agile practice so maintenance
30 videos are required for every three
years and after paying the renewal fee
that can be renewed now certified
associate in project management so here
this is an entry level certificate of
PMI especially for those people who has
less project experience it intends to
demonstrate fundamental knowledge
terminologies and processes of effective
project management so examination fee
would be dollar twenty two twenty five
for PMI members whereas 300 dollars for
non-members of BMI so duration of
examination is three hours and
examination will have 150 multiple
choice questions so prerequisites
someone who has secondary diploma 23
contact hours of PM education is enough
there is no experience of doing the
project is required as we saw in PMP so
maintenance is again three years someone
who need to continue this certification
as to retake the examination every three
years next certified scrum master so
certified scrum Master is an entry level
certification that helps support
professionals to begin as the scrum
practitioners is one of the most sought
after certifications as other after this
one can get the designation of certified
scrum Master which is offered by scrum
Alliance so examination of P which will
change team to time which is not
revealed so one has to approach the
training organization where they will
get trained on certified scrum master so
duration of examination is 60 minutes
and pattern would be 16 hours 2 days of
training and 50 multiple choice
questions after that particular two days
of train then prerequisite is done for
maintaining this credentials so one has
to ensure it has renewed every two years
then projects in controlled environment
that is prince2 so prince2 is a method
which is effective mostly from the base
of UK all the organizations who are from
UK region prefer prints to certification
and it is as popular as any other
project management certifications like
PMP so examination fee would vary from
900 dollars to thousand dollars
depending on where exactly you're taking
the examination and certification will
happen at two levels one is at
Foundation level and other one is
practitioner so in Foundation it is 60
Questions multiple choice and in
practitioner it is 68 questions now 60
questions or 68 questions each carries
one marks for correct answer any wrong
answer there will not be any negative
scoring one has to score 55 percent to
clear the examination so prerequisites
for Princeton Foundation is none whereas
prince2 Foundation is a prerequisite for
Princeton practitioner examination so to
maintain the certificate one has to
achieve 20 cpts every year continued
professional development hi guys my name
is ishan and I welcome you all to this
session of project planning today we
will be learning about different aspects
of project planning but before we begin
let's have a look at an incident here's
Max an assistant project manager who
looks tensed and is pacing around the
room then Jack a project manager who
works with him walks into the room and
asks him why does he seem so tensed to
which Max replies he is facing
difficulty in estimating the budget Jack
responds it might be because he is not
planning the project properly Jack
reassures Max and begins to tell him
about project planning so today we will
be learning about what is Project
planning and check out the fundamentals
of project planning then we will see why
project planning is so essential for a
project to be successful after that we
will check the tools for project
planning and finally we will have a look
at the steps for project planning so
without any further Ado let's begin with
what is Project planning project
planning is the second step or phase of
the Project Life Cycle Project Life
Cycle has five different phases from
initiation to closure today we will be
learning about this phase that comes
immediately after initiation in which
the project plan is documented and
further requirements are defined project
planning includes the following things
the first and foremost thing is
describing the objectives or outputs we
are expecting the project to yield
second we have is the elaboration of the
scope to make sure what the project is
all about and what all can be expected
from the project the third step we have
is forming a schedule this schedule is
important to run or perform different
tasks of a project each task having its
own start date and end date this helps
the project to finish in the scheduled
time and limit lastly we have making and
generating progress reports in which all
that went during the tenure of the
project is documented this helps in
evaluating the project and helps in the
forthcoming projects now let's have a
look at the project planning
fundamentals the First Fundamental that
we have is the determination of scope
cost and resources that determination
helps us in having a rough estimate
about the time that is required to
finish the project it helps us in
determining the number of people
required and what should be their skill
set we can divide the project into
smaller manageable sections and this is
made possible with the help of work
breakdown structure the second
fundamental refers to identifying the
problem there are several techniques by
which we can collect information and
discover issues there may be several
problems in a project and in that case
several risks or issues are prioritized
and the risk that requires immediate
attention is dealt with first then comes
identification of stakeholders when we
can identify the stakeholders we can
know who all will be affected and in
what way which helps us having a better
understanding of the project
stakeholders may be anybody they may be
the part of the project team or project
managers or customers they help you in
the project and contribute to its
success then the last fundamental we
will discuss is defining project
objectives a project plan is made
keeping in mind the requirements of the
project team and expectations of the
stakeholders if the project team can
meet the expectations of the
stakeholders then only we can say that
the project is successful now when we
know about project planning and its
fundamentals it's time to see why
project planning is so important project
planning reduces the cost and time of
the project as every step is monitored
and optimized in the best possible
manner project planning increases
employee satisfaction as every employee
who is a part is engaged in the team for
improved project performance project
planning helps in the implementation of
quality assurance as the output of every
step is duly tested lastly project
planning helps in reducing project risk
as planning helps to analyze prioritize
and deal with that risk moving on let's
have a look at the tools for project
planning the first tool that we have is
a Gantt chart today Gantt charts are one
of the most popular project management
tools they help in tracking the status
of the work at a particular time and
their independencies on each other Gantt
charts help in showing different phases
and steps involved in a project the
second tool we will talk about is
critical path method or CPM critical
path method helps in scheduling the
project activities so that the project
runs properly the critical path method
focuses on the longest stretch of
dependent tasks and determines the time
needed to complete them the next tool is
Project evaluation and review technique
or per chart bird provides a graphical
representation of the Project's timeline
explaining the independencies of
different tasks this tool not only helps
in making a schedule but also helps in
coordinating with all the team members
the fourth tool we will check is work
breakdown structure work breakdown
structure is a very common tool that
makes it possible for the team to break
its work into manageable sections work
breakdown structure is a step to step
process that helps in completing the
project efficiently the last tool we
will see is Project documentation
project documentation is an integral
part of the project life cycle project
documentation helps in understanding the
mistakes done during the project and
more importantly provides guidelines for
the upcoming project now when we know
about different tools for project
planning it becomes essential that we
know the necessary steps of project
planning there are seven steps in
Project planning let's have a look at
each of them in detail the first step is
identification of stakeholders as we
have discussed stakeholders could be
anybody they could be a part of the team
or a project manager or a customer when
we identify stakeholders we can find out
the expectations and requirements the
that are to be looked upon in this
project this gives us a clearer picture
of the project and helps in establishing
the Project's goal so the next step we
have is defining the project scope this
helps in determining a list of specific
project goals and deliverables that are
to be achieved during the course of the
project after we have defined the
project scope it is time to set project
objectives and prioritize them the
initial ideas that were there before are
now elaborated and final steps to
complete the project are defined in the
next step the deliverables are
determined after all project
deliverables are the only reason why the
project is being created this step
involves finding out what these
deliverables will be and the deadlines
of the delivery then the step that comes
into picture is creating a project
schedule the project schedule refers to
the guidelines when a particular task is
to be started and when it is supposed to
end this helps in monitoring the growth
of the project and later helps in
generating progress reports the next
step is the step of risk analysis this
step plays an extremely important role
in the success of the overall project it
helps in identifying the risk
prioritizing them and taking steps to
limit them the last step in Project
planning is to generate progress reports
in this step we update the stakeholders
about the project growth and it is done
so that all the concerned team members
can have a look at the progress of the
project after all this information Max
thanks Jack for the explanation and
looks forward to plan projects within
the budget and of better quality in this
session we will talk about project plan
in Excel we will learn about a project
plan and how we can make an effective
plan in Microsoft Excel before we begin
let's have a look at all the topics we
will be covering today first we will see
the basics of a project plan then we
will check the process of project
management Microsoft Excel and why
should one refer to Microsoft Excel
apart from this we will learn about how
to make a Gantt chart in Excel towards
the end we will check some Microsoft
Excel templates so without any further
Ado let's get started let's see what is
a project plan project plan is a basic
thing that is needed to execute a
project according to project management
of knowledge a project can be defined as
an approved collaborative document that
guides the team during project execution
and project control when we are making a
project plan a project plan must answer
several questions for us these questions
are like what are we expecting our
project to deliver how are we expecting
to get our deliverables within the
desired time who all will be a part of a
project and what tasks they will have in
the project when will the project start
and when it is expected to end that is
the deadlines of the project now let us
learn about project management in Excel
Microsoft Excel is one of the most
common application these days it is used
in both offices and at homes Microsoft
Excel is an easy project management tool
that allows the team members to easily
see the tasks in a project develop a
plan and track its progress before we
learn more about project management in
Excel let's first have a look why do we
use Excel Microsoft Excel is an easy
tool to plan a project so it can be used
by people who are beginners in terms of
project management in Excel one can find
several analytical tools like
concatenate Len and counter so this
makes data analysis easy and effective
as the entry of data is easy same is
tracking and controlling our project
status then there are several project
management templates in Excel that help
us to have an effective distribution of
project data we will be checking several
project management templates towards the
end of this video now let's have a look
at the process of making a Gantt chart
in Excel before we begin this it's
important we know what is a Gantt chart
a Gantt chart is like a horizontal bar
chart that is used for project
management with the help of a Gantt
chart we can check the status of the
task the date they start the date the
end and the dependencies on each other
Gantt chart helps in coordinating and
monitoring different tasks in a project
now let's have a look at the steps that
will help us in making a Gantt chart
first step we have is make a project
table we have several rows and columns
like here we have three columns in the
First Column we have the tasks in the
second we have a start date and in the
third column we have the duration or
tenure of the task the second step is to
to make a bar chart in Excel for this we
will select the entire second column
then we will go on the insert Tab and
click on the bar graph chart there we
can select stacked bar graph in 2D bar
charts as a result we will have the
entitled bar graph on the screen in the
third step we will add the duration to
the bar graph we will right click on the
chart and in the menu that appears we
will select select data option a window
that appears on the screen in that
window we will select add option as
shown we can also see the start date is
already in the entry section then in the
dialog box that appears type tenure in
the series name and click on the Range
selection icon that's shown in the
figure now select the relevant data from
the tenure column and click on ok now we
can see a bar graph that has two colors
on the screen this bar graph now has the
duration of the tasks the fourth step we
have is adding description to the Gantt
chart now we will open the box again and
in that box we will select the edit
option as shown in the figure then we
will select the tasks as we had selected
the duration of the tasks before and
click on OK we can now see the tasks
have appeared towards the left side of
the Gantt chart the fifth and the
remarkable step will help us convert
this bar graph into a Gantt chart we
will now click on the bars and select
the format data series option from the
menu that appears then in the format
data series dialog box we will select no
fill option we can find our Gantt chart
on the screen now in accordance with the
data that we had entered now we can see
the tasks on the left side are in the
reverse order so what we will do next is
we will click on the task panel then go
to the format access dialog box and
select the categories in reverse order
option now we can find a task in the
right order one more thing we can notice
is Gantt chart is starting with some
other date and not with the dates that
we had entered so for this we will copy
the first date in some other cell then
clicking on the copied cell we will go
to the home menu to select the dialog
box as shown in the figure then in that
drop down menu we will select the number
option we can now find a value displayed
in the copied cell we'll copy that value
click on the dates on the chart and add
the format access dialog box opens you
will paste that value in the box that
says minimum shown in the figure as a
result we will have our final Gantt
chart on the screen in the last step we
can give several designs to a Gantt
chart change colors and make it more
presentable for us now when we know the
basic steps of making a Gantt chart I
will show that practically to you in
Microsoft Excel our first step is to
open Microsoft Excel and in Microsoft
Excel we will make a project table in a
project table we will have three columns
the First Column will be task the second
column will have the start date the
third column will have tenure or the
duration of the task so beginning with
tasks we have task one in Task 1 we have
1.1 1.2 1.3 then comes task 2. in task 2
we have 2.1 2.2 2.3 and 2.4 then we have
task 3 in task 3 we will have two
subsections 3.1 and 3 point 2 then we
will start with the starting dates in
starting dates we'll put 1st January the
Task 1 1.1 will be first of January then
this will be 4th January let's say this
is 5th January then we will put this as
11th of January and this will be again
11th January only this will be 15th
January let's put this as 17th January
let this be 19th January task 3 begins
on 23rd January
and it the 3.2 section begins at 26th of
January now let's put the tenure or the
duration of the task we will begin with
task 1. it takes 12 days then 1.1 takes
7 days we say this takes four days and
this takes 8 days then for task 2 it
again takes 12 days it takes 5 days 5
days and let's say this takes 6 days and
this takes four days then we come to
task three this takes eight days and
let's say this takes six days and the
3.2 section takes five days so this is
how a project table is ready in the
second step we will select the entire
second column after we have selected
this column we will go to the insert tab
in the insert tab we'll go to the bar
columns and in this we will select 2D
stacked bar charts now we have the
entitle bar chart in accordance to our
data on the screen then comes the third
step we will add the duration of the
tasks to the bar graph we will click on
the chart and after we click on the
chart we will select select data option
in the select data source dialog box we
find the start date is already there now
we will click on ADD and after we click
on add in the series name section we
will put tenure then in the series value
we will click on this icon and select
the entire tenure series and click on OK
so this is the bar graph that we have
now this is now in two colors the orange
color and the blue color this bar graph
now has the duration of all the tasks in
our project table now in the fourth step
now it's time for us to add description
to our Gantt chart instead of this one
two three four five we will put Task 1
task 2 and the sub tasks so what we will
do is we will again go to that box we
will left click on the Gantt chart
select the select data option and then
we'll go to the start date here we'll
select the edit option in the edit
option we will select all the tasks and
click on ok now we can see all the tasks
are aligned towards the left of the bar
chart as we can see this is a bar chart
or a bar graph and not a Gantt chart the
next step we have is converting this bar
graph into a Gantt chart so we will
click on the bars and select the format
data series option from the menu that
appears here we have this format data
series option now we can see the dialog
box on the screen here we'll go into the
color section fill section and then we
will select no fill now we can see the
blue lines have disappeared so this
looks like a Gantt chart so now when we
have a Gantt chart on the screen we can
notice that the task here are in the
reverse order so what we will do is we
will click on these tasks and select the
format access option here we will select
categories in reverse order we can see
our Gantt chart is now in order like we
have a task one on the top and task 3 at
the bottom the dates are starting from
11th of December but the dates we have
provided are from 1st of January now we
will copy this cell then go on the dates
box here we'll go to format access in
the format access we can see minimum in
this minimum we will paste this value
and press enter as we press enter we can
see our Gantt chart starting from the
date that we wanted to start and that
too in the correct order starting from
Task 1 to task 3. now as a result we
have our final Gantt chart on the screen
in the last step what we can do is make
our Gantt chart more representable we
can change the color of These Bars we
can give them shapes and we can do many
other things to make it more presentable
we will first select the bars like what
we will do is we will select Task 1 and
let's say we give it the color blue then
task 2 we will give it color green and
in task 3 we'll give it give it the
color black so here the sub sections
will give different colors to to the
subsections as well then we come to task
2.1 this is how we can change the color
of these cells or apart from changing
colors we can select a bar graph and do
the gradient fill so this is how we can
make a Gantt chart more presentable
after changing the colors or changing
the shapes we have our final Gantt chart
on the screen finally let's have a look
at some Microsoft Excel templates for
project management Microsoft Excel
templates help in collecting data
putting them into order and check the
dependencies with each other with the
help of these templates we can monitor
the status of the tasks and we can also
check the progress our project has made
moving forth we will check some
important Microsoft Excel templates the
first template we have is Excel project
review template this template helps us
have an overview of the project we can
have a clear understanding of all the
tasks that are planned and that are
completed this helps project managers to
measure the progress of the project and
take further steps accordingly second
template we will check is Excel budget
template in this template late we can
monitor all the expenditures of our
project it helps us in managing the
budget of a project and also helps in
comparing the budget of a project at
different phases let's have a look at
the budget template in Excel ones we can
download this template from Office
timeline.com the Gans are towards the
right is in accordance with the dates
towards the left if you fluctuate the
date we can see the template working the
start date for Task 1 could be changed
to 10th June if we change this date to
10 June we can see the fluctuation in
the Gantt chart so this is how we can
use this template directly let's have a
look at the third template now third
template we will see is Excel Sprint
Project tracker template this template
is used majorly in agile projects where
the project is made in several streams
or sessions this template includes the
start date the end date and the duration
of each task we can also see the
percentage completed of each task let's
have a look at this print project
tracker template as well we can see the
Gantt chart towards the right and the
data towards the left so if we change
any data we can see the Giants are
changing for example we can change the
data in Sprint to feature 3. let's
change the start date to July 2nd we can
see the Gantt chart changing this is how
we can use this template directly to
track our sessions let's have a look at
the fourth Excel template this template
is Excel project tracker in this
template we have the data of all the
tasks with the status and owners we can
track the percentage of tasks completed
and also compare the plan duration of
the task to the actual duration of the
task after the critical part tracker
let's check the Excel project schedule
template this template helps in
effective management of the project as
it helps in monitoring the time that
each task of the project takes it
provides a clear view of all the work
associated with the project let's have a
look at this template in Excel once we
can see the Gantt chart in accordance to
the data if we change the estimated as
at two places let's say at the design
review we make it 15 hours instead of 5
hours and at the create Staffing plan
and we make it 2 hours instead of 20
hours we can see the Gantt chart
fluctuating this is how we can use this
template to manage the schedule in a
project moving forward the next template
we will see is Excel project status
report template this template helps us
having a list of project deliverables
and the risks associated with that
project this template helps the project
managers about different crucial
activities involved in a project after
this we have Excel Milestone tracker the
Milestone tracker helps us in tracking
or monitoring different tasks in a
project project managers use this
template to monitor the project
performance with respect to the
timelines the last template we will see
is Excel project planner Excel project
planner includes a list of tasks with
the respected owners along with the
start date and the end date of that task
this helps in monitoring each task and
comparing the estimated task date with
the actual ones let's have a look at
this template in Excel we can see the
Gantt chart with respect to the data
entered let's make changes at several
places in the data we can make this 22
to 24 we will make this 23 go to 2 and
we can make this 5th September go to 15
September and when we make the changes
we can realize the Gantt chart is
fluctuating so this is how we can use
this template to plan a project
effectively and efficiently in this
lesson we will focus on Project time
management let us begin with the
objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to
Define project time management explain
project schedule Gantt charts and
network diagrams identify the key terms
used in Project time management
describe the project time management
processes explain various schedule
network analysis techniques
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the third
knowledge area that is Project time
management and its processes let us
begin with the first topic of this
lesson project time management
the purpose of project time management
is to ensure that the projects get
completed on time
this knowledge area is primarily
concerned with developing a project
schedule and ensuring that project goes
as per the agreed schedule
if there is a need to change the project
schedule the change should happen by
following a proper change control
procedure another term used in the PMP
examination is schedule management plan
schedule management plan is part of the
project management plan and has
information on the planned project
schedule and its management and control
let us discuss the Key activities of
project time management in the next
screen
the Key activities that are part of the
project time management include
identifying activities estimating time
and resources and sequencing activities
it is important to identify a list of
activities that would be a part of the
project next an estimation of time and
resources required for completing the
identified activities are done
finally these activities need to be
sequenced as per the dependencies in the
next screen let us discuss project
schedule
project schedule represents the time
dimension of the project plan and has
information like when the project would
start when each of the project
activities would happen in what order
the project activities would happen when
project would be completed
Etc
usually Software System is used to
develop the project schedule
the project team can enter the list of
activities in the software as well as
their dependencies and the software can
produce the project schedule as the
output Microsoft Project is the most
popular tool used for project schedule
development generally project schedule
is considered similar to project
management plan
project management plan is different
from Project schedule project management
plan not only has information about the
Project's schedule but also other
important project related plans like
Risk Management Plan cost management
plan
Etc let us focus on Gantt chart in the
next screen
Gantt chart is a type of bar chart that
illustrates a project schedule it shows
the dependencies between the project
activities as well as their percent
completion
a sample Gantt chart is shown on the
screen
two summary elements of the work
breakdown structure are depicted to
complete those elements there are a
number of activities under them some of
these activities have dependencies for
example activity B and C have a
dependency activity C can start only
when activity B is completed
the chart gives you an idea about when
specific activities are planned to
finish and when the overall WBS element
will get delivered create tasks and work
with the Gantt chart this will make
answering Gantt chart-based questions
easy and fun in the next screen let us
understand the relationships that exist
among project activities
Network diagram is extensively used in
the project time management knowledge
area to plot the activity dependencies
this is a graphical representation of
the project activities in the form of a
network
there are two ways to draw a network
diagram
in precedence diagramming model PDM or
activity on node Aon boxes represent
activities and the arrows indicate the
dependency this type of network can have
all four types of relationships between
the activities
in Arrow diagramming model ADM or
activity on Arrow AOA the arrows
represent activities the relationships
and sequences can be inferred from the
direction of the arrows and linkages
between the activities
and such types of network only finish to
start relationships can be shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dummy activities to indicate some
dependency between the activities
there may be questions in the PMP exam
based on the network diagram so create
and work with the diagram this will make
answering Network diagram based
questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us look at a
network diagram
a sample Network diagram is shown on the
screen activities A and C can happen in
parallel B and D require both A and C to
complete whereas e requires both B and D
to complete activity on Arrow Network
diagram makes use of hammock activities
they are used to show a comprehensive
summary activity combining several other
activities underneath for control and
Reporting purposes in the next screen
let us look at a few important terms in
time management
when a successor activity can start
before the predecessor activity can
complete it is considered lead for
example you can start preparing the test
environment two weeks before the
development activity finishes
when the successor activity has to wait
for a few days after the predecessor
activity has been completed it is
considered lag for example one needs to
wait for two days for the foundation to
settle before work on the pillars for
the next floor starts
rolling wave planning is an iterative
planning technique in which the work to
be accomplished in the near term is
planned in detail while the work in the
future is planned at a higher level it
is a form of progressive elaboration
in the context of estimating techniques
analogous estimating is based on the
previous project data therefore if the
last five similar projects took six
months to complete the next one will
also take six months this technique
employs expert judgment
another estimating technique is
parametric estimating this technique
uses a mathematical model to calculate
projected time for an activity based on
the historical records from previous
projects and other information
a few common parameters are identified
based on the previous project data and
that parameter is used to predict the
time required to complete the next
activity or project for example you can
normally complete 10 kilometers of
Highway construction Lanes a week
effort is the total amount of work
required to complete the activity
duration is the amount of time it takes
in terms of elapsed or calendar days if
you have an activity that requires 10
people to work for five days the total
effort is 50 person days but the
duration is only five days
in the next screen let us look at the
project time management processes
there are seven project time management
processes they are plan schedule
management define activities sequence
activities estimate activity resources
estimate activity durations develop
schedule and control schedule
the first six processes are executed
during the planning process group the
ultimate goal of these planning
processes is to develop the project
schedule the seventh and the last
process is a part of the monitoring and
controlling process group
in the next few screens let us discuss
these processes in detail we will begin
with plan schedule management
as defined in pmbok guide plan schedule
management is the process of
establishing the policies procedures and
documentation for planning developing
managing executing and controlling the
project schedule
it belongs to the planning process group
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the project management plan provides
other subsidiary plans and will guide
the schedule planning activities on the
project
the project Charter provides an overall
context and the high-level product and
project description which might help
determine the approach for schedule
management few projects might have
scheduling constraint for example
projects of Olympics 2016 should be
completed at the same time
Enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project including the culture of the
organization the infrastructure like
scheduling systems available key
personnel and so on
organizational process assets provide
inputs such as policies and procedures
templates past performance data and
estimates historical information and
knowledge base now let us look at the
tools and techniques employed in this
process
expert judgment refers to input received
from knowledgeable and experienced
resources
experts can draw from their previous
experiences the proper approach to
govern the schedule on a project
meetings may be organized to determine
the schedule management plan
anybody responsible for the project
schedule management such as the project
manager sponsor customer and other
stakeholders must attend these meetings
several analytical techniques may be
used to determine the schedule
management plan these may include
different planning approaches and
philosophies such as rolling wave
planning or different scheduling
software that allow to build what-if
scenarios and study the effect of
advanced scheduling techniques like
leveling fast tracking and crashing
now let us look at the outputs of this
process
schedule management plan is a component
of the project management plan that
describes the criteria and activities
required to arrive at the project
schedule as well as how the project may
be baselined monitored and controlled
in the next screen let us define
activities process
define activities is the process of
identifying the specific actions to be
performed to produce the project
deliverables it belongs to the planning
process group the important input for
the define activities process is the
scope Baseline scope Baseline is a term
used collectively to refer to project
deliverables constraints and assumptions
of the project
in addition to the scope Baseline the
other inputs in this process are
Enterprise environmental factors
organizational process assets and
schedule management plan
a reason why Enterprise environmental
factors is an input to define activities
is because the organization might be
using project management software to
define activities and that may influence
the activity definition process
the knowledge base containing historical
information regarding activities lists
used by previous similar projects is a
good example of organization process
assets applied to scheduling
the tools and techniques used in
defining activities are decomposition
and rolling wave planning the last
technique is expert judgment where the
experience of project team members is
used in developing detailed activity
lists
the output of the process is activity
list activity attributes and Milestone
list
activity list contains a list of
identified activities activity
attributes are the additional
information about the activity itself
a milestone is a significant point or
event in the project a milestone list
identifies all the milestones and
indicates whether the Milestone is
mandatory or optional
let us move on to the next process
sequence activities
sequence activities is the process of
identifying and documenting
relationships among the project
activities and is also part of the
planning process group
for every activity and Milestone except
the first and last one is connected to
or at least one predecessor and one
successor
the inputs to this process are activity
list activity attributes and Milestone
list all these are the outputs of the
Define activity process
the other inputs are schedule management
plan and project scope statement
schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
organization process assets are also an
input to sequencing activities because
the organization might have some kind of
knowledge base for scheduling project
activities
the Enterprise environmental factors
relevant to this process may be
scheduling Tools in use project
management information systems work
authorization systems Etc
one of the important tools and
techniques used in sequencing activities
is the Precedence diagramming method
in this method the activities are drawn
on a network diagram and all the
different kinds of dependencies between
the activities are determined
while determining activity dependency it
is important to identify the type of
relationship or dependency between the
activities
the other technique is leads and lag
which is widely used for sequencing
activities
the output of the process is the project
schedule Network diagram which is a
graphical representation of the project
activities in a form of network which
also shows the activity dependencies
while designing the network diagram new
activities might be identified and that
would result in some of the project
document updates especially the ones
that list all the project activities
in the next screen let us look at the
estimate activity resources process
after sequencing the activities the next
step in Project time management is
estimating the resources required to
accomplish each of the identified
activities estimate activity resources
process also belongs to the planning
process group
here resources do not mean only the
human resources but includes all other
resources like equipment raw materials
Machinery Etc
schedule management plan is the first
input schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
the other inputs to this process are an
activity list and activity attributes
that are the outputs of the time
management processes
risk register is another input risks to
the project May influence the decisions
about the resources that need to be
deployed hence risk register becomes an
input to this project
in addition activity cost estimates are
another input cost and resource
estimates on a project are interrelated
and influence each other
for example the cost might dictate the
number and type of resources that can be
employed or the time might dictate the
cost that may need to be incurred
along with this the resource calendar is
also an important input because it has
the information about the availability
of each of the resources
some of the Enterprise environmental
factors that can influence estimating
activity resources are availability of
required resources within the
organization
the organizational process assets is
also an important input as the
organization might have standard
policies for Staffing or for hiring
contractors on the project
with all these inputs available for
estimating activity resources there are
various techniques used for estimating
the required resources the first
technique is using expert judgment
in this technique an expert in resource
planning and estimating can estimate
each of the activities
the next technique used is alternative
analysis in this the activities are
analyzed to identify different ways of
completing them this is to ensure only
the required resources are assigned to
each of the activities this helps in
resource optimization
along with the two techniques many
organizations routinely publish their
estimating data and this could be used
in activity resource estimation
another technique that is routinely used
in activity estimation is bottom-up
estimating which is decomposing the
activity further down to understand it
in more detail and estimating at that
level later all such estimates are added
to arrive at the estimate of the
activity
in real projects one has to use all the
estimate each of the activities
sometimes the project management
software also helps in estimating
the software estimates are based on the
inputs provided to It software should
only be considered as a supporting tool
in estimation and never fully rely on
its output
clearly the output of this process is
the activity resource requirements along
with this resource breakdown structure
is also prepared the resource breakdown
structure is the categorization of all
the required resources in various
categories that is human resources
equipment raw materials
Etc
in the process of estimation several
other project documents may also be
updated
for example the resource estimates are
directly correlated with cost estimates
let us now move on to the next process
estimate activity durations
the next process is to estimate the
duration required to complete each of
the activities
the duration estimation should be done
by someone who is familiar with the
project for example the same activity if
done by a high skilled resource would
take less time compared to a less
skilled resource
this may vary regardless of the resource
used due to the project requirements
in addition the activity duration
estimation should be updated
continuously as you move ahead with the
project because as the project
progresses there will be more clarity on
the project the inputs of this process
are similar to the ones in sequence
activities process
schedule management plan is the first
input schedule management plan provides
guidance in terms of methodology to be
employed for many of the scheduling
activities on the project
for instance it may contain information
about the estimation techniques to be
employed and the people who need to be
involved in the estimation process
activity resource requirements is also
an input to this process because
resources assigned to an activity would
significantly affect the activity
duration that is the lower skilled
resources would take more time than the
high-skilled resources
the other inputs include activity list
activity attributes and resource
breakdown structure
resource calendars are also an input to
this process the type and skill set of
resources available to the team may have
an impact on the time it would take to
complete the activities
risks to the project May influence the
decisions about the time required to
complete the activity hence risk
register becomes an input to this
process
the project scope statement defines the
constraints and assumptions affecting
the project duration
an example of Enterprise environmental
factor that can affect duration is
organization's productivity metrics
which is collected based on the
experiences from multiple projects
the last input in this process is
organizational process assets
now let us look at the tools and
techniques used for estimating activity
durations first is the expert judgment
which means using previous project
experiences and estimating the current
project duration this can be used with
other estimation techniques and used to
reconcile differences if different
techniques result in different estimates
three-point estimating is a method where
three estimates are used instead of one
it is part of a project management
philosophy known as program evaluation
and review technique pert
estimating activity durations is often
done as a team exercise as each activity
may require multiple skill sets to be
applied
therefore it is important to use group
decision making techniques to arrive at
a consensus or at least an estimate that
is acceptable to all the team members
Reserve analysis adds buffer into the
project schedule to deal with any
uncertainty the contingency reserve may
be added as a percentage of the activity
duration or fixed number of work periods
the other tools and techniques are
analogous estimating and parametric
estimating
the outputs of this process are the
activity duration estimates and project
documents updates
the activity duration estimates is
represented in terms of the range of
possible results for example 10 days
plus minus two days that is the activity
would take minimum eight days and
maximum 12 days in the next screen let
us look into a business scenario to
understand this concept butter
after reading the problem statement
click the solution button to look at a
possible answer
develop schedule is the process of
analyzing activity sequences durations
resource requirements and schedule
constraints to create the project
schedule
it belongs to the planning process group
generally scheduling software is used
for developing the project schedule
entering the activities durations and
resources into a scheduling tool
generates a schedule with planned dates
for completing project activities
developing a project schedule is an
iterative process revising and
maintaining a realistic schedule is a
task in itself and it continues
throughout the project as the work
progresses
the most of the inputs of this process
are the outputs of estimate activity
durations process
they are risk register project scope
statement project staff assignments
resources calendars organizational
process assets
Enterprise environmental factors
schedule management plan activity list
activity attributes project schedule
Network diagrams activity resource
requirements resource breakdown
structure and activity duration
estimates
various tools and techniques are used to
develop schedule process
schedule network analysis is a technique
that generates project schedule
it employs various analytical techniques
such as critical path method critical
chain method
modeling techniques and resource
optimization techniques to create the
project schedule
the other tools and techniques include
leads and lags schedule compression and
scheduling tool
let us now look at the outputs of this
process
the project schedule consists of a
minimum plan start date and planned
finish date for each activity
although project schedule can be
represented in tabular format it is more
often represented graphically using
either bar charts or network diagrams or
a combination of the two
the final schedule which is the output
of the developed schedule process is
also called schedule Baseline once the
schedule is baselined it can be changed
only through formal approvals meeting
the schedule Baseline is one of the
measures of project success
scheduled data produced may include
number of resources key Milestones Etc
project calendar specify the available
working days and the number of shifts in
each day it indicates how many hours and
days are available for the work of the
project to be completed
project management plan updates are a
result of the develop schedule process
many of the other subsidiary plans of
the project plan may get impacted which
may include cost management plan scope
management plan risk management plan Etc
this may also result in other project
documents being updated
in the next few screens let us discuss
schedule network analysis techniques
it is essential to know if the required
resources are available at that time
along with the time estimate of each of
the activities
since schedule is calendar based it
helps in estimating the same
schedule network analysis technique
generates project schedule there are
various schedule Network techniques
critical path method relies on
determining the critical path on a
project schedule
critical chain method is a variant of
the critical path method wherein the
critical chain is determined based on
The Logical resource and other kinds of
dependencies between the activities
what if scenario analysis is about
trying to vary a certain parameter to
observe the impact on the schedule for
instance you may want to check result if
you put in more resources on a
particular activity to reduce its
duration
resource optimization techniques try to
arrive at the optimal utilization of the
resources used on a project
ideally you would want the resources to
be fully utilized but you would also
want to build in sufficient buffers in
case a certain resource is not available
due to various reasons
in the next screen let us look at the
program evaluation and review technique
is based on three-point estimates for an
activity
the pessimistic estimate refers to the
worst case scenario
whereas most likely estimate is what you
expect to happen in a realistic scenario
the optimistic estimate on the other
hand represents the amount of time an
activity would take in the best case
scenario
based on these three estimates the
expected duration of the estimate is
calculated as per the formula given on
the screen
the formula for calculating standard
deviation of an activity and variance of
an activity is also given
there is no question asked on variance
but the formula is important because if
the standard deviation of the whole
project is to be calculated the process
is to calculate the variance of the
whole project and then take its square
root to calculate the standard deviation
of the project
concept-based questions on pert can be
expected in the PMP exam so make a note
of the formula while you prepare for the
exam
in the next screen let us understand
pert with an example
let us now figure out how we can apply
the three-point estimation that pert
uses in order to draw some useful
conclusions
assume that the optimistic pessimistic
and most likely estimates are 20 70 and
30 respectively using these values you
can determine the expected duration and
the standard deviation as indicated
now if the causes of variation are
random you can assume that the actual
values would be evenly distributed about
the mean and we'll follow the normal
distribution sometimes referred to as
the bell curve further you can use the
properties of the normal distribution
there is a 68 probability of the actual
value falling within first Sigma from
the mean
95.4 probability for the second Sigma
and 99.7 probability of the actual value
falling within third Sigma extending
this Logic the notion of Six Sigma is
reaching a level of confidence that only
3.4 times out of a million would the
actual value fall outside the stated
range pert allows you to plan based on
the intended level of confidence in the
outcome and determined buffers
accordingly
let us discuss the critical path method
in the next screen
critical path is defined as the longest
duration path through a network diagram
which determines the shortest time to
complete the project float can be
considered as a buffer time available to
complete an activity
float is calculated once the network
diagram is ready
it is also called as slack there are
three kinds of float the first being the
total float which is the amount of time
an activity can be delayed without
delaying the project end date or an
intermediary milestone
the second type of float is free float
which is the amount of time an activity
can be delayed without delaying the
early start date of its successor or
successor's activities
the last type is independent float which
is the amount of time an activity can be
delayed if all the predecessors finish
at their latest finish dates and you
want to start all the immediate
successors at their earliest start dates
the slack of the activities on the
critical path is zero because there is
no scope to delay activities on the
critical path
critical path actually represents the
project duration delaying activities on
the critical path is as good as delaying
the project duration
concept-based questions on critical path
can be expected in the exam so it is
essential to have a clear understanding
of the concept
in the next screen let us learn how to
calculate float
float of an activity can be calculated
by two methods however the first step in
critical path method is to identify the
critical path of the network once the
critical path is identified follow the
forward pass to find early start and
early finish for each activity
the float of the activities on the
critical path is zero so they represent
the overall project duration
use forward pass or backward pass to
calculate the total activity time
calculate late finish and late start
using backward pass method note the
total float formula before you start for
the exam
in the next screen let us look at
forward pass and backward pass methods
in detail
in forward pass you can either go
through the network starting with time 0
and keep calculating the time required
to complete each of the activities until
you reach the last activity of the
project
the starting time for each of the
activity in this approach is called
early start and the end time for each
activity is called the early finish
alternatively in backward pass you can
travel through the network from the
project end date and calculate the time
required to complete each activity
the end date in this approach is called
the late finish and the start date of
the activity in this approach is called
the late start
the float of the activity is either the
difference between the late start and
early start or the difference between
the late finish and early finish
both the differences work out to be the
same before the start of the PMP exam
please make a note of the total float
formula
let us understand the critical path
calculation with an example in the next
screen
let us look at an example for critical
path
there are five activities in this
project and two paths in the network
diagram start 1 2 4 5 and is One path
and start one three five and is the
second path since the duration of the
path start one two four five and is 18
days which is more than the duration of
the path start 1 3 5 and the critical
path of the project is start one two
four five end
let us take Activity three as an example
first calculate the early start and
early finish dates
Activity 3 can start only after Activity
one since the early finish of Activity 1
is 3 it becomes the early start of
Activity three
Activity 3 cannot start earlier than 3
because Activity 1 can be completed only
by then
therefore early start of Activity 3 is
3. since the duration of the activity is
four days
the early finish of Activity 3 is 3 plus
4 equals seven days
now let us calculate the late start and
late finish of activity 3.
late start of Activity 5 is 14 days the
Activity 3 happens just before activity
5. so the late finish of Activity 3 is
14 days to calculate the late start you
can subtract the duration from late
finish therefore the late start of
Activity 3 is 14 minus 4 equals ten
in the next screen let us focus on
schedule compression
look at the four activities in the table
the normal cost of executing each of the
activities as well as how much each of
the activities can be crashed is also
provided
which activity would you crash to reduce
the project Time by one day
activity a will be crashed if the
duration of the project is reduced by
one day as the per unit cost of crashing
the activity a is the least
all the activities are assumed to be on
the critical path here while crashing if
you end up Saving Time on a path which
is not the critical path you will not
end up Saving Time on the project
in the next screen let us look into the
impact of schedule compression
different schedule compression
techniques have different impact on the
project
the impact of Fast Track leads to risk
additions and increase in management
time for the project manager
crash leads to cost addition and
increase in management time for the
project manager
reduce scope on the other hand saves
cost and resources but increases
customer dissatisfaction
likewise cut quality saves cost and
resources but increases risk
resource reallocation does not add cost
or increase risk
in the next screen let us look into the
other techniques used in scheduling
there are several techniques that are
used in scheduling projects
what if scenario analysis in this
technique questions like what if a
particular scenario changed on the
project would that produce a shorter
schedule are put forth to understand the
impact of specific changes on the
schedule the goal is to produce a
realistic schedule
Monte Carlo analysis in this method a
computer simulates the outcomes of a
project making use of randomly generated
values that map the probability
distribution of the input variables
together these two techniques are called
modeling techniques
resource optimization techniques
these are also used to produce a
resource Limited schedule resource
optimization results in more stable
number of resources used in the project
critical chain method this technique
develops the project schedule that takes
into account both the activity and
resource dependencies
in the next screen let us look at the
last process in Project time management
control schedule
control schedule is concerned with
determining the status of the project
schedule determining that the project
schedule has changed and managing the
actual changes as they occur
the project schedule is an important
input to this process it is the actual
schedule that needs to be controlled
scheduled data contains information
related to the schedule that may need to
be monitored in order to take actions to
bring the project back on schedule
project calendar describes the working
hours and days for the project
work performance data has information
like which activities have started their
progress and which activities have
finished
the other inputs of this process are
project management plan and
organizational process assets
the key tools and techniques of this
process are the performance reviews
performance review is measuring
comparing and analyzing schedule
performance such as actual start and
finish dates percent complete and
remaining duration for work in progress
the other tools and techniques include
resource optimization techniques
modeling techniques schedule compression
leads and lags scheduling tool and
project management software
in development schedule process these
techniques are used for the first time
to develop the project schedule whereas
in control schedule process these
techniques are used to update the
project schedule the key output of the
control schedule process is the work
performance information this is
represented in the form of schedule
variants SV and schedule performance
index SPI
as a part of the control schedule
process the project team will generate
forecasts likely schedule for
forthcoming activities and project as a
whole
the other outputs include organizational
process assets updates change requests
project management plan updates and
project document updates in the next
screen let us look into a business
scenario to understand this concept
better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project time management includes the
processes required to manage the timely
completion of the project
a project schedule defines the start and
end dates of the project and the project
activities these activities are assigned
a duration and sequenced in a logical
order
Gantt charts and network diagrams are
used to identify project activities and
determine the relationships and
dependencies between them get chart
displays the start and end dates of
project activities the overall project
schedule and The Logical task
relationships while Network diagram is
used to plot the activity dependencies
plan schedule management define
activities sequence activities estimate
activity resources estimate activity
durations develop schedule and control
schedule are the seven processes under
project time management
schedule network analysis technique
generates project schedule based on the
estimates of time and resource
requirements in this lesson we will
focus on Project cost management let us
begin with the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to Define project cost management
differentiate between cost estimation
and cost budgeting explain control
accounts describe the project cost
management processes
apply earned value management technique
to track project performance
identify key terminologies used in
Project cost management
in the next screen let us take a quick
look at the project management process
map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
fourth knowledge area that is Project
cost management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of project cost management
project cost management involves
activities like estimating the cost of
each of the project activities adding
the cost estimates of the related
activities to arrive at the cost budget
and controlling the cost to ensure that
project activities are completed within
the defined budget in the next screen
let us discuss cost management plan
the cost management plan is a vital step
in Project cost management it contains
information like planning the project
cost managing and controlling the
project in relation to the cost Baseline
and managing cost variances project cost
management plan is a part of the project
management plan
the methods used in estimating the cost
of each of the project activities are
similar to the ones used in estimating
project time for example time estimation
methods like expert judgment analogous
estimating bottom-up estimating and
Reserve analysis are few of the
techniques that are also used in
estimating activity cost let us discuss
control account in the next screen
control account is an important Concept
in the project cost management project
cost is generally estimated at
individual activity level
it becomes difficult to manage cost at
the activity level in large projects
therefore the cost is managed at a
higher level this requires related
activities to be clubbed and their cost
being managed together as one unit this
unit is called control account
while estimating the project time WBS is
created to break down the project into
smaller deliverables these deliverables
are broken down into work packages and
these work packages are in turn broken
into activities control account is
defined at a level higher than the work
packages for example if five work
packages are part of the one control
account the cost of all activities
belonging to these five work packages
are managed as one unit
in the next screen let us discuss the
project cost management process
project cost management has four
processes
they are plan cost management estimate
costs determined budget and control
costs
the three processes Plan cost management
estimate costs and determined budget are
a part of planning process group and
control cost process is a part of
monitoring and controlling process group
let us look at each of these processes
in detail
let us begin with the first process that
is Plan cost Management in the next
screen
managing costs on a project is a
critical exercise if the activities are
planned well it becomes easier to
achieve harmony with the overall cost
and budget of the project Plan cost
management is the process of
establishing the policies procedures and
documentation for planning managing
expending and controlling the project
costs let us look at the inputs required
for this process
the project management plan provides
other subsidiary plans and guides the
cost planning activities on the project
the project Charter provides an overall
context and high-level product and
project description
which help determine the approach for
cost management for example for some
projects budget could be a constraint
whereas for others budget would not be a
constraint but subject to the other
objectives
Enterprise environmental factors provide
the organizational context to the
project including the culture of the
organization and the infrastructure for
instance the scheduling systems
available the key personnel and so on
organizational process assets provide
inputs such as policies and procedures
templates past performance data and
estimates historical information and
knowledge base
now let us look at the tools and
techniques employed in this process
expert judgment refers to input received
from knowledgeable and experienced
resources
experts can devise an approach to govern
the costs on a project by using their
previous experiences
meetings may be organized to determine
the cost management plan everyone
responsible for the project schedule
management such as the project manager
representatives from the appropriate
accounting or financial organization
sponsor customer and other stakeholders
must attend these meetings
several analytical techniques may be
used to determine the cost management
plan these techniques help to map the
impact of various decisions on cost for
example how do risk management processes
impact cost
Etc
cost management plan is the primary
output of this process it establishes
the units of measure levels of precision
organizational process links control
accounts to be used rules for
performance measurement and Reporting
frequency and methodology of monitoring
the costs and various other details that
lay the overall framework for cost
Management on a project
in the next screen let us discuss the
second process under project cost
management
estimate cost
estimate cost is the approximation of
the monetary resources required to
complete a project activity
cost of a specific activity is estimated
based on the information available at
that point of time as the project team
gets more information about the project
the activity cost estimation may change
let us look at the inputs of this
process
scope Baseline is the most important
input as it details out the Project's
scope of work
along with that project schedule is also
important this contains information like
when and which resource is required for
the project
it is good to remember that the same
kind of resources may have different
costs at different points of time
Human Resource Management plan is
another important input various elements
like Personnel rates Rewards or
recognition programs Etc are covered in
the human resource management plan which
is important in approximating the cost
estimate Human Resource Management plan
will be discussed in detail in the human
resource management knowledge area
risk register is also an input because
risk mitigation costs should be
considered in cost planning more
information on risk and its effect in
the project will be looked at in detail
in Risk Management knowledge area
another input Enterprise environmental
factors provides organizational context
to the project
organization process asset is listed as
an input as organizations might have
standard set of cost estimation policies
or templates
cost management plan is another
important input the cost management plan
lays the framework for the cost
management processes in the project
it provides guidelines such as the units
of measure accuracy desired
methodologies and tools to be used Etc
let us now look at the tools and
techniques used in this process
expert judgment Reserve analysis
analogous estimating cost of quality
parametric estimating project management
software bottom-up estimating
three-point estimating vendor bid
analysis and group decision making are
the various tools and techniques used in
this process most of the tools and
techniques used here are similar to the
ones used in the time management
knowledge area
vendor bid analysis is a technique used
to estimate project cost
for example a project requires material
procured externally through suppliers in
order to get that you invite bids from
three or four suppliers and assess their
quotations based on their quotations you
can get an idea of the cost that will be
involved in getting the material for the
project
group decision making technique is
another important technique for project
cost estimation
cost estimation is an exercise which may
be carried out by a group or Committee
in order to gather well-rounded input
therefore group decision making
techniques may be used to arrive at a
decision that team can work with
the outputs of this process are quite
straightforward
estimates of each of the activities are
arrived at basis of the estimate
includes things like how the estimate
was developed what were the assumptions
made in estimating Etc
project document updates is also one of
the outputs because the cost estimates
may result in updates to other aspects
of the project for example quality risk
time
Etc
in the next screen let us discuss the
third process under project cost
management determined budget
once the estimate of each of the
activities is arrived at the next
project cost management process is to
determine budget
it is the process of aggregating the
estimated costs of individual activities
or work packages to establish an
authorized cost Baseline this is where
the control account concept comes into
picture
the estimated costs of the activities
are aggregated to arrive at the cost
budget at the control account level
once approved this cost budget becomes
the cost Baseline of the project
project cost performance is measured
against the cost Baseline that is how
much more would the project cost be
compared to the original cost Baseline
the cost Baseline includes all
authorized budgets but excludes
management Reserves
the inputs used in determining the
project budgets are the activity cost
estimates and the basis of estimates
which are the output of the previous
cost management process
the cost management plan lays the
framework for the cost management
processes in the project it provides
guidelines such as the budgeting cycle
tools and techniques used to prepare and
approve the budget
Etc
in addition to these two important
inputs scope Baseline is also looked at
project schedule provides aggregate cost
in a particular calendar period to
ensure how much money can be made
available during that time
similarly resource calendar provides
information on the resource which is
assigned to the project at a particular
point of time this information is then
used to indicate resource costs over the
duration of the project
risk register gives an understanding of
the overall level of risk on the project
and therefore the level of contingency
reserves that need to be built into the
budget
agreements entered into what the
suppliers are also required to finalize
the budget again organizational process
asset is an input because organization
may have few policies for reporting the
cost budget or there might be some cost
budgeting tools being used there are
various tools and techniques used in
determining budgets
cost aggregation technique involves
adding up the cost and aggregating them
at the control account level so that the
cost can be managed in a better way
in reserve analysis once the costs are
estimated some extra amount is added to
the estimate as a management Reserve to
take care of any unplanned activities
expert judgment is a technique in which
an expert's help is sought to estimate
the activity cost expert is someone who
might have worked on a similar project
in the past and has a good idea to
estimate the activity cost involved
historical relationships are used to
predict the total project costs using
mathematical model
this is similar to analogous estimate or
parametric estimate method
funding limit reconciliation technique
is used to ensure that cost on the
project is budgeted or spent as per the
availability of the fund for example if
the project can get the funding of only
fifty thousand dollars a month the
project budget should be planned
accordingly
the output of this process is the cost
Baseline this is an authorized project
budget over a period this is used to
measure Monitor and control over all
cost performance of the project
in addition to this the Project funding
requirements are also arrived at funding
requirements means how much fund the
project requires monthly quarterly or
yearly for the execution
the last output of this process is
Project document updates
an understanding of determining budget
may be useful when answering questions
in the PMP exam so make a note of the
inputs tools and techniques and outputs
of determining budget in the next screen
let us discuss the last process of
project cost management that is control
cost
control costs is the process of
monitoring the status of the project to
update the project budget and managing
changes to the cost Baseline
updating the budget involves recording
actual costs spent until date any
increase to the authorized budget can
only be approved through the perform
integrated Change Control process
some of the typical activities that
happen as part of the control cost
process are ensuring that cost
expenditure does not exceed the
authorized funding monitor the cost
performance to understand variants and
monitoring the work performance against
the funds expended
the inputs to the process are project
management plan organizational process
assets Project funding requirements and
work performance data
work performance data contains the
information about the project progress
the important tools and techniques used
in controlling costs are earned value
analysis management
forecasting to complete performance
index
other important aspects of controlling
costs are the review the performance
analyze the reserves to make sure the
project has enough budgetary reserves to
meet the expenses and project management
software which helps in tracking and
managing costs
now let us look at the output of this
process
the key outputs of this process are work
performance information in terms of cost
variance CV schedule variance SV and
earned value EV and forecasts about the
cost performance
this process may also result in change
requests arising out of cost control
measures as well as updates to project
documents the project management plan
and organizational process assets
business scenario based questions on
Project cost control can be expected in
the exam so if you have questions on
these Concepts get them cleared as that
will help you score higher in the next
screen let us learn about earned value
management and its related terms
earned value technique is an excellent
way to track the project progress
against the project plan it is a method
of measuring the project performance
objectively and comparing it against the
project Baseline results from an earned
value analysis indicate deviation of the
project from cost and schedule baselines
Baseline is the initial approved value
along with approved changes therefore
schedule Baseline is the first approved
project schedule along with approved
changes
there are various terms used in earned
value technique
planned value is the authorized budget
assigned to the scheduled work
earned value is the work performed in
terms of budget authorized for that work
actual cost is the cost incurred in work
performed
budget at completion is the budgeted
amount for the total work
estimate at completion is the expected
total cost for the project
estimate to complete is the expected
cost to finish all the remaining Project
work
variance at completion is the projected
budget surplus or deficit at the end of
the project all the parameters displayed
on the screen are measured in terms of
cost you may come across business
scenario based questions on earned value
Management in the PMP exam so ensure
that you develop a clear understanding
of this topic let us look at an example
of a planned value in the next screen
planned value is the estimated value of
the work planned this value is measured
in terms of currency say dollar if the
plan value is three hundred forty
dollars then the work plan is worth
three hundred forty dollars
how do you calculate earned value the
solution is add the budget allocated to
each of the activities that have been
completed at the point of time the
resulting value is the earned value
in the next screen let us look at the
formula used to calculate earned value
in cost variance negative means the
project is over budget positive means
the project is under budget similarly in
schedule variance negative means the
project is behind schedule whereas
positive means the project is ahead of
schedule
the value of the next two parameters
cost performance index CPI and schedule
performance index SPI values vary
between 0 and 1. for example a CPI of
0.8 implies that 80 cents of work is
obtained for every dollar spent in the
project
similarly if SPI is 0.9 it implies that
project is progressing at only 90
percent of the speed originally planned
the next parameter is estimate at
completion or EAC
there are different ways of calculating
the EAC value the method used depends on
how the cost and schedule variances are
expected to play for the rest of the
project
BAC by CPI is used if you expect that
the current cost performance will
continue until the end of the project
AC plus BAC minus EV is used if you
expect that the rest of the project will
be managed at the budgeted rate
AC plus BAC minus EV by the product of
CPI and SPI is used if you want to
factor in the impact of the cost as well
as schedule variances
AC plus Etc is used if you want to
re-evaluate the Project based on a
forecast value for the estimated cost of
the remainder of the project
the next parameter is estimate to
complete or
Etc which is the cost of project from
this point to the end
this is calculated by subtracting the
actual cost from the estimate at
completion
in addition variance at completion can
be calculated by subtracting the
estimate at completion from the budget
at completion variance at completion is
the cost estimation whether it is over
or under budget
another parameter is the to complete
performance index or tcpi this is the
cost performance needed to achieve a
desired outcome
for example if the project needs to be
managed to the original budget BAC then
tcpi that is the CPI that must be
maintained for the rest of the project
is calculated as BAC minus EV by BAC
minus AC
similarly if it has to be managed within
a revised Target say EAC then tcpi is
calculated as BAC minus EV by EAC minus
AC before the start of the PMP exam
please make a note of the formulas of
earned value technique in the next
screen let us look into a business
scenario to understand this concept
better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
let us take the example of a software
development project there are four
phases and each phase takes a month to
complete and is expected to cost ten
thousand dollars the phases are planned
to be completed one after the other the
status of the project at the end of the
month three is summarized in the table
requirements definition is completed and
actual spending on this is ten thousand
dollars
architecture and design is done and
actual spending on this is twelve
thousand dollars development and unit
testing is only fifty percent done
though it was supposed to be completed
by Third month it has cost nine thousand
dollars until date
system testing and go live has not yet
started
Note S indicates start time F indicates
finish time and PF indicates that it is
partly finished at the end of the month
based on the above information calculate
the CV SV CPI and SPI of the project
let us look at a solution in the next
screen
before we end this lesson let us also
look at a few definitions that might be
useful for your PMP examination
law of diminishing return this means the
more you put into something the less you
get out of it for example doubling the
number of resources working on a project
will not necessarily have the time
working capital the amount of money the
company has to invest on the project and
the day-to-day company operations
funding limit reconciliation the process
of comparing the planned expenditure in
a given period with the available
funding for that period
large assets purchased by the company
lose value over time this is called
depreciation there are two forms of
depreciation straight line and
accelerated
same amount of depreciation is taken
every year for instance a car with a
price tag of ten thousand dollars and
useful life of ten years is depreciated
one thousand dollars per year at the end
of the tenth year the value of the car
is considered zero for all accounting
purposes accelerated depreciation
depreciates faster than the
straight-line depreciation for instance
a car with a price tag of ten thousand
dollars depreciates three thousand
dollars the first year one thousand five
hundred the next year one thousand the
third year and so on let us now check
your understanding of the topics covered
in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project cost management includes the
processes involved in estimating
budgeting and controlling costs so that
the project can be completed within the
approved budget
cost management plan contains details on
how to plan manage and control the
project cost in relation to the cost
Baseline and manage the cost variances
cost estimate is an educated guess of
how much an activity or project will
cost
budget considers the cost estimate and
accordingly sets aside funds for the
completion of the project
under control account technique related
activities are clubbed and their costs
are managed as one unit
the four project cost management
processes are Plan cost management
estimate costs determined budget control
costs
earned value management technique
indicates potential deviation of the
project from the cost and or schedule
baselines
in this lesson we will focus on Project
quality management let us begin with the
objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to Define quality and quality
management differentiate between quality
planning quality assurance and quality
control explain cost of quality and its
categories
describe the project quality management
processes
explain the seven basic tools of quality
explain Six Sigma in the next screen let
us take a quick look at the project
management process map
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the fifth
knowledge area that is Project quality
management and its processes in the next
screen let us understand what quality is
the project manager is responsible for
quality in a project however it is also
the responsibility of each and every one
in the project to ensure that whatever
they do meets project quality
expectations quality is defined as the
degree to which a set of inherent
characteristics fulfills requirements a
project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable usable means that the
intended users can use the product
without any problem in the next screen
let us look at some quality related
terms
it is important to discuss a few terms
to understand the concept of quality
better customer satisfaction is defined
as conformance to requirements and
fitness for use it is important to
understand the subtle distinction
between quality and greed grade is a
classification based on technical
characteristics low quality is always a
problem but low grade may not be a
problem rather it would be a matter of
choice similarly it is important to
understand the distinction between
precision and accuracy precision is the
granularity of measurement that is how
fine-grained can you measure the outcome
accuracy is how correct you are that is
how close you are to the desired value
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of optimal level of quality
quality comes at a cost more effort put
in quality will give better results
however you cannot keep on investing on
increasing the quality as there is no
limit to how much a product can be
improved investment in quality is
determined by knowing the optimal level
of quality
optimal level of quality as shown in the
diagram is said to be achieved at the
point where the incremental revenue from
Improvement equals the incremental cost
to secure it suppose you are the
manufacturer of toys but the toys are
below quality and the sales are low to
improve the quality you invest in
identifying the demands of children
sharing few samples and recording their
feedbacks once all these are captured
and implemented in the products you lure
the parents to buy them as the
investment is increased to manufacture
good quality toys the cost will
therefore increase and it might become
prohibitive for parents to buy optimal
level of quality is reached at a point
where you get maximum number of buyers
for the toys manufactured now that we
are clear on the concept of quality in
the next screen let us discuss quality
management
quality management involves performing
activities like creating standard
policies and procedures and ensuring
that those standard procedures are being
followed properly in the project it aims
to ensure that project meets all the
initial agreed requirements without any
deviation and that the specified
approach to Quality is implemented on
the project
three broad activities are done as part
of quality management they are quality
planning quality assurance and quality
control
quality planning is the first step when
quality related activities of the
project are planned quality assurance is
the next stage of implementing those
quality plans and quality control is the
last stage when periodic checks are done
to see if project quality is improving
in the next screen let us look into the
differences between the three aspects of
quality management
it is important to understand the
different kinds of activities that come
under quality planning quality assurance
and quality control once the quality
planning is done the quality management
plan is ready this quality management
plan has standards templates policies
and procedures to be followed in the
project it contains information on the
level of quality being aimed and the
plan to achieve that level it is the aim
of quality assurance activities to
ensure that the activities planned under
quality planning phase gets executed for
the project it is the task of quality
assurance to determine if the project is
complying with the organizational as
well as project policies and procedures
this is ensured by conducting regular
process audits to identify deviation
from what is planned in the quality
management plan
these audits are generally done by
quality Department of the organizations
quality assurance focuses on the process
not on specific products the role of
quality control is to measure specific
project data or results against
standards to inspect and verify the
Project's product defect repair and
measure whether quality indicators are
improving quality control is about the
product and data for example it was
planned as part of quality management
that project would get completed plus or
minus 10 percent within the cost budget
three months back when the measurement
was done project was over budget by 20
percent
when the measurement was done a day
before it was only 15 percent over
budget
therefore the project has showed an
improvement of five percent in the last
three months and it is quite likely that
over the next three months project may
get within the planned limit of 10
percent
instead of showing Improvement if the
data shows cost increase then corrective
and preventative actions are required to
get the project within the 10 percent
limit this is quality control
in the next screen let us discuss a few
quality management Concepts
let us look at some terms that are
commonly used in quality management
parlance total quality management or tqm
is a quality management philosophy that
involves holistic thinking about meeting
the objectives of an organization it
places the responsibility of quality
squarely on the management Kaizen is a
Japanese term that stands for change for
butter Kaizen philosophy is one that
should always be looking for small and
continuous improvements in the process
deeming cycle or pdca cycle that is plan
do check Act is a process control and
Improvement approach propagated by the
famous quality Guru Edward deeming it
means you plan for something executed
check the output and based on the
lessons you act to bring the deviations
under control
kanban is a pool-based management system
that originated in Japan based on just
in time jit Inventory management
the idea behind kanban is to minimize
the work in progress and achieve a
smooth flow in the process from start to
finish
because building up inventory only to
paper over the imperfections in the
system tends to hide the problems
in the next screen let us focus on cost
of quality
cost of quality is the cost that needs
to be incurred to make a quality product
the sum of all the costs incurred is
ensuring that project conforms to
requirement is cost of quality
cost of quality can be broken down into
two major categories first is the cost
of conformance or the money spent during
the project to avoid failures this can
further be subdivided into prevention
costs which is the cost to prevent
errors like training the team creating
documents on equipment and in time to do
it right the other subdivision is
appraisal costs or the cost for
assessing quality like testing
destructive testing loss and inspections
the second category is the cost of
non-conformance it is the money spent
during and after the project because of
failures this is subdivided into
internal failure costs it is the cost of
failures that occur before the product
is released to customers for example
rework and scrap the second subdivision
is external failure costs it is cost
incurred on failures that occur after it
has been released by the team for
example liabilities warranty work and
lost business concept based questions on
cost of quality can be expected in the
exam so please make a note of the
categories of cost of quality let us
look at the project quality management
processes in the next screen
there are three project quality
management processes of which the first
process plan quality management is done
as part of the planning process group
the next process perform quality
assurance is done as part of the
executing process group and the last
process control quality is done as part
of the monitoring and controlling
process group in the next three screens
let us look into each of these processes
in detail
the aim of the planned quality
management process is to identify the
relevant requirements or standards to
execute the project effectively to
achieve the desired quality level
quality planning results in the creation
of the quality management plan
aim of the plan quality process is to
identify the standards a standard is an
agreed upon process to work or achieve a
result a standard can be set from within
the organization or government once all
the standards for the project are
identified the aim of the quality
planning activities involves determining
what work needs to be done to meet those
standards
before adhering to the standards you
should question their relevance with the
project implementing all possible
standards applicable to the project in
random will have cost and time
implications
let us look at the inputs to this
process
the project management plan provides the
scope schedule and cost Baseline all of
which have an implication on the quality
management plan
quality plan has a direct correlation
with these it might also have an impact
on and be impacted by other subsidiary
management plans such as risk management
the stakeholders of the project may have
specific requirements and Views about
the quality parameters of the project
and these have to be considered
the risk register gives an indication
about the kind of risks that are
inherent in the project and also those
which must be considered while planning
the activities to ensure quality the
requirements for the project need to be
considered for planning quality related
activities because quality is all about
meeting the requirements in addition to
these Enterprise environmental factors
and organization process assets are also
listed as inputs because the standards
can be either from within the
organization or from government or other
external bodies standards from within
the organizations are usually the best
practices learned over a period while
executing numerous projects an example
of government standards can be standards
to control air pollution by the motor
vehicles which vehicle manufacturers
must adhere to to accomplish quality
planning first analyze the benefits
versus the costs of meeting quality
requirements next identify the cost of
quality and confirm if that kind of
investment in quality is Justified
in addition to these two benchmarking
helps in analyzing the quality of
activities of similar projects executed
in the past this helps in identifying
the particular quality of output of the
previous project which in turn acts as a
basis for the current Project's quality
planning
design of experiments can also be used
for Quality planning this is a
statistical way to determine what
variables will improve quality the most
for example in case of manufacturing
doors it can be determined that
increasing the quality of the wood can
have Maximum Impact on improving the
quality of the tour in addition the 76
quality tools also known as the 7qc
tools are used to determine the plan to
achieve the desired level of quality
statistical sampling as a tool becomes
relevant whenever the quality plan
cannot be applied to all the artifacts
produced for example if destructive
testing is a requirement then it can be
carried out only on a sample not on the
entire population
statistical sampling helps in arriving
at a representative sample that can give
useful information
other additional tools such as
brainstorming force field analysis Etc
may be used to determine the quality
management plan for the project
conducting regular meetings is another
important tool the quality management
plan has to be determined in a
collaborative manner by Consulting the
team members and other stakeholders
quality management plan is a key output
of this process
checklist is a list of items to inspect
for example many of the office buildings
have housekeeping checklists to ensure
that all floors cabins Etc are cleaned
checklists are created during quality
planning and used in quality control
metrics are Project Specific data that
need to be measured to check the status
of the project the simplest project
metrics can be cost and schedule metrics
are also decided during quality planning
and used in quality control one of the
roles of the project manager is to not
only manage the project but also improve
processes in the project to decrease the
instances of defects which in turn saves
time and money such activities are
listed in the process Improvement plan
which eventually becomes part of project
management plan
as a result of the planning activities
other project documents may also get
updated for example the quality
management plan may result in updates to
the cost or resource requirements there
may be questions in the PMP exam based
on the plan quality management process
so please ensure you have a fair
understanding of the concept before you
take the exam
in the next screen let us discuss the
second quality management process
once the quality planning is over the
next process and project quality
management is quality assurance which
involves determining whether the
standards are being met and the
processes are being followed therefore
the input for this process is the work
that has been completed during the
quality planning stage
they are project documents quality
management plan process Improvement plan
quality metrics and quality control
measurements let us look at the tools
and techniques used in this process
quality audit is the process to check
whether the project is complying with
the organization policies standards and
procedures and determine whether these
policies standards and procedures used
are efficient and effective
so a good audit not only looks at this
compliance but also for the new Lessons
Learned From the current project that
can help make the future projects better
process analysis involves using the
lessons learned from doing the initial
few work to make the remaining work more
efficient
for example if the project involves
installing a software package then the
lesson learned from the first few
installations can be used to improve the
process on remaining installations
apart from these all the quality
management and control tools such as the
seven basic quality tools will be
relevant to this process
the key output of this process is
Project documents updates to ensure that
if there is any deviation from agreed
standards it is corrected also if there
are any lessons learned that can help
improve the future projects the
organization process assets get updated
this quality assurance may result in
Improvement suggestions change requests
may be generated and the project
management plan may need to be updated
understanding characteristics of quality
assurance tools and techniques may be
useful while answering the exam so
prepare this topic well before you take
the exam in the next screen let us
discuss the last process of quality
management
the key focus of the quality control
activities is on the correctness of the
work
quality control helps answer questions
like is everything okay with the project
does the project plan require changes to
successfully execute the project will
the project succeed
Etc
let us look at the inputs to this
process the quality metrics measurements
are done continuously to see whether the
project quality is improving the project
deliverables are inspected against the
planned checklists quality control acts
upon the deliverables and work
performance data produced in execution
it also refers to the project management
plan for understanding deviations from
the plan it also considers the approved
change requests information from other
project documents and organizational
process assets there are seven popular
tools and techniques used in doing the
quality control activities they are
collectively known as seven basic tools
of quality other relevant tools are
statistical sampling inspection or
testing and review of the approved
changes quality control activities
result in quality control measurements
the verified deliverables validated
changes information about the work being
performed recommended changes and
updates to the organizational process
assets project management plan and other
project documents in the next screen let
us look into a business scenario to
understand this concept better after
reading the problem statement click the
solution button to look at a possible
answer
Six Sigma is a highly disciplined
process that focuses on developing and
delivering near perfect products and
services consistently if large volume of
data is plotted over a period of time
you would most probably have a
bell-shaped graph such graphs are also
called normal distribution graph it's
called as normal distribution because
any large volume of data is plotted with
the intent to track variations would
most probably be in a bell-shaped curve
the line corresponding to the top of the
bell curve is the median of the data
sample standard deviation concept is
used to measure how far any data is from
the mean standard deviation is also
called Sigma one standard deviation from
the mean covers 68 percent of the data
Six Sigma means six standard deviations
from the mean this would cover
99.9966 percent of the data
we will look at an example of Six Sigma
in the following screen to understand
Six Sigma let us look at an example a
tire Manufacturing Company produces one
hundred thousand tires a day it is not
possible to verify each and every Tire
manually to ensure it is defect free
instead random sample of these
manufactured tires are taken and checked
for defects assuming that the thickness
of the tires is a parameter to measure
defect any tire that has a thickness
more than or less than 10 millimeters is
considered to be defective now if you
measure the actual thickness of all one
hundred thousand tires manufactured
daily and plot them on a graph you get
normal distribution graph one standard
deviation from the mean covers 68
percent of the data meaning if the
thickness of the 100 000 tires are
plotted 68 000 of them lie within one
standard DB Asian above or below the
mean now if a company operates at Six
Sigma level they would ensure that all
tires that are up to six standard
deviations from the mean are defect free
therefore in such cases you can expect
only three defective tires out of a
million tires manufactured let us now
check your understanding of the topics
covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
a project is said to meet quality
expectations when all the project
requirements agreed in the beginning of
the project are met and the resulting
product is usable
quality management includes creating and
following policies and procedures that
meet the Project's defined quality needs
quality planning defines the standards
templates policies and procedures
quality assurance determines if the
project is complying with the policies
and procedures quality control measures
specific project results against
standards
plan quality management perform quality
assurance and control quality are the
three project quality management
processes
seven basic quality tools are used to
plan and achieve the desired levels of
quality
at Six Sigma level there would be only
three defects out of a million units
manufactured
in this lesson we will focus on project
management framework let us begin with
the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to Define project project
management program management and
portfolio management
recognize the roles of project
management office
identify the project constraints and
their impact on the project
explain the role of a project manager in
stakeholder management describe
different organization structure
differentiate between a Project Life
Cycle and a product life cycle
let's begin this lesson with
understanding what a project is in the
next screen
a project is a temporary Endeavor
undertaken to create a unique product
service or result for example developing
a new product service or result
constructing a building industrial plant
or infrastructure and implementing
improving or enhancing existing business
processes and procedures in the next
screen we will focus on the
characteristics of a project
a project can be distinguished based on
its characteristics the definition
describes two characteristics of a
project first it is temporary in nature
temporary here does not mean short in
duration a project can extend for long
duration based on the requirements for
example creating a new indigenous
missile defense system for a country
however there is always a definite plan
start and end date for a project it
cannot go on indefinitely
secondly the project is supposed to
produce a unique output the output could
be a product service or result there can
be many common activities between two
projects but the outcome of each project
should be unique in some way or the
other
now let us look at what marks the end of
a project a project ends when either the
objectives are met or the project is
terminated because the objectives will
not or cannot be met
the other reason to terminate the
project can be that the need for the
output of the project does not exist
anymore usually the sponsor of the
project takes a call about the closure
of the project
it is important to differentiate Project
work from regular operational work for
example your office receptionist does
the same work every day of picking any
incoming call and directing the call to
the right person in the office this is
an ongoing repetitive work and can be
classified as operation
operations unlike projects are neither
temporary nor unique
creating a new software system to
effectively track your customer
complaint can be an example of a project
when the software is successfully
developed the project objective is met
which marks the end of the project when
you start using this software to track
customer complaints you are entering
into the operations phase
in the next screen let us now look into
project management
as defined in the pembok guide project
management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements project
management is achieved by proper
application and integration of the 47
processes project application and
integration means these processes should
be executed in the right manner as well
as in the right order in the next screen
let us discuss how to manage a project
program management is defined as the
application of knowledge skills tools
and techniques to a program to meet the
program requirements and to obtain
benefits and control not available by
managing projects individually as
defined in pmbok guide a program is a
group of related projects which when
managed as a group in a coordinated
fashion provides benefits and control
that are not available while managing
them individually these benefits could
be from decreased risk economies of
scale improved management of
dependencies delivery of additional
capabilities optimal utilization of
shared resources and so on let us now
learn the various features of program
management
random projects cannot be grouped
together as a program the projects in a
program should be related in some way or
the other and there should be some value
added in managing them together
a project may not be a part of any
program but a program will always have
projects a project can also be executed
as a standalone project
a program is designed to deliver some
strategic benefits value to the
organization these benefits can be
tangible or intangible examples of
tangible benefit could be increased
profit margins or operational cost
savings examples of intangible benefits
could be improved team morale or
building up certain competencies
while a project manager focuses
relentlessly on the Fulfillment of the
Project's requirements that is scope
cost time quality a program manager
needs to focus on ensuring that the
organizational benefits are realized
in the next screen let us understand
what a portfolio is
portfolio is yet another term used along
with project and program
a portfolio may have multiple projects
and programs that are managed as a group
to achieve strategic objectives note
that all projects and programs in a
portfolio may not be necessarily
interdependent or directly related
a portfolio can be created based on the
business objectives
for example an I.T Service Company can
have a portfolio named Japanese projects
which is formed with an aim to take over
the Japanese Market by giving more
attention to these projects within this
portfolio similar projects can be
managed as a program
and all banking projects from Japan can
be managed as a banking program
in the next screen let us discuss
portfolio management
portfolio management is the centralized
management of one or more portfolios
this includes identifying prioritizing
authorizing managing and controlling
projects programs and other related work
to achieve strategic business objectives
therefore whether the company should
have Japanese projects as portfolio or
not is decided by portfolio Management
in the next screen let us understand the
relationship between portfolios programs
and projects
the image on the screen will help you to
understand the terms portfolios programs
and projects a portfolio is part of an
organization's overall strategy it
represents a conscious decision by an
organization to invest in the portfolio
the overall objectives of a portfolio
are then cascaded down to the lower
level components the components could be
sub-portfolios programs or projects
these components can further be broken
down into smaller components for ease of
management
although a project may not contain
operations a program or a portfolio it
can include other work this other work
May comprise training and development
customer support and services
Etc if the other work has Synergy with
the overall objectives and adds to the
capability to deliver the higher level
benefits then it can be included in the
program or portfolio as well
in the next screen we will discuss
project management office
project management office or pmo is a
specific type of body or Department
within an organization
pmo performs several roles in the
organization and these can broadly be
classified as primary roles and other
rules
typically the pmo may take up any one or
a combination of the three primary roles
it provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization it
provides support and training in
organization on how to manage projects
and finally it provides project managers
for different ongoing projects in the
organization
pmo may also help in managing
interdependencies between the projects
selecting managing and deploying shared
or dedicated project resources if need
be terminating a project and organizing
Lessons Learned sessions and maintaining
the project management knowledge base
for an organization in the next screen
we will discuss how to manage the triple
constraints
any project can be done successfully if
there is no constraint on time or there
is unlimited budget available
unfortunately that is not true in real
life
a project is performed within some
constraint and these constraints are
usually competing therefore if you
change one it would affect the other for
example if the project duration
increases it would lead to increase in
the project cost as well
triple constraint is a term that
originally referred to the three
competing project constraints within
which the projects are performed these
constraints are costs time and scope
quality is a primary concern for a
project manager
therefore the project manager has to
make trade-offs to keep the scope cost
time quality plane and balance to
achieve the balance the project manager
also needs to manage other aspects of
the project for instance the people
stakeholders risks communication and
procurements
the project manager plays the essential
role of integrating all these different
aspects of project management in the PMP
examination you can expect business
scenario-based questions focusing on the
triple constraints
in the next screen let us understand who
a stakeholder is
a stakeholder can be defined as the one
whose interests May positively or
negatively be affected or perceived to
be affected by the decision activity or
outcome of the project as per the
definition the project team project
manager project sponsor pmo Office
customer
Etc are the stakeholders of the project
a project sponsor is the one who gives a
go ahead for a project and provides the
necessary resources to execute the
project therefore the head of projects
in the organization who provides a green
signal to start a project and allocates
required resources to the project is the
project sponsor a project sponsor is
usually somebody placed high up in the
organizational hierarchy of the
Performing organization that is the
organization in which the work of the
project is being carried out
in the next screen let us look at
stakeholder management
one of the key responsibilities of a
project manager is to manage
stakeholders a project manager has to
involve the stakeholders from the
beginning of the project until the end
so they are aware of every step a
project manager has to take up specific
activities for stakeholder management
identifying both internal and external
stakeholders
missing out any stakeholder can be
disastrous for a project a stakeholder
who has identified towards the end of
the project may come up with his own
requirement at that stage and
incorporating them can be risky
determining stakeholder requirements
after identifying all the stakeholders
the project manager also needs to ensure
that their requirements are clearly
identified sometimes stakeholders might
themselves not know of their requirement
and it is the job of the project manager
to get them right by doing a proper
stakeholder requirement analysis
determining stakeholder expectations
stakeholders might also have some
unstated expectations
which need to be clarified to see if it
can become a project requirement it is
again the role of the project manager to
determine the stakeholders expectation
communicating with stakeholders once all
the stated and unstated stakeholder
requirements are known the project
manager as part of stakeholder analysis
should focus on communicating them
regularly to keep stakeholders involved
in the project once you understand the
practices of stakeholder management it
will be easier for you to answer
scenario-based questions in the
examination in the next screen let us
look at the various organization
structure
projects are performed in an
organization and the functioning of the
organization might affect the project
the different organization structured
types explained here are based on the
level of authority that a project
manager gets into in those organizations
in a functional type of organization the
organization is grouped by the area of
specialization within different
functional areas for instance marketing
accounting engineering Etc are
departments within the organization each
employee typically reports to a
functional manager in such types of
organization normally projects are
undertaken within the department itself
if a project requires any assistance
from another department the request
moves from the head of the requesting
Department to the head of the concern
Department the team members do their
normal departmental work in addition to
the project work
the next type of organization is
projectized organization in such
organizations there are no departments
the organization's resources mostly work
on projects team members report to a
project manager the project manager has
complete control over the resources when
the project is completed either they
move on to another project or they look
for some job outside the company they do
not have a department for themselves
the third type of organization is a
matrix organization which is a blend of
functional and projectized
organizational structure a team member
belongs to a department as well as they
are part of a project team in such
organization team members have two
bosses one their department head and the
second their project manager
since there are two bosses here this
type of organization is further
classified into three different types
they are weak strong and balanced Matrix
organization
so out of the two bosses that team
members have in Matrix organization if
the project manager has more authority
over the team member such organizations
are called strong Matrix where the
functional manager has more Authority
it's a weak Matrix organization if they
both share equal Authority then it is a
balanced organization
there is another term that you might
find in the exam called type Matrix this
generally refers to a co-located team
that is a team that has been placed in
the same location to enhance their
performance in the PMP exam if there is
no mention of the organization type you
can assume it to be a matrix
organization
let us look at each of these
organization structures in detail in the
next screen let us look at functional
organization
in a functional organization the
resources of the organization are
grouped by functions sometimes called
departments examples of functions could
be sales Finance Administration
manufacturing Etc
each function plays a definite role in
the organization and is headed by a
functional head or supervisor
all the resources in such an
organization report directly into their
functions therefore A salesperson would
report into the sales organizational
hierarchy a purchase executive would
report into procurement and so on you
would notice that in a functional
organization the project manager's role
is not explicitly called out when a
functional organization embarks on a
project each of the functions that are
involved May volunteer some resources to
work on the project one of these
resources may end up playing the project
manager's role the resource assignments
may not even be full time and sometimes
even the project manager is part-time
since the project manager has no
authority over any of the resources they
are dependent on the functional heads
this makes it more challenging for the
project manager to coordinate in the
team
however functional organizations provide
an opportunity for specialization for
example if a purchase executive was
reporting into the purchase Department
that executive would have exposure to
all the purchasing that happens within
the organization and has a well-defined
career path
in functional organizations project
management happens at the functional
head level next let us look at the
projectized organization and the next
screen
the projectized organization has all the
resources aligned around projects the
project managers have complete control
over the resources working on their
projects
the biggest advantage of the projectized
organization is that the resources have
loyalty to their projects and project
execution becomes easier
this kind of structure is suitable for
organizations whose work is in the
nature of projects there are few
disadvantages in this structure as well
firstly the role of the resource is over
once the project is completed secondly
highly specialized roles within a
project may not be fully occupied all
the time for example a purchase
executive may have work for selected
periods on a project while purchase
activities are going on however for the
rest of the period their capability may
not be optimally utilized there is less
scope for functional specialization as
the project boundaries limit the kind of
work for the resources
each project manager is in charge of a
project and its resources
next let us look at the Matrix
organization
in a matrix organization the resources
report to the functional managers and
are managed by the project managers as
well
there might even be a function that
represents all the project managers in
the organization which provides project
management expertise
The Matrix structure has three variants
commonly referred to as weak balanced
and strong
in a weak Matrix the authority of the
project manager is the weakest and
strongest in a strong Matrix structure
the titles given to project managers and
functional or weak Matrix organizations
are project expediter or project
coordinator they would be called project
managers in a balanced or strong Matrix
structure and have slightly more
authority over the time of the team
members the advantage of the Matrix
structure is that resources can be
optimally utilized while preserving the
capacity of the project managers to get
projects executed efficiently resources
can specialize in their functions and
have stability in their careers also
contribute to the projects at the same
time potentially the disadvantage of
Matrix organization is that the
communication overhead increases
significantly this is because every
resource in the organization belongs
into a project and into a function
leading to a dual reporting structure
in a matrix organization project
management happens at project resource
level in the next screen let us
summarize the advantages and
disadvantages of different
organizational structures
each organization structure has its own
set of advantages and disadvantages the
advantage of functional organizations is
that resources may find clearly defined
career paths and Achieve specialization
and skill development in their
respective Fields it will be a flexible
Workforce since only one manager will be
responsible avoiding confusion the
disadvantage of such organization type
is that project work is hampered
Department work is always given higher
priority than the project work in
addition there is no career path in
project management which leads to lower
interest in projects
in the case of the projectized
organization one of the clear advantages
is better communication within the
projects since Project work is the only
work team members are doing it also
leads to loyalty towards the project
goals the disadvantage of such
organization type is the inefficient use
of resources because every project team
has their own support function therefore
this might lead to the duplication of
effort it also leads to the resources
being left with no work since their
roles are over once the project is
completed
it also hampers skill development
because the project requirements dictate
what kind of work team members perform
at different stages on a project
now let us look at the Matrix
organization it also has the advantage
of better coordination and maximum
utilization of resources
however the disadvantage is the higher
potential for conflict among the
managers which might lead to
communication complexity and overhead
management
in the next screen let us focus on the
comparison on Project Life Cycle and
product life cycle
Project Life Cycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure of the
project
the product life cycle on the other hand
also encompasses the operational and
maintenance phases
a typical products life cycle starts
with conception of the product and goes
until its withdrawal from the market the
withdrawal might be because it becomes
obsolete or there is no further need for
the product in the market
a product has a long life cycle a
product can require or spawn many
projects over its life
for example a project in product
conception phase could be to determine
customer needs whereas a project during
product maturity phase could be used to
perform competitive analysis
typically a product life cycle is longer
than the Project Life Cycle a project
also has its own life cycle and this
life cycle depends upon the industry and
the organization within which the
project is being executed
sometimes different organizations within
the same industry use different life
cycles
there can be questions in the exam based
on the comparison of project lifecycle
and product life cycle so understanding
the differences will be useful in
answering such questions
in the next screen let us discuss more
on Project Life Cycle
a life cycle is composed of phases each
phase represents a discrete unit of work
required to be done on the project there
are different ways of classifying
project life cycles let us first discuss
the sequential versus overlapping life
cycle
in sequential phases the subsequent
phase starts only after the previous
phase has been completed whereas in
overlapping phases two or more phases
may run in parallel for some time this
could help fast tracking and compressing
the amount of time required
the other way of classifying life cycles
is how they go about the process of
planning
and predictive life cycles there is a
large upfront planning phase where all
the details of scope cost time are
planned before beginning the subsequent
phases
these phases then are executed in either
sequential or overlapping modes they are
suitable for large projects where all
the requirements are likely to be known
in advance and where upfront planning
effort is required to get the necessary
approvals another feature of predictive
life cycles is that each phase May
potentially be different in the nature
of activities and may require people
with different skill sets for example
traditional software development
lifecycle has phases like requirements
feasibility planning design construction
testing and transition
we will continue project life cycles in
the next screen
incremental and iterative life cycles
have a short upfront high level
definition and planning phase the
product is then developed through a
series of iterations where iteration
increments or adds to the functionality
by a little all the activities are
intentionally repeated in iterations
adaptive or agile life cycles are
variants of incremental and iterative
life cycles where iteration is very
short typically two to four weeks
agile methodologies are becoming very
popular in the software development
industry and in other Industries where
the requirements are highly changeable
and frequent feedback is beneficial
let us now check your understanding of
the topics covered in this lesson
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson
project management is the application of
knowledge skills and tools and
techniques applied to project activities
to meet the project requirements
pmo provides the policies methodologies
and tools and templates for managing
projects within the organization
project manager has to integrate various
project aspects like the people
stakeholders risks communication and
procurements with the project
constraints time scope cost and quality
identifying internal and external
stakeholders determining their
requirements and communicating with them
regularly is an important role of a
project manager
functional projectized and Matrix are
the three types of organization
structures based on the level of
authority given to the project manager
Project Life Cycle spans the initiation
of a project until the closure while
product life cycle also encompasses the
operational and maintenance phases in
this lesson we will focus on Project
Communications management let us begin
with the objectives of this lesson
after completing this lesson you will be
able to Define communication and project
Communications management identify the
different communication methods
technology and channels explain the
elements of a basic communication model
describe the project Communications
management processes in the next screen
let us take a quick look at the project
management process map
there are 47 processes and project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped into five process
groups in this lesson we will look at
the seventh knowledge area that is
Project Communications management and
its processes in the next screen let us
understand communication
communication can be best defined as a
two-way process of exchanging
information between two entities as you
can see on the screen if project is an
entity the project needs to communicate
with other entities in the organization
like project managers Senior Management
of the organization and any other
stakeholder of the project similarly
these entities may also have to
communicate with the projects the
communication between project and the
stakeholders is always two-sided project
manager is responsible for ensuring
proper communication to and from the
project in fact a project manager spends
almost 90 percent of his or her time on
communication you can now understand how
important it is for a project manager to
plan this activity well in the next
screen let us discuss communication
methods
communication can be done in two ways it
can be done written or verbal both
written as well as verbal communication
can either be formal or informal formal
means communicating by following some
basic rules whereas informal means
taking a casual approach these two
combinations result in four different
communication methods they are formal
written formal verbal informal written
and informal verbal formal written
method is used for project management
plans project Charter and over long
distance communication formal verbal
method is used during presentations
whereas informal written method is
applicable while writing notes or emails
informal verbal on the other hand is
applied during conversations
you can expect questions in the PMP exam
which require choosing a communication
method for a given situation so a fair
understanding of the communication
methods can help you score higher in the
next screen let us look at the various
communication Technologies
communication technology refers to the
different media used for communicating a
few such Technologies are listed on
screen among which email fax and
telephone are a few popular
communication Technologies in the next
screen let us understand the
communication Channel with the help of
an example
communication takes place between four
people and a team the lines across the
members represent there can be six
unique channels of communication
existing within the team now if the team
comprises 10 members how many unique
channels of communication will be
calculated you can use the formula n
multiplied with n minus 1 and the
resulting sum divided by two n is the
total number of people involved in
communication in this case n equals to
ten if this is put into the formula you
will get 45 as the result
therefore 45 unique communication
channels exist in a team of 10 people it
is difficult to manage such a large
number of communication channels
therefore it is important to structure
communication otherwise everyone starts
communicating everything to everyone and
it can become a real chaos in the
project in the PMP exam you may be asked
to calculate the number of communication
channels in a scenario-based question so
please make a note of the formula to
answer the question correctly in the
next screen let us discuss the basic
communication model
project Communications management
includes the processes required to
ensure that information about timely and
appropriate generation collection
distribution storage and ultimate
disposition of project is prepared and
circulated to all project stakeholders
it is the responsibility of a project
manager to ensure that the information
requested by the stakeholder is
communicated to them the frequency at
which the information needs to be shared
may also vary from stakeholder to
stakeholder for example think about a
simple process of sharing a project
status report with the customer and
Senior Management this knowledge area
explains how it should be done as per
PMI in the next screen let us discuss
the project Communications management
processes
there are three project Communications
management processes
process is carried during different
process groups plan communication
management is done during planning
process group manage Communications is
done during executing process group and
control Communications is done during
monitoring and controlling process group
in the next few screens we will cover
each of these processes in detail
plan Communications management is the
process of developing an appropriate
approach and plan for project
Communications based on stakeholders
information needs and requirements and
available organizational assets
this belongs to the planning process
group
stakeholder register is an important
input to this process it is a list of
all the stakeholders the project
management plan has information about a
large number of the project requirements
and the stakeholders who need to receive
communication of various kinds are
therefore a critical input to this
process in addition to these two
organization process assets and
Enterprise environmental factors are
also inputs to this process many
organizations have standard templates to
prepare communication management plan
which are part of the organizational
process assets and Enterprise
environmental factors the first
technique used in this process is the
communication requirements analysis
where the communication requirements of
each of the stakeholders are analyzed
and categorized in this you try to find
how many of the stakeholders need
similar kind of information which can be
grouped together if you send information
through an email system all those
stakeholders who need similar
information can be marked in CC in the
email next you can decide on the
communication technology these days
email is the most widely used technology
but in few cases you might have to send
information using some other technology
like fax or registered post for example
all government Communications are done
using registered post to keep a written
record finally you need to understand
how communication really happens that is
the communication models and the various
communication methods used you may need
to conduct meetings before agreeing on
and finalizing the communications
management plan the communications
management plan is the primary output of
this process which lays down procedures
around Communications in the
organization communication management
plan has information like which
stakeholder needs what kind of
information at what frequency and how as
a result of this process some other
project documents may also get updated
there may be questions in the PMP exam
based on the planned Communications
management process so a fair
understanding of the process will help
you answer such questions correctly in
the next screen let us look into a
business scenario to understand this
concept better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
manage Communications is the process of
creating collecting Distributing storing
retrieving and the ultimate disposition
of project information in accordance to
the communications management plan it
belongs to the executing process group
managed Communications is done
throughout the Project Life Cycle
everything cannot be planned during
communication planning so manage
Communications takes care of responding
to unexpected requests for information
as well Communications management plan
is an important input work performance
reports have information regarding
project performance and Status
information organizational process
assets are the standard templates
created for the status report by
organizations in some organizations
there are guidelines for communication
distribution Enterprise environmental
factors are the other inputs to this
process various tools and techniques are
used in this process Communications
technology represents the means of
technology that is email instant
messaging telephone conferencing Etc
that are used to exchange information
the use of communication models helps
you determine the technique that is best
suited for a particular situation
communication methods are the various
methods used to communicate for example
whether it is interactive or offline
whether information is being pushed by
the provider or polled by the recipient
Etc Information Management systems help
design a framework for managing the
information within a project that is how
it is acquired where it is stored and
how it is distributed and destroyed in
performance reporting all the
information is synthesized in the form
of performance reports that are later
distributed to the appropriate
stakeholders and forms an important part
of the communications strategy on a
project the first and primary output of
this process is the communications
messages that are generated during the
project the other outputs include
project management plan updates project
document updates and organizational
process assets updates in the next
screen let us discuss controlled
Communications process control
Communications is the process of
monitoring and controlling
Communications throughout the entire
Project Life Cycle to ensure the
information needs of the project
stakeholders are met it is part of the
monitoring and controlling process group
the inputs to this process are the
project communications project
management plan and issue log which has
a list of issues that are raised by
different project stakeholders data
related to the work being performed on
the project and various other project
documents which may have to be
communicated other inputs include work
performance data and organizational
process assets let us look at the tools
and techniques in detail the information
management systems provide tools to
collect consolidate and present the
information in the form of code urgent
concise Communications expertise must be
sought from different stakeholders on
how you should go about this process
several meetings may be needed to ensure
the efficiency and efficacy of the
communications the major outputs of this
process is the work performance
information which indicates that the
work performance data has been analyzed
interpreted and presented in an easily
comprehensible form this process may
also give rise to change requests
updates to the project management plan
project documents and organizational
process assets in the next screen let us
look into a business scenario to
understand this concept better after
reading the problem statement click the
solution button to look at a possible
answer
here is a quick recap of what was
covered in this lesson communication is
a two-way process of transferring
information from one entity to another
the four commonly used communication
methods are formal written formal verbal
informal written and informal verbal the
total number of unique channel of
communication can be calculated using
the formula n multiplied with n minus 1
and the resulting sum divided by two by
analyzing the communication model
problems in Project communication can be
identified project manager is
responsible for timely availability of
information to all stakeholders the
three project Communications management
processes are plan communication
management management Communications and
control Communications
in this lesson we will focus on Project
human resource management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the sixth
knowledge area that is Project human
resource management and its processes in
the next screen let us understand
project human resource management
project Human Resource Management
includes the processes that organize
manage and lead the project team
one of the key elements of human
resource management is that each of the
project team members should have clear
assignment of their roles and
responsibilities
in addition even the team working on
project management tasks should be a
part of the Project's team and they are
responsible for project management
functions like initiating planning
executing monitoring and controlling and
closing along with other leadership
activities in the next screen let us
understand the difference between
functional and project manager
an organization may have both functional
managers and project managers the
difference
functional manager is the one who
handles a business function or
department for instance the HR manager
is responsible for the HR department in
an organization therefore an HR Manager
will be a functional manager generally a
functional manager is also a subject
matter expert
the roles and responsibilities of the
functional manager depend upon the core
business of the organization and overall
organization structure functional
managers normally own the resources and
provide the projects with necessary
resources they also negotiate with the
project manager regarding resources the
project manager on the other hand is
responsible and accountable for the
success or failure of a project and the
quality of the project they are not
technical experts the project manager
may not have authority over the
resources depending upon the
organizational structure they often have
to negotiate with the functional manager
for the resources and are responsible
for the product quality a project
manager will credit the team with the
success of the project and accept the
blame for the failure
now let us look at an example to
understand the roles played by
functional and project managers the CEO
of an organization initiates a new
project to secure an ISO
2008 certification for the company now
this project would require team members
from each of the company departments and
whoever is the project manager of this
project will have to request the
functional manager to assign one of
their team members to the project
resources assigned to the project go
back to their respective departments
once the project is completed
let us now discuss the project Human
Resource Management processes in the
next screen there are four project Human
Resource Management processes the first
process plan human resource management
is done as part of the planning process
group the next three processes are part
of the executing process group these
processes are acquire project team
develop project team and manage project
team let us now look into each of these
processes in detail in the next screen
let us begin with plan human resource
management
plan human resource management is the
process of identifying and documenting
project roles responsibilities required
skills reporting relationships and
creating a staffing management plan this
process is part of the planning process
group in addition to that finalizing the
project hierarchy of who reports to whom
and designing the Staffing management
plan is also part of this process
the first input to this process is the
project management plan there could be a
lot of information in the project
management plan and subsidiary plans
that may be relevant to the creation of
the human resource management plan for
example the Project Life Cycle processes
the timelines how the work will be
accomplished
Etc the other key input for this process
is the activity resource requirement
team members can be identified based on
these requirements in addition to this
Enterprise environmental factors like
current employment Outlook Etc are also
important for example if the economy is
booming and there are Apple job
opportunities for the team members the
reward and recognition system can keep
the project team interested in the
project organizational process asset is
also an input to this process an example
of the organization process assets can
be templates or a form to request for a
new resource let us now look at the
tools and techniques used to develop
human resource plan
the roles and responsibilities are
captured in the form of organization
charts and position descriptions there
are various ways to draw this chart it
can be either hierarchical chart which
shows the reporting function or it can
be text based the other technique used
for developing the human resource plan
is networking this involves formal or
informal interactions within the
organization and outside by the project
manager to identify the best team for
the project depending upon various
interpersonal factors
organizational Theory helps to
understand how individuals come together
and function as an organization
expert judgment and meetings are
required to put the human resource plan
together
the output of this process is human
resource management plan this plan
contains documents like Staffing
management plan
project organization chart and rules and
responsibilities Matrix
the Staffing management plan is a
comprehensive document that describes
when and how team members would be added
to and released from the project
another component of the Staffing
management plan is the recognition and
reward system
recognition and reward system helps
project managers motivate their team the
Staffing management plan is relevant to
the projects of a functional or Matrix
organization where project team members
are always caught in a dilemma about
prioritizing Project work against
regular departmental work in the next
screen let us discuss organization
charts and role descriptions
a project manager needs to make sure
that there is an organization chart
prepared specifically for the project it
should clearly identify the roles and
the reporting relationships between them
a sample organization chart is shown on
the slide
another way of clearly delineating
responsibilities among team members is
by using a responsibility assignment
Matrix one form of responsibility
assignment Matrix is the raci chart in
the raci chart R stands for responsible
a for accountable C for concerned or
consulted and I for informed for each
important activity or deliverable on the
project it needs to be clearly
identified who is responsible or
contributes to it who is ultimately
accountable who is merely concerned
about the success and who needs to be
informed or kept in the loop an example
of the raci chart is shown on the screen
in this case project manager John is
accountable for the project plan and the
other team members Chris Sally and Ting
are responsible for completing the plan
similarly you can note the roles of each
resource in the other activities
in the next screen let us understand
resource histogram
resource histogram is a method of
depicting how many resources are
required for the life of a project if
You observe the chart shown on the
screen it indicates that the number of
Staff hours required on the project
increases to a peak in 2014 and then
slowly tapers off especially for long
running projects the level of Staffing
needed may vary considerably over a
period This has implications for other
parts of the plan as well for example
the cost will vary as the number of
resources change this piece of
information helps a project manager to
understand at what time they need to
onboard and off-board resources on a
project in the next screen let us look
into the second human resource
management process that is acquire
project team
acquire project team is the process of
confirming human resource availability
and obtaining the team necessary to
complete project activities
this process belongs to the executing
process group
acquiring resources may not be required
in the planning phase therefore it is
done in execution phase though you may
plan to acquire few in the planning
phase major acquisition is done in
execution phase this may be true where
large projects are run spanning over
many years with several detailed
activities the key input is the human
resource management plan Enterprise
environmental factors help understand
which team members will be available to
work on the project
how much they will cost
Etc organizational process assets will
help understand the hiring procedure of
the company the policies that govern the
use of team members on the project
Etc the key technique for acquiring the
project team is negotiation as a project
manager you have to negotiate with the
company's Senior Management resource
manager or with prospective candidates
to secure the most suitable resources on
the project sometimes the resources may
be pre-assigned to a project this
typically happens when they are the key
resources without which the project
cannot take off sometimes the project
team is acquired by getting required
resources through external vendors most
of the bigger organizations have
approved a list of vendors who provide
resources on a contractual basis
nowadays the concept of virtual team is
also quite popular to get a project team
so even though the project is being
conceived in one country a big big part
of the team can be in another country
for example if the project is conceived
in the USA majority of the team can be
in Germany and both the teams can
coordinate over the phone email chat Etc
multi-criteria decision analysis is also
an important tool to achieve the
objectives while acquiring the human
resources for the project it is
important to consider a number of
factors such as availability cost skill
set experience attitude relocation needs
Etc these criteria have to be considered
in totality and balanced out against the
Project's requirements the output of
this process is Project staff
assignments resource calendars and
updates on project management plan let
us now discuss the next process develop
project team
once the project team is acquired the
next step is developing the project team
develop project team is the process of
improving competencies team member
interaction and overall team environment
to enhance project performance
this process belongs to the executing
process group the inputs to this process
include project staff assignments
resource calendars and Human Resource
Management plan one of the techniques
used in developing project team is
interpersonal skills it is more of an
art than a science and this is where
individual characteristics of project
managers matter a lot if the project
manager genuinely commands trust and
respects the team members developing the
team becomes easy team members look up
to the project manager not only for
getting Project Specific Instructions
but also for their career advancement as
well social activities like celebrating
a team member's birthday going for
parties outside the office
Etc helps in team building training is
also an important tool for developing
the project team as it helps in
increasing the knowledge of competencies
of the team members sometimes
co-locating the team members at a single
place also helps in developing team
bonding this is especially important if
team members work from different
geographical locations knowing a person
face to face does help in reducing
conflict project managers can also
encourage the team members by providing
recognition and rewards Personnel
assessment tools give the project
manager insights into the strengths and
opportunities for improvement in the
team members these tools also help in
understanding members aspirations so
that the project manager can better
align the project goals with the
individual aspirations finally the
project manager should also set some
ground rules in the project to ensure
that team performs their work without
any problems some such rules can be
everyone should reach office for daily
meeting by 9 30 am sharp if there is
more than a 10 percent delay in
completing any activity assigned it
should immediately be escalate to
project manager if there are any
unforeseen circumstances it should be
immediately brought to the notice of the
project manager Etc the output of this
process is team performance assessments
this is done by the project manager to
evaluate and enhance the effectiveness
of the team as a whole this is a
document which explains team
Effectiveness as information about the
team evolves the Enterprise
environmental factors may also be
updated questions that test a project
manager's role in developing a project
team can be expected in the PMP exam so
ensure that you have a fair
understanding of the role before you
take the exam in the next screen let us
discuss the manage project team process
managing the project team is different
from developing the project team though
it is also done during the execution
process group it relates to measuring
team members performance providing
feedback resolving issues and managing
changes to optimize project performance
to measure team members performance the
manager should know the work assigned to
them as well as their performance on the
assigned work hence project staff
assignments and team performance
assessments are listed as input to this
process the human resource management
plan serves as a guideline for managing
project teams some organizations have
template and procedures to do such
assessment and that being the reason why
organization process asset is also one
of the inputs to this process the work
performance reports as well as issue
logs will be inputs because the team
management activities have to be
performed in this context observation
and conversation is a technique where
the project manager monitors and
discusses the tasks done by the team
this does not imply formal project
status reports but having an informal
interaction with the team before
documenting the project status report
knowing about the issue early helps in
resolving them early formal performance
appraisals are helpful in evaluating the
team members performance on the project
the project manager creates these with
the help of the team supervisors it is
an established practice in most
organizations to evaluate team members
for their work this may have a bearing
on their future assignments salary
promotions Etc since the power of
appraising lies within the project
manager the project manager can use this
as an effective tool for managing the
team since multiple resources work on a
single project it is quite natural to
expect conflicts it is the
responsibility of project manager to
resolve conflicts Conflict Management
has been discussed in detail later in
the lesson you can expect questions on
Conflict Management in the exam
the other tool is interpersonal skills
the output of managing a project team
includes corrective action
recommendations like which team members
to be changed implementing some reward
system to motivate the team
Etc updating the projectmanagement plans
documents organization process asset and
Enterprise environmental factors are the
other outputs of this process there can
be questions in the PMP exam that test a
project manager skill in managing a
project team so ensure that you are
aware of the inputs tools and techniques
and outputs of managing a project team
let us discuss Team Dynamics in the next
screen any team naturally goes through
several stages as it gets together these
stages are forming storming norming
performing and adjourning informing
stage a team formally comes together for
the first time in storming stage
disagree payments start to surface this
is followed by norming when the teams
start working together and trusting each
other in performing stage they are able
to deliver results as a team finally the
team is adjourned when the work of the
project is completed or the project is
terminated
in the next screen let us discuss
conflict management
many organizations look for people with
diverse background to get different
perspectives about work if people with
diverse backgrounds and culture work on
a project it is quite natural to expect
conflict conflict often results in
opportunities for improvement the root
causes of conflict can be scarce
resources scheduling priorities and
personal work Styles while the popular
belief is that personality or ego can be
the key reason for conflict it is the
least possible reason for conflict as a
project manager if you find yourself in
between a conflict with a team member
sit across the table and resolve it if
not they should get their immediate
managers involved and try to resolve it
to avoid conflicts a project manager
should let everyone involved have
complete clarity about the project
assign the roles and responsibilities to
each of the team members clearly ensure
that there are no overlapping
responsibilities which could be a
possible cause for conflict sometimes
boredom at work can also lead to
conflict so one of the responsibilities
of project manager is to keep motivating
the team members and let them work on
interesting and challenging assignments
business scenarios based questions on
Conflict Management can be expected in
the PMP exam so it is essential to have
a fair understanding of the topic in the
next screen let us look at conflict
resolution techniques
there are five techniques of resolving
conflict they are withdraw or avoid
smooth or accommodate compromise or
reconcile force or direct collaborate or
problem solve in withdraw or avoid one
Retreats from a potential conflict
situation or defers the resolution to a
later date this does not resolve the
conflict but allows for more time in
smooth or accommodate areas of agreement
are emphasized to reduce the intensity
of the conflict again this does not on
its own result in a resolution but it
may succeed in changing the perceptions
about the situation in compromise or
reconcile there is some give and take in
order to bring some satisfaction to all
parties depending on how the process
went this may be perceived as a when
when or a lose-lose situation because
none of the parties really get what they
want enforce or direct a person in a
position of authority directs how the
matter should be resolved it may be
necessary to do this when the matter has
to be resolved immediately however this
may result in upsetting one or more of
the conflicting parties and collaborate
or problem solving the parties in the
conflict are asked to come together to
collaborate and look for a resolution to
the problem this offers the greatest
likelihood of a satisfactory and
permanent resolution and should be
resorted to whenever possible business
scenario-based problems where a
resolution technique has to be selected
can be expected in the PMP exam so
understanding the conflict resolution
techniques is essential in the next
screen let us look into a business
scenario to understand this concept
better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer one of the key
responsibilities of a project manager is
to get work done by the team there are
certain powers that a project manager
can use to get the work done a project
manager has to use a combination of
techniques to get this accomplished
various powers of a project manager are
legitimate or formal reward penalty
expert and referent in legitimate or
formal project manager can formally
assign a work to a team member that he
or she has to do project manager can
reward and recognize the team members
the reward could be as simple as
assigning challenging or sought after
work to a team member this can motivate
good performers on the project sometimes
project manager can penalize the team
members for poor performance some
project managers are able to command
Authority because of their expertise in
a certain field project manager can be
considered as a reference of higher
authority to get the work done sometimes
referent Authority also arises from the
personal charm or Charisma of the
project manager legitimate reward and
penalty are the powers derived from the
project manager's position in the
company expert power exists when the
project manager is an expert on the
subject matter reward and expert are
usually the best forms of authority to
use penalty is the worst way of
influencing and managing the team a
project manager should resort to this
only as a last option regardless of the
project manager having formal reporting
authority over the team they are
naturally looked upon as the leaders for
their projects project managers need to
be familiar with the leadership styles
and be able to tailor their style
according to the needs of the project
and that of the team there are three
leadership styles the first one is
authoritarian or autocratic in this
style the leader sets clear expectations
of the team and expects complete
compliance in a participative or
Democratic style the leader offers
guidance but also involves the team in
decision making in a delegative or
laissez-faire style the leader leaves
the work to the team without offering
much guidance in most circumstances you
would want your leader to employ a
participative style but there may be
occasions when other styles might be
appropriate in the next screen let us
discuss McKenzie's 7s framework
a popular framework in management
science is the McKenzie's 7s framework
there are seven elements that are
divided into two categories an
organization working on a project will
have these elements already in place and
hence these become the hard elements the
first three elements of the 7s framework
are the strategy structure and systems
the leader or project manager is
expected to step in and exhibit soft
elements to earn the mantle of
leadership
the next four elements are shared values
Skills style and staff
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
eighth knowledge area that is Project
risk management and its processes risk
is an uncertain event or condition that
can affect a project positively or
negatively although most of the time you
view this uncertainty as bad sometimes
it also has a likely positive outcome
let us look at an example of risk having
a positive outcome you're using a
software for managing timesheet of your
team members due to budget constraints
you are forced to use a new software
though you are initially reluctant to
use it you found the new software to do
better than the current one it is more
efficient and has better reporting
facility an example of bad uncertainty
can be swine flu government declares
mandatory holiday to check flu spread
which may affect your project object
work risks can be managed only if they
are measured quantitatively Suppose
there are many risks identified in a
project and you have limited resources
to manage them you should know which
risk is most important that has to be
managed first therefore measuring risk
becomes very critical risk is measured
by assigning a monetary value to it and
that value is arrived at by multiplying
the probability and impact of the risk
risk can be categorized in various ways
one such categorization is external
internal technical or project management
related risk external risk arises out of
external policies or regulations for
example government policy that the river
water can be used for drinking purposes
May hinder your production which is
dependent on the river water internal
risk arises from within the project for
example the complexity of the work may
result in time and cost escalation
technical risks arise from the
technology being used projects and space
exploration have a lot of technical
complexity risks could be related to
project management for example if there
are many interdependencies between the
sub-projects it is a risk from the
project management standpoint
the categorization of risk can be based
on the origin risks can be classified as
scope risk resource risk schedule risk
cost risk and quality risk
scope risk can include redoing the same
task if the scope is not well understood
when the only resource is assigned to
some other project it is called resource
risk a decision tree helps in analyzing
risk and its impact on making decisions
in a scenario where there is uncertainty
on the outcome suppose you want to buy a
car you can buy either a new car or an
old car which one should you buy which
has more risk over a period of five
years consider the concept of decision
tree to solve this problem the initial
cost of buying a new car is twenty
thousand dollars and the cost of buying
an old car is fifteen thousand dollars
for a new car the probability of it
having any problem fail scenario is only
10 percent that is there is a 90
likelihood that it will just work
without any problems past scenario and
if it does have any at all the impact of
the problem is fifteen thousand dollars
the reason is that it was bought at a
higher cost an old car has seventy
percent probability of having a problem
the reason being the probability is high
because the car was already used by
someone else in the past however the
impact here is low say ten thousand
dollars if you add probability
multiplied by impact of both the options
at the decision nodes you will find
buying an old car over a period more
risky than buying a new car the project
cost will be arrived at after
considering the risk reserves of both
the known risks and unknown risks there
is a specific order in which these
reserves are calculated in the project
cost First the cost of all activities is
identified activities are the smallest
unique project tasks all the activity
costs add up to the cost of the work
packages work packages are the last
level of classification and a work
breakdown structure work packages costs
adds up to the control account cost one
or more work packages are clubbed
together to create a control account and
manage the cost of the work packages
next the project costs are identified
there can be multiple control accounts
in a project now once the project cost
is calculated some Reserve is added to
take care of any uncertainties you may
have made some assumptions to calculate
the cost of the activities and by adding
some Reserve you would want to take care
of those uncertainties in this case make
a note that you are accounting for the
assumptions made and it can be said that
this Reserve takes care of known
uncertainties this Reserve is also
called contingency reserve at this point
you have arrived at the cost Baseline
that is the cost for the project that
will be used for budgeting and tracking
purposes once the planned cost is
arrived the there is another Reserve
that gets added called management
Reserve note that management reserves
are not part of the cost Baseline and
are used during emergencies only by
adding contingency reserve you have
taken care of known uncertainties and by
adding management Reserve you take care
of unknown uncertainties that is those
risks that perhaps have not yet been
identified unknown uncertainties are
added based on experience or expert
judgment project risk management
includes the processes of conducting
risk management planning identification
analysis response planning and
controlling risk on a project the key
objective of risk management is to
increase the probability and or impact
of positive events and decrease the
probability and or impact of negative
events there are six risk management
processes
plan risk management identify risks
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis and
plan risk responses belong to the
project Planning Group and control risks
belong to the monitoring and controlling
process group in this lesson we will
focus on Project stakeholder management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the 10th
knowledge area that is Project
stakeholder management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand who
stakeholders are
a stakeholder is anybody who has a stake
in the project a stakeholder may be an
individual a group or an organization
who may affect or be affected by or
perceive to be affected by a decision
activity or outcome of a project further
the nature of the impact can be positive
or negative thus giving rise to the
notion of positive or negative
stakeholders irrespective of whether a
stakeholder is positive or negative it
is important to engage with the
stakeholders and get them involved in
the project this can make a critical
difference to the success or failure of
the project a single disgruntled
stakeholder can bring the entire project
to its knees whereas an actively engaged
and influential stakeholder can have the
opposite effect let us understand who
the common stakeholders of a project are
there are several categorizations of
stakeholders the project managers
themselves are important stakeholders
the project team members represent
stakeholders in the project the Senior
Management of the organization which is
working on the project has a stake in
the project the sponsor that is the
person or entity that provides the money
and resources for the project and
essentially Champions the project is an
important stakeholder the customer which
may be different from the sponsor is a
stakeholder as well for instance and
many of the projects in the social
sector the sponsor may be the government
or a development agency whereas the
customers would be the people who
actually benefit from it the end users
which may be different from the
customers or the sponsors are
stakeholders too the vendors or
suppliers who provide goods or services
to the project are important
stakeholders people whose lives may be
impacted by the output of the project
are also stakeholders for example if a
highway project requires possession of
privately owned land people whose land
is being taken away are the stakeholders
if the construction of a dam or water
reservoir benefits the downstream
farming communities they are the
stakeholders here competitors who
provide alternative goods or services
are stakeholders too sometimes
environmentalists or other social groups
may become stakeholders the government
or political leadership may become
stakeholders for projects in the public
domain it is sufficient to state that
there could potentially be hundreds of
stakeholders for a large project it is
in the interest of the project manager
and the project team to clearly identify
all such stakeholders up front and then
actively manage them throughout the
project in the next screen let us
discuss the classification models for
stakeholder analysis
not all the stakeholders have the same
amount of influence or power over the
project therefore the way to manage each
stakeholder needs to be calibrated based
on a proper classification of the
stakeholders this is the role of the
classification model you can come up
with a grid that Maps the power of the
stakeholders the interest they have the
influence they may have or the impact
that they can have on the project
through the power interest power
influence or influence impact grids it
can be represented by mapping
stakeholders to a power or interest grid
the diagram on the screen has x-axis
which represents interest level and
y-axis which represents the power level
based on the various combinations of
power levels and interest levels the
grid can be divided into four quadrants
the stakeholders on the top right
quadrant with high power and high
interest need to be managed closely that
is you have to monitor their involvement
and engagements very closely the
stakeholders on the bottom right
quadrant with high interest but low
power need to be kept in the loop that
is you should share information with
them and keep them regularly informed
the stakeholders on the top left
quadrant with high power but low
interest can be managed by keeping them
happy for example by making sure that
their interests and opinions are taken
into consideration the stakeholders on
the left bottom quadrant with low power
and low interest may be managed less
actively by simply monitoring how things
are going with them the salience model
describes classes of stakeholders based
on their power ability to impose their
will
urgency need for immediate attention and
legitimacy appropriateness of their
involvement level this is a useful
framework to guide the stakeholder
management strategy on a project
practice creating power grids for
business scenarios this will help in
understanding the level of Engagement of
project manager needs to maintain with
various stakeholders
in the next screen let us discuss the
stakeholder engagement assessment Matrix
the stakeholder engagement assessment
Matrix allows visualizing the current
and desired states of a stakeholder's
involvement in the project the five
levels of involvement are as unaware
resistant neutral supportive and leading
unaware is where the stakeholder is not
aware of the project or its impact
resistant is where the stakeholder is
aware of the impacts and is resistant to
change neutral is where the stakeholder
is aware of the project and is neither
supportive nor in opposition to the
project supportive is where the
stakeholder is aware of the project and
its impact and is supportive of the
change leading is where the stakeholder
is aware of the project and impacts and
is actively engaged to ensure that the
project is successful
let us now look at the Matrix the table
has one row per stakeholder identified
you place C in the column which best
indicates the current level of
Engagement for that stakeholder then you
place D in the column which best
indicates the desired state of
Engagement this table can be a quick
visualization tool that helps understand
where work has to be done in the
stakeholder management activities in the
next screen let us discuss the skills
required for stakeholder management
stakeholder management is both an art
and a science
since it involves dealing with people
and people are inherently non-linear and
unpredictable there is no one size that
fits all strategies or tools that will
work while managing them
however a project manager may use a few
traits and techniques while managing
stakeholders which are classified as
interpersonal skills and managerial
skills a project manager must possess
good interpersonal skills that is must
invest the time and energy to build
trust this involves multiple things such
as establishing a personal Rapport
following through on commitments being
punctual Etc once the trust is
established it helps in smoothing many
difficult bends conflict management is
an important skill for a project manager
while communicating with stakeholders
the project manager must practice active
listening they must not assume that they
have all the answers
instead they should spend some time to
understand the issues and the
stakeholders points of view this alone
can go a long way in smoothing ruffled
feathers and building constructive
relationships resistance to change is
natural a project manager must know how
to convert that into a positive energy
in its favor managerial skills that may
help in accomplishing the project
objectives a project manager must be
able to build consensus among the group
while absolute uniformity may not always
be possible or desirable the project
manager must use techniques to ensure
widespread discussions and arrive at a
path that the group can buy into the
project manager must be able to
influence people often without
necessarily being in the position of
authority
the project manager must be skillful to
negotiate agreements the project manager
must be able to understand and modify
organizational behavior in order to move
the project in a certain direction
Network diagram is extensively used in
the project time management knowledge
area to plot the activity dependencies
this is a graphical representation of
the project activities in the form of a
network
there are two ways to draw a network
diagram
in precedence diagramming model PDM or
activity on node Aon boxes represent
activities and the arrows indicate the
dependency this type of network can have
all four types of relationships between
the activities
in Arrow diagramming model ADM or
activity on Arrow AOA the arrows
represent activities the relationships
and sequences can be inferred from the
direction of the arrows and linkages
between the activities
and such types of network only finish to
start relationships can be shown
such diagrams may need to make use of
dummy activities to indicate some
dependency between the activities
there may be questions in the PMP exam
based on the network diagram so create
and work with the diagram this will make
answering Network diagram based
questions easy and fun
in the next screen let us look at a
network diagram
a sample Network diagram is shown on the
screen activities A and C can happen in
parallel B and D require both A and C to
complete whereas e requires both B and D
to complete activity on Arrow Network
diagram makes use of hammock activities
they are used to show a comprehensive
summary activity combining several other
activities underneath for control and
Reporting purposes in this lesson we
will focus on Project scope management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the
second knowledge area that is Project
scope management and its processes let
us begin with the first topic of this
lesson that is Project scope management
project scope management includes the
processes required to ensure that a
project comprises all and only the work
required to complete the project
successfully the project scope
management is concerned about the scope
what is not there in the scope is also
clearly identified
in the next screen let us look at the
Key activities performed under project
scope management
let us look at a few of the typical
activities that happen as part of the
project scope management
constant monitoring is essential to make
sure that all the project work is being
completed the gradual uncontrolled
increase in scope of the project is
referred as scope creep
it is necessary to define the project
scope boundaries and not let people
randomly add to the project scope
gold plating is doing more than what is
required as part of the Project's scope
this has to be avoided in projects as
per the published statistics about
projects done globally less than 40
percent of projects can be considered
successful therefore the focus should be
on what is required rather than
squandering around with what is not
required forty percent might be
considered less but a project is
classified as successful only if it
meets all its objectives and is done
within time and cost budgets
in the next screen let us understand the
differences between product scope and
project scope
project scope management deals with
managing both the product scope as well
as the project scope
product scope refers to the features and
functions that characterize a product
service or result
the word product may also include
creation of a service for example in the
banking industry each of their services
is called a product
likewise a savings account is one of
their products mutual fund is another on
the other hand project scope is the work
that needs to be accomplished to deliver
the output of the project which could be
a product service or result with the
specific features and functions
for instance to deliver a product you
may also need to produce a requirements
document or a design document
these are not part of the product scope
but it may very well be part of the
project scope
and the next screen let us discuss a few
key terms used in the project scope
management
WBS stands for work breakdown structure
it means breaking the project
deliverables into smaller and more
manageable components called wart
packages the last level of work in such
subdivision is called work packages and
the whole structure is called WBS
for example a typical software
development project would have various
activities like finalizing requirements
designing the new system coding testing
and going live with the new system each
of these translates into high-level
deliverables which can be further
subdivided into smaller activities which
are more predictable
WBS dictionary like any dictionary
contains the explanation of the terms
used in WBS
a typical WBS dictionary has details
like the control account name of the
work package description of the work
package resource assigned if there are
any assumptions or dependencies to
complete the work package the due date
to finish the work package Technical
dependencies and so on
WBS dictionary is useful for the person
or group working on the work packages as
it further elaborates the decomposed
work package
control account is a level within WBS at
which management wishes to exercise
control for example perform earned value
analysis Track Performance
Etc in this lesson we will focus on
Project integration management
there are 47 processes in project
management grouped into 10 knowledge
areas and mapped to five process groups
in this lesson we will look at the first
knowledge area that is Project
integration management and its processes
in the next screen let us understand the
concept of project integration
management
project integration management involves
unification consolidation articulation
and integrative actions that are crucial
for successfully completing the project
the project integration management is
high-level work that project manager
does and it involves managing
interdependencies among the other
knowledge areas the other nine knowledge
areas involve detailed work in a
specific direction for example project
cost management Deals Only with how to
manage cost in a project
the project management processes do not
happen independently for example a new
resource added to the project may
require changes in cost or schedule or
both
in dealing with such situations the
project manager integrates the processes
of project management the need for
integration drives much of the
communication and the work of the
project manager
let us discuss the key role of project
manager sponsor and team in the next
screen
project manager team members and project
sponsors have different roles to play in
a project
the project manager is supposed to play
multiple roles in the project the key
role is to perform integration
the project manager puts all the pieces
of the project together into a cohesive
whole in doing so the project manager
tries to ensure that the project is done
faster cheaper and utilizes resources
optimally while meeting the project
objectives
as the project progresses the team
members work on completing the project
activities the role of the Project's
sponsor is to protect project from any
unnecessary changes and to ensure that
it has the required resources for
completion the Project's sponsor is the
champion for the project within the
Performing organization that is the
organization in which the work is being
performed
in the next screen we will cover the
project selection methods
an organization can undertake a project
under contract with an external
organization or take up a project driven
by internal business needs
there should be a formal process of
selecting project in all organizations
to ensure that it is making the best
possible use of limited corporate
resources
for example if the organization has an
option to take up any one out of the two
projects both of which use the same
corporate resources the organization
would naturally select the one which is
more profitable
there are two broad ways to select a
project one way is the benefit
measurement method where one project is
compared with other competing projects
another approach is based on
mathematical models wherein you examine
the most optimal selection of projects
by trying to optimize a goal for example
maximize operating profits such methods
may be called constrained optimization
methods
there are different methods under both
these categories and you should be
familiar with the names of these methods
broadly the benefit measurement methods
focus on ascertaining the costs and
benefits of undertaking the project
the methods under benefit measurement
method include murder board where a
panel of experts shoots down a new
project idea peer review scoring models
economic models and benefit compared to
cost
the constrained optimization methods
rely on mathematical modeling techniques
to determine the best selection of
projects to achieve certain business
objectives
the methods of constrained optimization
method include linear programming
in reality you might not have seen these
methods to be followed in Project
selection
often personal relationship with the
sponsor may be more important than
anything else this is quite normal and
any organization worldwide works this
way however as a certified project
manager it is important for you to be
familiar with more scientific methods of
project selection
a typical question on the PMP exam could
be what type of project selection
technique is peer review and the right
answer is benefit measurement method you
need to understand the characteristics
of various project selection methods to
answer scenario-based questions in the
next screen we will focus on the project
selection methods
there are five project management
processes which are part of project
integration management knowledge area
they are the develop project Charter
done in the initiation process group
develop project management plan
undertaken in the planning process group
direct and manage work carried out in
the executing process group Monitor and
control project and perform integrated
Change Control undertaken in the
monitoring and controlling process group
and close project or phase done in the
closing process group
foreign
project Charter is an initiating process
a project Charter is essentially a
document that authorizes a project once
a project has received a charter it
means that the project manager can start
employing the organization's resources
for the project activities
let us look at the key inputs to be
considered in preparing the project
Charter
the first input is the project statement
of work this is created by project
sponsor or the customer describing their
needs project scope and how the project
fits into their strategic goal if the
project is taken up under a contract the
request for proposal that is RFP can be
considered as project statement of work
the next input is the business case this
document establishes whether the
investment in a project is worth from a
business point of view the business need
for the project and the cost benefit
analysis it provides important
information to the project manager about
the goals of the project and the
boundaries in terms of the desired
results cost Etc
if the project is being undertaken as
part of a contract or agreement the
agreement provides an important input
for the project manager that establishes
what must be done in the project
the next input to be considered for
project Charter is Enterprise
environmental factors
any project to be executed within the
organization has to deal with the
organization culture and existing
systems you can consider this as an
organization baggage that comes with the
project this is the reason a project
being executed in two different
organizations may be done differently
another factor to be considered is
organizational process assets
this is a broad term and includes all
the organizational processes procedures
and policies corporate knowledge base
and historical project information
every organization develops a set of
processes procedures and policies that
are based on the best practices learned
by the organization over time the
historical information includes past
project management plans risks Lessons
Learned Etc of similar projects executed
now let us look at the tools and
techniques used in this process
the first technique is expert judgment
expert judgment is an invaluable input
to the process of formally authorizing a
project because an expert can provide
insights into why a project makes
business sense or why it does not from
experience they may be able to shed
light about the validity of the business
drivers feasibility assumptions and
constraints that need to be considered
for the project
facilitation techniques is another
technique used the chartering process is
often a collaborative activity involving
many influential stakeholders in an
organization
facilitation techniques help bring all
these stakeholders together and engage
in fruitful discussions in order to
arrive at an informed decision whether
to go ahead with a project or not
the only output of this project is the
project Charter let us try to understand
what the project Charter might contain
project Charter usually contains the
high-level project requirement and it
should be created by the project sponsor
and handed over to the project manager
the project manager can do the
groundwork to prepare the project
Charter but it must be signed by the
project sponsor or somebody in the
Performing organization who is higher in
Authority than the project manager
it is important to point out that a
project Charter is not a project
management plan the detailed risk
schedule cost analysis Etc is part of
the project management plan and should
be done during the project planning
phase when there is more detail on the
availability of the project to do so the
charter should be sufficiently high
level to accommodate the minor changes
that might arise in the project
in this lesson we will focus on project
management processes
project lifecycle addresses the question
what to do to get the work done
it varies industry-wise for example let
us look at a typical Project Life Cycle
in a software industry first you
understand what is required and analyze
it as part of the requirement analysis
phase then as part of the design phase
you figure out the implementation of it
and arrive with the approach next you
implement the functionality by writing
the code as part of the coding phase the
code is then verified to ensure it works
right as part of the testing phase the
tested and verified software is then
installed at the customer locations as
part of the installation phase after the
installation the system then moves into
operations and support phase
the project management process addresses
the question what to do to manage the
project
the process is for managing the projects
are likely to be the same across
Industries
for instance in the develop schedule
process one needs to develop the project
schedule irrespective of the industry or
domain you're working
in the next screen let us understand the
project management process groups
the project management processes are
divided into five process groups they
are initiating process group planning
process group executing process group
monitoring and controlling process group
and closing process group
the initiating process happens at the
beginning of the project or a phase the
planning executing ads monitoring and
controlling processes go together
therefore you plan execute and replan
based on the execution result
the project closing processes are
performed when the project work or a
phase within the project is completed
the typical project management process
and the closing phase releases resources
back to the resource pool so the team
members can be assigned to another
project
note the iteration of processes within
the phases is dependent on the scale of
the projects small projects may have
only one iteration whereas bigger
projects may have multiple iterations
before they enter a new phase
project management processes are
overlapping activities let us look at
the interaction between these activities
in the next screen
process groups have overlapping
activities that occur throughout the
Project Life Cycle
the output of one process group is
generally the input to another or a
deliverable of the project for example
project management plan is an output of
planning process group and an input to
execution process group
note that production of the plan is not
a one-time activity as the project
progresses the project management plan
may get updated as a result of the
monitoring and controlling processes the
updated project management plan once
again forms an input to the execution
process group
in the next screen we will discuss the
project management process group
knowledge area and project management
process mapping
given on the screen is the list of the
47 project management processes 10
knowledge areas and five process groups
the table shows how each of them is
interrelated you can see that the
project integration management processes
can be mapped back to all five process
groups while project scope management
processes are mapped back to only
planning and monitoring process group
study the table to identify processes
under project management and the
knowledge area they belong to all the 47
processes are described in detail in
this tutorial
each knowledge area is covered in detail
as a lesson it also covers how the
process is mapped to process groups to
help you understand the big picture
further the inputs and outputs of each
of these processes tools and techniques
that are used in these processes and
what exactly happens during these
processes are also discussed
earned value technique is an excellent
way to track the project progress
against the project plan it is a method
of measuring the project performance
objectively and comparing it against the
project Baseline results from an earned
value analysis indicate deviation of the
project from cost and schedule baselines
Baseline is the initial approved value
along with approved changes therefore
schedule Baseline is the first approved
project schedule along with approved
changes
there are various terms used in earned
value technique
planned value is the authorized budget
assigned to the scheduled work
earned value is the work performed in
terms of budget authorized for that work
actual cost is the cost incurred in work
performed budget at completion is the
budgeted amount for the total work
estimate at completion is the expected
total cost for the project
to complete is the expected cost to
finish all the remaining Project work
variance at completion is the projected
budget surplus or deficit at the end of
the project all the parameters displayed
on the screen are measured in terms of
cost you may come across business
scenario based questions on earned value
Management in the PMP exam so ensure
that you develop a clear understanding
of this topic let us look at an example
of a planned value in the next screen
planned value is the estimated value of
the work planned this value is measured
in terms of currency say dollar if the
plan value is three hundred forty
dollars then the work plan is worth
three hundred forty dollars
how do you calculate earned value the
solution is add the budget allocated to
each of the activities that have been
completed at the point of time the
resulting value is the earned value
in the next screen let us look at the
formula used to calculate earned value
in cost variance negative means the
project is over budget positive means
the project is under budget similarly in
schedule variants negative means the
project is behind schedule whereas
positive means the project is ahead of
schedule
the value of the next two parameters
cost performance index CPI and schedule
performance index SPI values vary
between 0 and 1. for example a CPI of
0.8 implies that 80 cents of work is
obtained for every dollar spent in the
project
similarly if SPI is 0.9 it implies that
project is progressing at only 90
percent of the speed originally planned
the next parameter is estimate at
completion or EAC
there are different ways of calculating
the EAC value the method used depends on
how the cost and schedule variances are
expected to play for the rest of the
project BAC by CPI is used if you expect
that the current cost performance will
continue until the end of the project
AC plus BAC minus EV is used if you
expect that the rest of the project will
be managed at the budgeted rate
AC plus BAC minus EV by the product of
CPI and SPI is used if you want to
factor in the impact of the cost as well
as schedule variances
AC plus Etc is used if you want to
re-evaluate the Project based on a
forecast value for the estimated cost of
the remainder of the project
the next parameter is estimate to
complete or
Etc which is the cost of project from
this point to the end
this is calculated by subtracting the
actual cost from the estimate at
completion in addition variance at
completion can be calculated by
subtracting the estimate at completion
from the budget at completion variance
at completion is the cost estimation
whether it is over or under budget
another parameter is the to complete
performance index or tcpi this is the
cost performance needed to achieve a
desired outcome
for example if the project needs to be
managed to the original budget BAC then
tcpi that is the CPI that must be
maintained for the rest of the project
is calculated as BAC minus EV by BAC
minus AC
rly if it has to be managed within a
revised Target say EAC then tcpi is
calculated as BAC minus EV by EAC minus
AC before the start of the PMP exam
please make a note of the formulas of
earned value technique in the next
screen let us look into a business
scenario to understand this concept
better after reading the problem
statement click the solution button to
look at a possible answer
let us take the example of a software
development project there are four
phases and each phase takes a month to
complete and is expected to cost ten
thousand dollars the phases are planned
to be completed one after the other the
status of the project at the end of the
month three is summarized in the table
requirements definition is completed and
actual spending on this is ten thousand
dollars
architecture and design is done and
actual spending on this is twelve
thousand dollars development and unit
testing is only fifty percent done
though it was supposed to be completed
by Third month it has cost nine thousand
dollars until date
system testing and go live has not yet
started
Note S indicates start time F indicates
finish time and PF indicates that it is
partly finished at the end of the month
based on the above information calculate
the CV SV CPI and SPI of the project
let us look at a solution in the next
screen
before we end this lesson let us also
look at a few definitions that might be
useful for your PMP examination
law of diminishing return this means the
more you put into something the less you
get out of it for example doubling the
number of resources working on a project
will not necessarily have the time
working capital the amount of money the
company has to invest on the project and
the day-to-day company operations
funding limit reconciliation the process
of comparing the planned expenditure in
a given period with the available
funding for that period
large assets purchased by the company
lose value over time this is called
depreciation there are two forms of
depreciation straight line and
accelerated
same amount of depreciation is taken
every year for instance a car with a
price tag of ten thousand dollars and
useful life of ten years is depreciated
one thousand dollars per year at the end
of the tenth year the value of the car
is considered zero for all accounting
purposes accelerated depreciation
depreciates faster than the
straight-line depreciation for instance
a car with a price tag of ten thousand
dollars depreciates three thousand
dollars the first year one thousand five
hundred the next year one thousand the
third year and so on
critical path is defined as the longest
duration path through a network diagram
which determines the shortest time to
complete the project
float can be considered as a buffer time
available to complete an activity
float is calculated once the network
diagram is ready
it is also called as slack there are
three kinds of float the first being the
total float which is the amount of time
an activity can be delayed without
delaying the project end date or an
intermediary milestone
the second type of float is free float
which is the amount of time an activity
can be delayed without delaying the
early start date of its successor or
successor's activities
the last type is independent float which
is the amount of time an activity can be
delayed if all the predecessors finish
at their latest finish dates and you
want to start all the immediate
successors at their earliest start dates
the slack of the activities on the
critical path is zero because there is
no scope to delay activities on the
critical path
critical path actually represents the
project duration delaying activities on
the critical path is as good as delaying
the project duration
concept-based questions on critical path
can be expected in the exam so it is
essential to have a clear understanding
of the concept
in the next screen let us learn how to
calculate float
let us look at an example for critical
path
there are five activities in this
project and two paths in the network
diagram
start one two four five and is One path
and start one three five and is the
second path
since the duration of the path start one
two four five end is 18 days which is
more than the duration of the path start
one three five and the critical path of
the project is start one two four five
end
let us take Activity 3 as an example
first calculate the early start and
early finish dates
Activity 3 can start only after Activity
one since the early finish of Activity 1
is 3 it becomes the early start of
activity 3. Activity 3 cannot start
earlier than 3 because Activity 1 can be
completed only by then
therefore early start of Activity 3 is
3. since the duration of the activity is
four days
the early finish of Activity 3 is 3 plus
4 equals seven days
now let us calculate the late start and
late finish of activity 3.
late start of Activity 5 is 14 days the
Activity 3 happens just before activity
five so the late finish of Activity 3 is
14 days to calculate the late start you
can subtract the duration from late
finish therefore the late start of
Activity 3 is 14 minus 4 equals 10.
in the next screen let us focus on
schedule compression
hi welcome to project management tools
tutorial from Simply learn I am CMR
Chandra Mr a certified project
management professional as part of this
tutorial we are going to look at about
project management tools essential
features of project management tools top
10 project management tools currently
used in the industry so what is project
management tools why should we use
project management tools while doing
project management so project management
tools help to keep a streamlining flow
in project management processes the
tools help the team are an individual to
carry out the steps of project
management in an effective and efficient
manner so project management tools
features and functionalities so
basically a project management tool
should have minimum fulfilling these
features and functionality they should
be simple to use customizable they
should have API for integration it
should help in collaboration it should
help in Risk analysis and real-time
reporting when we say simple to use the
project management tools need to be
suitable for every project we do one
needs to find a tool that will have a
pleasant interface and increase work
productivity the project management tool
must be easy to configure according to
the organization needs every project
management approach every project
management templates every artifacts
needs tailoring and adaption before
adopting as part of the practice there
are business patterns that change every
day so having customizable tool is an
added Advantage API or application
programming interface enables the
sharing of data and application between
devices the tools with API integration
allow seamless connectivity amongst the
team the project management tools must
allow for collaboration so that whole
team can work together collaboration not
only makes it task easier but also
increases the productivity of the
project risk analysis helps to identify
analyze and respond to the risk quickly
and efficiently it needs to capture all
the details of the risks their impacts
the probability of occurrence of the
risk and risk responses and tracking
them throughout the Project Life Cycle
the real-time reporting enables the
access of data at different locations of
the project management one can assess or
Access Data at any time about the
Project's current status this will help
in having a real-time update about the
project status to the stakeholders of
the project the top 10 project
management tools what we have today in
the market are monday.com Rick jira
software Trello Asana teamwork Meister
task base camp oracles Primavera and
Microsoft project management tool so let
us look at these one by one so
monday.com was released during the year
2012 and it is known for providing
features to enable flexible planning and
monitoring capabilities the website
where you can find monday.com access is
the tool is
www.myday.com so this tool is used by
more than 90 000 team across the globe
monday.com features and functionality
includes it is easy for collaboration
highly customizable excellent for
analytics integration with Dropbox
Google Drive and pipedrive is possible
surprising the basic version is dollar
25 on monthly basis so which will
provide you 5gb storage one board per
dashboard and it is built annually the
standard package includes 5gb storage
three boards per dashboard and it is 39
dollars per month which is billed
annually professional includes unlimited
storage 10 boots per dashboard and it
costs dollar 59 per month and it is
built annually monday.com is used by the
following customers organizations of
monday.com that is karzberg discovered
Channel Adidas storm Phillips Etc Rick
is another project manager tool which
was released in 2006 so this application
provides its user with robust features
and allows them to collaborate with each
other the website to access the tool is
www.rec.com and this is used by over 18
000 organizations across the globe the
features of Rick includes it has
collaborative editing flexible workflow
real-time reporting and efficient Work
Management the pricing includes 0 to 5
users it has basic Integrations and
which is free whereas professional
includes dollar 9.8 per user per month
which is which has a slabs of 5 10 and
15 users and Rick proof free trial
business version has 5 to 200 users and
Rick proof free trial whereas 24.80
dollars per user per month the companies
which uses the rig tools are Airbnb
Laurel TeamViewer Tiffany and Co Etc now
let us look at jira software jira
software was released during year 2002
it is a software development tool used
by agile teams famous for its bug
tracking system the website to access
this tool is
www.atlacion.com software slash jira
used by over 65 000 customers the
features of jira software includes agile
reporting Rich toolkit for developers
bug tracking mobile applications so the
pricing of jira software is as follows
so for forever 2GB storage and Community
Support which cost dollar zero but a
standard is around dollar seven per user
per month which includes 250 GB storage
and 925 standard support premium is
dollar 14 per user per month unlimited
storage and has 24x7 premium support
jira software is used by the
organizations that is Hitachi Visa
Dropbox Nestle Dominos Coca-Cola Samsung
Etc now let us look at the tool Trello
so this application was released in
2011. it is known for providing
flexibility in organizing and
prioritizing the tasks with the help of
its boards lists and cards website to
access the tool is
www.trailo.com used by over 50 million
people the features of Trello includes
smooth editing easy file uploads from
Dropbox or Google Drive high security
standards and easy data searching
techniques so the pricing includes it is
free for 10 mb per attachment and 10
team boards business class includes 250
MB attachment unlimited team boards and
it cost dollar 9.99 per user per month
annually Enterprise version provides 250
MB for attachment unlimited team boots
and costs around 20.83 dollars per 100
users per month the companies who use
Trello or Google Adobe PayPal UNICEF the
New York Times Etc now let us look at
Asana the Asana tool was released during
2008. it is an high quality task
management software that makes the
tracking of tasks easy across the
project management the website to access
this tool is
www.asana.com used by over 140 000
companies the features includes
incredible task management Gantt charts
privacy controls easy progress tracking
the pricing includes the basic model
Asana is provide 0 to 15 people
beginners in the project management so
premium includes custom Fields priority
support where the pricing is dollar
10.99 per user per month annually the
business version includes Advanced
integration priority support and it
costs 24.99 for 100 users per month the
companies which uses Asuna are Deloitte
Vodafone Red Bull Uber Salesforce NASA
Etc let us look at Teamwork tool
teamwork was released during year 2007.
it is a cloud-based project management
solution that helps in managing group
activities and establishing flexible
communication the website to access this
tool is
www.teamwork.com used by our 370 000
organizations the features of teamwork
includes high quality CRM help desk
software risk register and easy time
tracking the pricing includes 0 to 5
users and 100 MB file space is provided
free of cost whereas pro version
includes 5 to 50 users 100 GB file
spaces which cost nine dollars per user
per month premium origin costs around
dollar 15 per user per month which
includes 5 to 100 users and 250 GB file
space the organizations who use
Teamworks are Forbes eBay Microsoft
Studios HP paper pal Disney's Honda now
let us look at the tool Meister task so
this tool was released during year 2015
and it is known for providing automated
and streamlined workflows to make the
overall processes more productive the
website to access this is
www.mastertask.com used by our 2 million
users the features of this tool includes
it is simple to use seamless workflow
Gantt charts flexible project boards the
pricing it is zero dollars per month up
to three projects and unlimited project
members the pro version includes
unlimited projects unlimited
Integrations which costs around 8.25
dollars per user per month whereas
business costs 20.75 dollars per user
per month which has security
restrictions priority email and phone
support the organization who use the
tool are virgin Optics Consulting and
data and supports expert dot d Etc base
camp the base camp tool was released
during the year 1999 it is a real-time
communication tool that allow users to
keep track of priorities and actionable
tasks the website to access this tool is
www.basecamp.com used by over 3 million
users the features of base camp includes
easy to use various third-party
Integrations daily backups and
comprehensive project calendar the
personal version is free and 0 to 20
users and 1GB storage space is provided
in business version it is 99 per month
for unlimited users I have 500 GB
storage space the companies who use
Basecamp is thoughtpot Harvest wlb
Groupon Etc Oracle Primavera so this
tool was released during the year 1983
which is acquired by Oracle Corporation
in the year 2008. Primavera helps
project manager to handle a vast number
of tasks with the help of its unlimited
resources and Target plans website to
access this tool is
www.primavera.com which is used by over
7143 companies so features of Primavera
includes creation of WBS the work
breakdown structure issues and risk
recording supports large number of
activities and easy collaboration with
project users the Enterprise project
portfolio management version costs
around 2750 dollars per user which
improves planning and execution
professional project management version
is USD 2500 per user handles large-scale
highly sophisticated projects so Oracle
Primavera contract management version
module costs around USD 2000 per user
keeps construction projects on schedule
and on budget so the companies which use
Primavera are Burns McDonald's Pond or
caddies Etc Microsoft Project so
Microsoft project management tool was
used during the year 1984 so this tool
allows users to develop a schedule
assign resources track progress and
manage budgets all through the project
the website to access this tool is
www.office.microsoft.com Project the
features of Microsoft Project includes
simple to use effective monitoring easy
communication enhanced decision making
so this is a cloud-based solution and
the pricing is Project plan 1 costs
around dollar 10 per user per month on
an annual commitment managing projects
where web browser is the feature project
plan 3 which costs around dollar 30 per
user per month with annual commitment
which is fully updated project desktop
application project plan 5 which costs
around 55 dollars per user per month
with annual commitment evaluating
project ideas from anywhere in the
organization is possible through this
project standard 2019 version costs
around 620 dollars per PC per user for
those who don't need collaboration tools
and advanced features project
professional version 2019 costs around
1030 dollars per PC per user syncing
with Project online and project server
the organization which uses Microsoft
projects are comptel Airbus Intel Volvo
Xerox Etc hey guys
so without further Ado let's get started
with what exactly is Trello
so Trello is a simple and easy to use
collaboration tool that can enable you
to organize projects and everything
related to it into boards with Trello
you can find all kinds of information
like what's being worked on who's
working on what and what progress the
project is making now we'll learn about
that in a little bit while we're talking
about the Trello demo
now let's talk about the advantages of
Trello
now first off cello can be used
immediately after signing up so Trello
offers you a free sign up after which
you get access to almost all of trello's
features now it does have a premium
service but most fellow's important
features are available in the free
account
secondly it follows the kanban system so
the kanban system is a popular
methodology that can be used to achieve
lean
so with Trello you can also achieve lean
now Trello also has a very popular
mobile application which also has the
same features as the interface that you
see on the desktop that's very user
friendly
now the fourth Advantage is that all
project related items can be seen on one
page which means everything you need
about the project is available in one
place
next adding new members creating issues
and assigning them are very easy with
the help of Trello
now that we had a look at all the
advantages that are provided by Trello
let's have a look at a live demo
so first off let's go to trello.com
so here you can see two options to log
in or sign up so first of all if you've
never used the website before go to sign
up
so here you can enter your email or you
can go through Google or Hotmail or
Outlook so it's very simple I already
have an account so I'll just log in
right so I'm just going to log in
so if you're using cello for the first
time this is what it would look like
so here you have personal boards
templates home and so on so let's go one
by one
firstly the most important thing that
you need to know about is boards which
is right here so let's assume you're
using this for a deal which means that
you need people to share the board along
with
so first of all let's create a team
so here I'm just going to name a company
called company code
say we do engineering on t
this is right up brief team description
and continue so here say I have four
members so I have Bob
I'm adding them here so depending on
what your team is like you can add those
team members so this is important so
that you can connect with them while
you're on the board so this is
company.com so we'll just add them
so the team members that you're going to
invite will get an invite email very
soon as soon as you're done by clicking
the invite to team button
we'll also add Bill who also works at my
company
and there's technician one
is technician one who works at
company.com
we'll add anybody who's required later
so invite to team
and there you go there's some details
here about the team and all that let's
go back to home
and now let's create a new board under
company code so the difference here is
that for personal boards is that like
the name says it's personal you can also
add the team if you want later on but
here you have the option for creating a
team Port so I'll show you how you can
create a team board from personal board
so you got create board
here you can show as this is by default
selected is no team because it's under
personal change it to company
and you can write
business anything else like that
and then you create a board
and there you go the board has been set
up
so now
first things first it's that you can
make this team visible which is
either only board members can see it or
since it's a small team the entire team
can seek it so it's up to you how you
want it there's the public option which
everyone can see which I don't think is
necessary but if you feel like it you
can do that too
first of all you can even write a
description of the board which is what
you want to achieve with this board for
example this is business or sales or
something like that you can change the
background into something more colorful
or less colorful like this
and then
there's search cards which we haven't
added anything so far so there's nothing
to search the stickers
which again is I feel unnecessary at the
moment you can also see something called
Butler So based on your usage or how
you're using Trello Butler can provide
you suggestions like what you can add
here like you can see here
the tips haven't been added so far
because we haven't used Trello so far
So based on your usage it'll give you
suggestions
now let's go back
so here QC power ups so power-ups are
basically additional features that you
can add to your board
so there are features that are connected
to a number of different fields there's
analytics automation utilities tools and
so on
so as a free user you get access to one
power up but still we don't have to use
it so far because
we don't have anything on our board but
based on your requirement you can go
through these power ups and decide on
one of them
so now let's get back to business or
about so first you can see add a list
so this basically refers to the
different processes that you want to
follow in this board so first of all
We'll add a list title I'm going to add
2 2
that's the first list
then that's in progress
on hold
and complete it
so here we have four lists which
represent the processes in this business
so if you want you can even add another
list depending on your requirement so in
these lists there are things called
cards so which are like subtopics so
first of all let's add
very simple
title for example
deliver product
company
a second very simple the lower product
B
like this so on and so forth if you want
it
so here this is a card so this card can
be moved from each stage to another as
it progresses
so this is in the to-do stage since we
have not started with anything
so once you click on a card so this
pop-up shows up so here you can add a
description like conversed with company
a
ready to go
just some details that you want to add
you save
now one thing you can see add to cart so
there are a number of different things
you can add to this card
so members
now I have four team members I can add
Bob
here I want Bob in on this I want Bob to
see the activities as it happens I want
Bill to also see as things proceed
right so the Bob and Bill are in on this
right now
next you have labels so depending on
what you want to use this for for
example I want to use this to represent
that it's important or immediate
put it as red save so I can select this
label to indicate that this is now very
important so depending on your company's
you know style or depending on your
requirements you can add the labels
then you have a checklist so different
steps can be focused on with this
checklist for example I'm just going to
write steps
so we're delivering a product for
example so let's just
use steps government Gathering I'm just
going to write the
software life cycle steps analysis
design
implementation
testing
employment
and maintenance
so yeah we have all the steps so one
thing is that once each of these steps
are done
you ticket
so a percentage increases so until
you're done with hundred percent you can
just keep taking finally it will show
100 and you're done
so another thing is a due date so this
is basically by when you want it
completed
so this is basically a reminder that we
need to complete it or for a particular
date is done so I'm not adding it to
your data as of now but that's up to you
next you have something called
attachment so say for example all your
requirements have been gathered into one
PDF so where all the requirements that
are required by the company are shown in
that PDF you can attach it here so that
everyone has access to it then a cover
can also be added to your card which is
just basically beautifying it so we can
find one
example this
and there you go there's a pretty good
looking cow here
now we have all the information so let's
get started
so to officially Mark the beginning of
the project we'll just go and put this
to in progress so at the same time you
can do the same thing with this card as
well about Company B so let's just focus
on company a now
so say the steps have already started
requirement Gathering is done designing
is done implementation is also done so
depending on the person you know the
technician so the technician could
respond that you know we've already
started so before that we need to add
the technician he's already on this but
if you had to add him you search for
main bus
and you have board members who's already
in the board you can add the technician
now you can also you know add activity
details like technician one
how's it going how's the process going
now he could respond here with it's
fine
so each time one of us you know adds the
other or says something to the other
they get notifications so that you know
they get to respond as well they get to
know what's happening
now
let's say for example the technician is
not able to complete the project or
complete his work so it's put on hold so
here I could say
so testing isn't done so you can say
by the delay or what's going on
and he would given a property response
and once he's ready he can finish the
texting
and put it back to in progress then
eventually all of it is done deployment
and maintenance
so here you have an option to hide
complete items that's up to you you can
also delete them if you feel like it you
can close this and then after everything
is done and you feel that everything of
the process is done you can put it on
completed so if this is a recurring
process you can you know make a copy of
this which you can find by doing this
copy or you could just put this on
archive
indicating that it's done you can even
get it back by just going
more
archived items and then there you have
it you can send it back to board that's
up to you
and there you go that's most of
everything you need to know about Trello
one another thing is that right now you
can only add 10 boards on this feed as
of now because you're using a free
membership also depending on the
intensity or the difficulty of the board
you can also have different
boards for different projects I've just
used one for multiple projects but it's
entirely possible for you to have one
board per project you can also you know
favorite this indicating that this is a
very important one that you need to
focus on every day so this is where you
get all the notifications that access
change there you go all kinds of
responses everything that you need is
available on this home screen which is
basically like a home feed you can also
find templates depending on your
requirement
so you can choose a template from a wide
variety of options so I'm just going to
show you the kanban template
so here you have details about the
template you have an example of what the
template looks like and so on
and there you go that's everything you
need to know about Trello in this
session we will be talking about agile
project management and several other
things related to it before we begin
let's have a look at all the topics we
will be covering today first we will see
the basics of agile project management
then we will check the relevance and
principles of agile project management
we will then see necessary steps to
implement agile methodology along with
that we shall also see different
Frameworks involved in the process and
finally we shall see some companies that
use agile project management so without
any further Ado let's get started with
what is agile project management agile
project management as the name suggests
is a flexible approach to building a
project in agile project management the
project is broken down into several
stages or Sprints agile does not work on
the principle of delivering the final
product at the end of the project it
works on delivering sections of a
project or mini projects the process of
project management in the case of agile
is agile based so there won't be any
central control of project manager as it
was there in the traditional way of
working before we move forward let's
have a look at the Agile development
cycle agile methodologies consists of
several small Cycles or Sprints at the
end of each stage we get a mini project
there's a product backlog that explains
new features changes in the existing
features and several other improvements
in the project then we have a Sprint
backlog which has a list of tasks that
are to be completed during each spread
the Sprint consists of planning
designing execution testing and
deployment stages and at the end of each
Sprint a mini project is delivered with
every Sprint new features are added to
the product which plays a significant
role in the overall project growth after
all the Sprints and early validation in
the development the final deliverable
has a fewer chances of failure let's now
have a look at some reasons why
Industries have started moving towards
agile project management the first
reason is high product quality when we
talk about high product quality we refer
to the buildup the product as per
stakeholders demands testing is
performed at Short intervals of time
wherever needed to ensure high quality
of the product then another reason is
customer satisfaction whatever is done
in the project is known by the customer
the deliveries don't take longer
durations as they used to take in the
case of traditional ways the changes may
be provided by the customer in the
execution phase of the project third
reason is reduced risk since the project
is divided into Sprints so if the risk
affects one Sprint it doesn't mean whole
of the project will be at risk the
process of risk analysis continues to
take place with all the other processes
another significant reason for agile
project management is better and faster
return on investment the project is now
developed in several Sprints and each
Sprint has its own version therefore the
project becomes Market ready after a few
Sprints only since the projects can now
be released with ease and shorter
duration this helps the organization to
stay ahead in competition with respect
to other organizations which are still
not moved to Agile methodology now we
shall check the principles of agile
project management there are 10
principles for successful agile project
management the first principle is the
satisfaction of the customer by
delivering the project fast and with
least number of Errors the next
principle refers to decreasing the
amount of time between the phase of
planning and delivery the third
principle states that the team of
managers and developers work together
and increase the productivity of their
work the next principle states that the
changes requested by the stakeholders
can be taken into consideration and
worked upon during the development phase
as well the fifth principle pays
attention to the factor of coordination
among the team members then the sixth
principle refers to the process of
monitoring and tracking the progress of
the project at the end of each Sprint
and making amendments wherever needed
moving on the next principle states that
there must be a feeling of trust and
support towards the team to complete the
Project's objectives the next principle
emphasizes on face-to-face conversations
with the development team the
face-to-face conversation helps in both
solving problems and easy knowledge
sharing then the nine principle
emphasizes on finding Solutions and
maximizing the amount of work done with
Simplicity this ensures timely
completion of tasks by all the team
members the last principle states that
scrum tools like monday.com or Zoho
Sprints must be used to simplify the
complicated codes which further helps in
Saving Time We Shall now see the steps
in agile project management the goal of
agile methodology is to produce shorter
development life cycles and more
frequent product releases than
traditional waterfall project management
so we will now check six steps in agile
project methodology the first step in
the process is Project planning project
planning includes feasibility study
development of scope breaking the
project into executable tasks or Sprints
and then estimating the amount of time
needed to complete those prints the
second step is the step of roadmap
creation a road map is a plan of action
that shows how a project shall evolve
over time a list of all the features
that the final product should have is
created and the steps to achieve those
features are taken the next important
step is release planning since we are
doing the project keeping in mind the
agile project methodology the project
will complete in Sprints that means
there will be the release of features at
the end of each cycle and unlikely
traditional waterfall model the
development Cycles will be smaller the
fourth step in agile project management
is Sprint planning the Sprints are made
keeping in mind what all is to be
accomplished in that particular Step At
the beginning of each Sprint the goal of
that Sprint is decided and steps to
achieve that goal are taken the next
step in the process emphasizes on daily
meetings there are short meetings every
day to discuss if the team was able to
finish the task for each Sprint and
check if there are any amendments that
are required each team member talks
about what they achieved in the last
print and what are the they going to
work on in the next print the last step
is the step of Sprint review and
retrospective there are two meetings
after each Sprint first meeting is for
the Sprint review this meeting is with
the stakeholders to show them the
finished product this helps both sides
to build a relationship and discuss if
there are any issues in the end product
the second meeting is for having a
Sprint retrospective this meeting
involves the stakeholders to discuss
what went well and what went wrong
during the Sprint Sprint rate
perspective takes place after the Sprint
review and before the next print
planning now when we know the steps
needed for agile project methodology we
must understand some agile project
management Frameworks there are several
Frameworks available today here we will
be discussing some of the most popular
Frameworks the first framework we will
discuss is the kanban framework kanban
framework is a well-known framework for
implementing agile software development
in the case of kanban framework work
items are represented on the kanman
board with helps all the team members to
see the state of every piece of work at
any time kanman board not only helps in
visualizing the work but also optimizing
the workflow among the team the next
framework we will discuss today is the
scrum framework scrum framework is a
popular framework for managing complex
knowledge work like in the field of
research and Advanced Technologies scrum
is a simple framework that helps team
work together and learn through their
experiences gained while working on a
problem the third framework we will see
today is the hybrid framework the hybrid
framework is a combination of agile
methodology and non-agile methodology in
the case of a hybrid framework planning
is done using the traditional way of
project management while the execution
and delivery is done using the agile
methodology since the hybrid is a
combination of the two it handles the
requirement changes and delivers the
product in different stages the fourth
and the last framework we will see is
the lean framework the lean framework
works on the principle of providing
maximum customer value and creating zero
waste it focuses on optimizing the flow
of products all through the value stream
this helps in eliminating waste all
through the process and create processes
that requires less human efforts this
also simplifies the process of
information management and makes it more
accurate finally let's have a look at
some companies that have opted for agile
project management today around 22
percent of the organizations worldwide
have all their teams working on the
principle of agile project methodology
let's have a look at some of the most
prominent companies in the world that
use agile project management in the list
we have IBM Cisco atnt Microsoft Philips
and Samsung welcome to simple learns PMP
6th edition training tutorial I am CMR
Chandra Mr a certified project
management professional Prince to
practitioner itl expert itl for managing
professional kobit 5 and devops today we
are going to look at understanding what
is the PMP certification what is PMB
okay eligibility criteria to appear in
PMP examination the project management
framework the project management process
groups knowledge areas and processes so
now Imagining the world where you have a
project being done and you are the
project manager and how best a project
can be conducted so to make a project
successful it is required to follow a
best practice so if you have a
certification just imagine having a
certification that lets the world know
that you know what you are doing in
project management so PMP certification
gives you all so what is PMP
certification
so the PMP the project management
professional certification is a
certification of PMI the project
management Institute which is at USA so
is an internationally recognized
credential for project managers see the
certification indicates that the
certified professional has a sufficient
experience education skills and
competency reason being before going for
PMP certification it asks for specific
prerequisites which involves experience
in project management as well as formal
education of project management and
demonstrated skills so that being a
prerequisite for project management
professional certifications it is very
essential that one need to understand
what it takes to become eligible for PMP
examination so that we will go through
in the subsequent slides so the moment
one has the PMP certification that
itself indicates the prerequises to take
a PMP certification is accomplished
already before going for certification
and then the individual will go for a
certification and become certified
professional so that way it concludes it
also in the indicates that person who
holds the PMP certification has
sufficient experience education skills
and competency moreover there are more
than 10 hundred thousand PMP
certification holders across the globe
so PMP certified individuals earn 25
percent more than non-certified
individuals so now PMP certification
also has the advantages which are given
here like helps the project manager to
practice the project management better
create the results better demonstrate
the project management capability better
so this also helps project manager to
show the commitment towards the project
management profession and having PMP
certification provides the recognition
across the globe which helps in getting
better salary compared with people the
professionals who are not certified and
also helps in increasing the network
project management Network who actually
practices project management the fellow
practice project managers who are
practicing the project management so
there are certain vocabularies jargons
which are used specifically while doing
the project management PMP helps to
understand those so now let us look at
what does the official guide which is
used
in PMP that can help to become a project
management professionals
so that is PMB okay which is referred as
project management body of knowledge or
PMB okay
which is the collection of processes
best practices terminologies and
guidelines accepted as standards within
the industry
so the latest edition of this is sixth
edition which was released in 2017. the
first edition of pmbok guide was
published in 1996 and the sixth edition
as I mentioned was released in 2017 and
the exam format was revised from 26th
March 2018. so PM book guide will become
the basic reference to appear in the PMP
examination so one needs to go through
the training based on PM book guidelines
so that will help them to pass the
examination easily so eligibility
criteria for appearing for PMP
certification examinations so you can
have two types of eligibilities which
PMI defines so Option 1 includes someone
who has secondary degree should have 7
500 hours of leading and directing
project that is an experience what it is
asking as a prerequisite before the
professional go for examination plus
such 35 hours of project management
education formally from a registered
education provider like simply learn
option 2 someone who has four year
degree project management experience
leading and directing project this
experience will be 4500 hours whereas as
we saw in option one in option 2 35
hours of project management education is
required and that is from registered
education provider like simple learn as
I mentioned earlier so this training
which is conducted by registered
education provider will have their
trainings aligned with PMB OK the latest
edition so simply learn enables people
to learn what are the topics in PMP
framework plus make the professionals
ready to appear the examination and
become successful
the project management framework which
is defined in pmbok includes five
process groups 10 knowledge areas and 49
processes so when we say five process
groups this indicates the way the
project flows how each of these process
groups are connected while project
happens in the Project Life Cycle
whereas 10 knowledge areas are the one
which needs to be looked up to
demonstrated up to considered while
doing the project management and the 49
processes distributed across five
process groups and 10 knowledge areas
has the activities the objectives the
inputs outputs tools and techniques
clearly defined so that those can be
applied while doing the project
management so those are aligned the way
it is shown in the table so five process
group that is initiating planning
executing monitoring and control and
closing these are the process groups
whereas 10 knowledge areas includes
project integration management projects
code management project schedule
management project cost management
project quality management project
Resource Management project
communication management project risk
management project procurement
management and project stakeholder
management so each of these knowledge
areas and process groups are aligned in
such a way where the processes aligned
with a specific process group and
knowledge area can be demonstrated
accordingly if you look at a process
with which goes from initiating to
planning planning to executing and then
monitoring and control while you do
monitoring and control if there is
anything found as a deviation it may
come back to planning or executing for
necessary Corrections once the necessary
Corrections happens again it moves to
monitoring and control to check whether
it is completely done as expected or not
if it is confirmed everything is done as
per the requirements defined then it
moves to closing this is how the project
Flows In The Project Life Cycle whereas
all the 10 knowledge areas happens in
parallel so now if you look at
initiating process group you can see two
processes that is develop project
Charter and identify stakeholders so
develop project Charter and identifies
stakeholders basically defines project
Charter required for the project as well
as initial identified stakeholders who
are required to move forward in the
project similarly if you look at
planning process group you you have 24
processes which are distributed across
all the 10 knowledge areas so these
processes creates a plan for the project
which involves scope Baseline schedule
Baseline cost Baseline quality
management approach then Resource
Management approach means the plan I'm
into 7s approach I'm speaking about the
plan similarly communication management
plan risk management plan procurement
management plan stakeholder management
plan and all of these will get
Consolidated into project management
plan in the integration management
knowledge area once this plan is done
and approved then it moves for execution
all that project manager do during
execution is directing and managing
Project work and managing the project
knowledge at the same time project
manager would take responsibility of
managing quality acquiring resources
developing team managing team then
Communications which are planned as as
per the communication management plan
communication should happen during
execution so similarly implementation of
risk responses defined while doing the
planning and conducting the procurements
as planned and then managing stakeholder
engagement so actual execution of those
work packages execution of those
deliverables happens from the team now
as those deliverables happens the
delivered products are checked monitored
and controlled you can see validate
scope control scope likewise for each
knowledge areas there is a Control
process which checks is that happened in
execution as it was planned in plan
planning process group so then that is
Consolidated here for monitoring and
controlling the project work in entirety
integrated similarly performing
integrated Change Control any deviations
found in any of these checks which is
being done in the control
now that deviations needs to be
corrected so change will be reached so
request for change will be raised and
that will be approved and controlled and
necessary directions are given approvals
are given and that moves towards
execution for implementation once it is
implemented again validation happens
once control checks if everything is
okay then it moves to the closure now
activities in closure a project or a
phase involves just an activities of
closure the products or services or
results which are created from the
project does not go to closure until
those are validated checked conformed
and signed off only then it goes to
closing project or phase and necessary
formalities which are required to be
completed before conclusion will happen
in closing project.face this is how the
project flows second point which you
keep in mind is a project manager is
also called as an integrator so Main
Focus the umbrella view the birds have
your project manager should have from
Project integration management
so this layer project integration
management where project manager should
have an umbrella view total view about
entire project what is happening so
bigger picture only when project manager
has a bigger picture project manager can
come to the lower levels and C is are
they progressing the way it is supposed
to so then go back look at the bird's
eye view again and see is it going in
the right direction which is very
essential so further I guess we will
look at each of these process groups and
what happens in each of the process
groups similarly in knowledge areas so
let us move forward now project
management process groups so these
process groups details the necessary
requirement that need to be satisfied to
ensure that project resources are used
efficiently and these represents the
chronological faces that all projects go
through during the Project Life Cycle so
starting from initiating stage it moves
to planning once the plan is ready then
it moves to execution as the execution
happens validation checks happens in
monitoring and control and as you find
some deviation in monitoring and control
for correction of the deviation it comes
back to execution or if any necessary
changes needs to be done in planning
also while doing these Corrections then
it may move to plan then execution and
then monitoring and control so this Loop
continues until the confirmation yes it
is delivered as per the plan and then it
moves to close so that's how the project
flows and the Project Life Cycle would
be like that so initiating process group
so initiating process group involves the
processes activities and skills needed
to define the beginning of the project
as I mentioned earlier in initiating
process group the creation of project
Charter happens and identification of
the basic stakeholders main stakeholders
who are required to understand the
further requirements in detail who needs
to be engaged so those are identified so
setting up permits authorization and
initial work orders which should be in
place and are important for Effective
and logical progress of the project and
success across all project faces so this
clearly sets up the phases for the work
to be completed initializing teams and
having a well thought out budget which
is very important so this gives that
view in totality but it may not give you
the full granular details but it sets
the direction provides that insight and
also one important thing we should keep
in mind is in initiation stage
appointment of project manager happens
the formal Declaration of appointment of
project manager happens and project
Charter will be formally handed over to
project manager and that formal
Declaration of assignment of project
manager happens from then project
manager takes over and first activity
project manager does is identification
of stakeholders so next process group is
planning process group where we have
around 24 processes to define the
Project's scope cost schedule quality
resource risk then procurement
stakeholder engagement so comprehensive
plan if it is waterfall approach or
basic skeleton plan which is required if
it is agile approach so it also
clarifies the goals and expectations
while putting in place infrastructure to
achieve the goals keeping in
budgetary constraints the end to end
view of the project is provided in
planning so this acts as a basic
reference while the execution and
monitoring and control happens So based
on the planning the way it is done
execution will happen now next process
group is executing process group where
the role of project manager is to direct
and manage Project work and manage the
project knowledge main activities being
an integrator of a project secondly
acquiring resources it may be human
resource or technology resource or any
other resource required for the project
then if it is human resource there needs
to be necessary training development of
the team and then managing them so lot
of Team Dynamics are involved that needs
to be handled so this involves managing
teams while handling time expectations
and achieving Benchmark goals team
members delivers those results team
members does all the activities and then
creates set results so team concerns
this to to be addressed because as you
see the people together the team members
together it is quite obvious conflict
maker so conflict resolution should
happen the engagement with the team
member should happen so demonstration of
work which is done by the project team
that needs to be monitored and
controlled parallely which happens
during the execution monitoring and
control is also happening so project
manager should look at both so consensus
needs to be addressed execution is that
happening as per the plan has to be
checked as part of monitoring and
control while execution is happening so
birds are view an entirety which says
how the execution should happen that
needs to be directed and monitored
whereas coming on ground seeing is that
happening the way it is required that is
also very essential so next is
monitoring and Control process group now
as part of these process group as I
mentioned while execution happens it is
very essential to check validate
and control so this process group
involves processing change orders any
deviations being found change requests
are raised and if that change request
needs some modification or changes in
planning then it goes to planning if no
such planning requirements simple change
that straight go to execution change get
executed and then again validation
happens so integrated change management
which is there in this particular
process group so this also focuses on
addressing ongoing budget considerations
handling unexpected circumstances that
could hamper the team's ability to meet
the initial project expectations so it
goes on throughout the Project Life
Cycle so two process groups if you
closely observe planning process groups
and monitoring and Control process
groups are the process groups where you
see processes in all the knowledge areas
otherwise if you see an initiating
process group it is only two process one
is an integration management other one
is stakeholder management if you look at
execution you don't see in scope time
cost and risk management similarly if
you see closing process group only one
process which is in initiating process
group so these are the only two process
groups planning process groups and
monitoring and Control process group
where you see the most of the processes
so next process group is closing process
group so closing process group closing
project or phase is a process what we
have in this process Group which
basically focuses on addressing the
culmination of project management skills
shown throughout the other
interconnected processes that guided the
projects so all the aspects of process
are closed and all the necessary
paperwork is submitted so it can lead to
great reviews and Word of Mouth
referrals in the future so all the
activities which need to be done for
formal closure and conclusion which is
done in the closing process group so
this is about all the 5 process group
defined in the PMP framework so now let
us move towards understanding each of
the knowledge areas and the different
processes within it so how many
processes in each of the knowledge areas
aligning it with the process group we
just saw in the table but when we look
at it understand what are those exactly
so now knowledge areas are necessary for
Effective project management which can
take place during any of the explained
process groups so they are 10 so those
are project integration management
project scope management project
schedule management project cost
management project quality management
project Resource Management project
communication management then project
risk management project procurement
management project stakeholder
management so many people ask me when I
train the people they ask me how do we
remember all of this so remembering
process group will be easy because it is
the flow which if you can remember then
remembering the process group will be
easier but remember the knowledge areas
so one thing you should keep in mind is
initially when PMB okay were defined
mostly in until Third Edition or fourth
edition we used to focus on Triple
constraints so when we say triple
constraints we used to tell scope cost
and time now later when as the best
practices evolved as the pmbok walled so
it did not limit on Triple constraints
it actually said six constraints what
are the six constraints so scope cost
time quality resources and risk so if
you can able to remember the six
constraints so each of associated with
each of these constraints there is a
knowledge area like you have project
scope management which is one of the
area of constraints similarly schedule
management link to time cost management
quality management resource management
and risk management so out of 10 easily
you can able to remember six further
there are four now integration
management by default integrates all the
nine knowledge areas so remembering that
may not be difficult so to consolidate
this to conduct the project properly you
need stakeholders you need to procute
something and you need to communicate so
other three knowledge areas remembrance
should happen by linking to this so
firstly remember six constraints that is
scope time cost quality resource and
risk then you have communication which
needs to happen to communicate there
should be stakeholder and also there
should be Supply which needs to happen
to the project so if you can link like
this nine knowledge areas you can
remember so in all these nine knowledge
areas you will integrate and manage in
integration management so in fact all
the plans which are defined in rest of
the nine knowledge areas except
integration management so all those
plans are called as subsidiary plans so
all these nine subsidiary plans that is
scope management plan schedule
management Plan cost management plan
quality management plan Resource
Management plan communication management
plan risk management plan procurement
management plan and stakeholder
management plan so all these nine
subsidiary plans are integrated together
and Consolidated in project management
plan so that happens in Project
integration management so this we should
keep in mind so project integration
management what does it do so project
integration management basically
includes plans to develop project
Charter a document that sets up the
project and assigns the project manager
created during the initiation phase so a
project management plan is also created
which is a roadmap for the entire
project to become a success so the
project plan once approved by
stakeholders and sponsor is monitored
and tracked through the change log it
also directs and manages the project
work this process is monitored analyzed
and reported to identify and control any
changes or problems that could be
encountered so one thing we should keep
in mind when we say project integration
management this is the only knowledge
area where we see processes in all the
process group so we have process in
initiating process group we have
processes in planning we have process in
execution process group we have
processes in monitoring and Control
process group and also in closing
process group so project integration
management is only knowledge area where
it has a processes in all the process
groups which we don't see in any other
knowledge area now next we look at the
list of processes like develop project
Charter is in a initiation process group
develop project management plan which
consolidates all the nine knowledge
areas is in planning process group
direct and manage Project work manage
project knowledge these two processes
are in executing process group Monitor
and control project work perform
integrated Change Control these two
processes are in monitoring and Control
process group so close project or face
is in the closing process group so now
we will move to project scope management
so when we use the term scope
the term scope refers to the boundary
within which we need to do something so
first thing we should keep in mind when
we say project scope two things one is
the scope of that product service or
results which we are creating which
comes out as a product or a service a
result out of a project which comes out
what is getting created so scoping that
part of it so other scope part of it the
processes the tools the resources what
is being used during the project so that
deliverables happen so two part of the
scope we should look at so project scope
management involves those areas deals
with the work of the project and
involves plan scope management an
important part of project management
plan the collection of requirements of
the product or service also takes place
in this process group and also project
scope management knowledge area deals
with work of the project which involves
plan scope management an important part
of the project management plan so the
collection of requirements of the
product or service also takes place in
this stage the scope of project is also
defined in the scope statement this is
expected to undergo change over the
course of project the scope is validated
during the project ensuring that the
deliverables are approved by sponsors or
stakeholders so as I mentioned earlier
it involves the scope of the results
what is being created and all the scope
of those processes resources tools which
are used during the project so processes
in Project scope management knowledge
area so plan scope management which is
in planning process group collect
requirements Define scope create W base
even these three processes are in
planning process group in total four
processes in planning process group
whereas validate scope and control scope
these two processes are in monitoring
and controlled process group So when you
say plan scope management it's about
defining how to collect the requirements
how to manage those entire scope
management planning and requirements
management plan also has to be defined
then requirements are collected from the
stakeholders who have been identified
and then scope will be defined now very
important thing here is about work
breakdown structure so we have a product
or a service or a result which we are
working on to create as a result of the
project so how will you understand all
the parts of it that needs breaking down
that particular product or services or
results which we are going to create
into multiple pieces in a structure
which would look like a tree so that you
will get it necessary Insight towards
what is being delivered
so firstly product breakdown structure
is made and for each of the layers of
this product breakdown structure you
will be assigning an activities
assigning resources effort estimation
cost estimation sequencing those all
this will will be done later basic thing
needed is work breakdown structure for
that so to create WBS the technique
called decomposition is used and this
approach is top down approach next
validates coupon control scope as WBS
provides the structure of various things
which needs to be delivered referring to
that as the execution happens validation
should happen whether it is delivered
accordingly or not and is that scope
management is being done according to
the plan control scope will be checking
that so next is the project schedule
management when we say schedule it's
quite obvious for us to understand when
what needs to be done
so what needs to be done is already told
in scope and when are we going to do
that for that you need to have a
specific schedule the timeline so the
project will have various different
activities tasks which is assigned to
the particular WBS element so these
activities will have a specific start
date end date and this will have a
specific output which is coming out as
part of those actions which happens so
the project is divided into tasks each
with their own start dates and deadlines
and budgets so these are revised as the
project moves forward depending on how
the project is progressing a schedule
for the project and determining who is
responsible for that so helps us to
understand which resource is required at
what point in time similarly the cash
flow requirement can also be understood
by having a defined schedule so the
tasks are placed in a sensible order and
the dependencies between each of them
are noted once sequence Advanced the
resources required for the tasks are
estimated and assigned the time required
for each of these tasks are also
determined now when we say this we will
require to understand and visualize
while doing a project the WBS structure
is defined and in what sequence each of
these elements are delivered and what
timeline start time end time and how
each of these are connected to other WBS
element in what sequence what activity
is required what resource required what
effort required what competency skill
required so all these are put in so
since we schedule and sequence it we
know when is that required so this
requires working with other knowledge
area very closely when I say w base
element it's quite obvious it comes from
scope management when I say allocation
of resources obviously it has to work
with Resource Management to create a
resource calendars if it's a cost
management to understand the flow money
flow cash flow so budget should be there
for the project so cash flow when what
amount is required to understand that it
cost is linked to schedule so all these
knowledge areas should work very closely
with coordinating with each other
interfacing with each other so project
schedule management also uses a very
important technique called network
analysis technique where we speak about
critical path then forward pass backward
pass then identification of floats so
when is a critical path critical path
refers to the longest path in the
established Network diagram of a project
and that will be the minimum time
required for project to complete so this
critical part needs to be closely
monitored as the execution of the
project happens because any delay in
this critical path will delay the
project itself so that's about some
summary about schedule management now
let us look at the processes which are
involved in schedule management so plan
schedule management define activities
sequence activities estimate activity
durations develop schedule so all these
five processes are in planning process
group so schedule management how it has
to be done needs to be clearly planned
as part of plan schedule management then
when to define activities it is quite
obvious we need to know what needs to be
delivered so WBS element helps us when
the scope Baseline is provided as an
input here so taking that activities are
defined then the sequencing happens then
when we say estimate activity durations
so we speak about two terms like effort
and duration if I want to deliver
something let me assume uh to deliver X
for a person it requires one day or for
a person it requires 10 days if we say
so to create that working piece of a
product it takes 10 man days we will say
that is an effort now if I have 100
pieces of suchness to be created how
many mind days I need so 10 into 100
piece 10 days into 100 peso 1000 mandies
now how many resources I have I may have
around 25 resources now 1000 divided by
25 it will be around I guess 400 400
mind is no I think to a thousand divided
by uh it's about 4 40. so 40 Man days of
means that is duration whereas effort is
1000 minus 40 days will become duration
so likewise looking at how many
resources we have how many uh what is
that effort is actually required is
involved and then what is the duration
within which we need to complete it
either you look at how many resources I
have based on that I will look at the
duration or I will look at the Target
date mainly Target date is given by
customers as you discussed when the
project needs to be completed
accordingly you are required to acquire
the resources so this itself is showing
us these knowledge areas now work very
closely now so without scope you cannot
define activities now without
understanding the activities you don't
know what is the effort so now once you
understood the effort you know what
resource what competency when so you
have to work with Resource Management so
to have those resources
onboarded or acquired you need to have
money cost so what cost it takes so
likewise it goes one by one hello
operating that's why you see 24
processes in the
planning process group distributed
across all that in knowledge areas so
this is about schedule management now I
look at
the cost management project cost
management so when we say cost it is
quite obvious it's all about money what
money the expenditure the outgoing money
so project incurs cost if any
individuals I keep getting these
questions in lot of trainings so is
checking the revenues the invoice
raising and collection of payment is
that a job of a project manager now when
we say the project management and look
at it as a project management activities
now it's all about delivering the
results of the project so when we say I
need to collect invoices and do I submit
invoices collect payments when you say
that so that doesn't mean it is part of
a project management role no now if in
your organization if you have a
designation of project manager or sub
manager or something and invoice
submission and collection of payment is
also part of your job description you
have to do you don't have any choice so
designation is totally different when
compared with the meaning of the Roll
Call project manager so any other things
which are associated with your
designation in the organization it may
be project manager also designation
possible depending on what job
description what job activities are
associated with it accordingly and to do
but when you do a project management
activity in specific when you involve in
the project so all these aspects what we
are defining that needs to be taken care
hundred percent along with it raising an
invoice collection of payment or
coordinating with some other department
to find out new opportunities in the
existing customer those are all
additional things which are given to you
as an individual with that designation
to justify many things so as a
professionals I have a position in
organization with some designations and
there is a CTC salary which is given and
that needs to be justified to justify
that various different roles are
attached to you for your designation so
that you need to look up to accordingly
and to deal with now let us come back to
project cost management so it's about
expending money what we're speaking
about
which basically focuses on estimating
and allocation of budget to the project
that is first thing one is to estimate
approximate what cost it takes for a
project now what are those cost
components so where is that cost
incurred so cost is incurred
to the resources acquired cost is
incurred to the tools cost is incurred
in all that activity what we do right so
everywhere the one we create result for
raw material what you acquire the people
the technology resource what to occur
the facility what you have so all this
involves money the cost expenditure so
approximation of the cost needs to be
done what it takes to complete this
project and confirm budgeted so this
involves project budgeting so good
estimation tools need to make sure that
the funds are within the need of the
project and stakeholder sponsors are
kept informed so estimation and
budgeting cannot happen in isolation
project manager cannot do alone that
requires to involve the experts the
Divine experts who can determine how the
budget can be established how it can
change how it can be controlled what are
The Regulators needs to be kept in mind
so it considers all those processes
required to do that
all the tasks which are involved like
cost and combining them will determine
project budget so firstly approximation
would happen based on that approximation
then the approximation of that will be
submitted then the budget is confirmed
after all location so this needs to be
monitored and controlled throughout the
Project Life Cycle so initially I also
mentioned earlier about triple
constraint scope time and cost so it is
very important to monitor these three
critically so for that there is a
technique which is used which is very
popular earned value management which
speaks about or provides you the Insight
towards how the project is progressing
in terms of scope time and cost
which are basically very important ones
then comes rest of the things quality
resource risk which complements to this
right so project cost management
involves four processes that is Plan
cost management estimate cost determined
budget which are part of planning
process group and control cost is part
of monitoring and Control process group
now next uh knowledge area is Project
quality management so when we say
quality it's all about ensuring that
grades are set requirements are clearly
defined and how are you going to ensure
that inner in characteristics what are
defined are accomplished so you need to
have a quality management approach
quality management plan in place now
what quality management I should follow
there are a lot of Standards lot of best
practices so that is based on the
project environment in which
organization are you doing in any given
organization there will be quality
management practices which are followed
an approach that may require to get
reflected in the projects which is being
done in that environment or if project
has a specific requirement that specific
quality management standard or practice
needs to be followed then that needs to
be defined accordingly the quality
management should happen so quality
management is a part of entire project
management plan which speaks about
quality specifications products or
service the artifacts which are used as
part of the project so when we say
quality management approach we speak
about many terms like acceptance
criteria quality criteria customer
quality expectations then quality
assurance quality control so all these
needs to be kept in mind and brought in
place and this in execution if you look
at there is a process called manage
quality when we looked at scope schedule
and cost there was no processes defined
in execution but since the
accountability of ensuring quality is
with project manager there is a process
now remember all these 49 processes
defined in PMP are project management
processes these are not the processes
which are for execution so these are all
project management processes if any team
member is configuring something creating
something delivering something none of
those activities are defined as part of
these processes as planned when you make
a clear plan like when I said create WBS
where you have the elements which needs
to be delivered or defined when you're
putting an activities into it adding
activities into it that anyway you have
a domain expert to do it accordingly
execution happens by team members but as
a project manager you are not involved
in that in entirety in execution I'm
saying so project quality management
will have the processes like plan
quality management manage quality and
control quality so plan quality
management is part of planning process
group manage quality is part of
executing process group whereas control
quality is part of monitoring and
controlling process group so the next
knowledge area to look at is Project
Resource Management so when we say
resource by default we think about human
resources so that's how the knowledge
area was in the fifth edition
so it was called as project human
resource management but as the
discussions happen has the realization
happened it is not about just human
resource many resources involves
technology resources facility resources
so the renaming of that knowledge area
happened in sixth edition as project
Resource Management so project Resource
Management focuses on ensuring
identification of those roles
identification of those resources having
a plan in place so that resources can be
managed better so predominantly when we
say resource it's quite obvious we think
about human resources so which is very
very unpredictable kind of resource
whereas when it comes to technology
resource it is predictable the nature
the behavior the configuration
everything is predictable but only those
human resources are the one which
requires a special treatment
a special approach to engage with them
so this knowledge area helps to identify
roles within the project team as per the
project management team structure
defined so there should be project
management team structure defined and
what needs to be delivered from which of
the roles which also include how they
fit into overall structure of the
project so these team members or
resources need to be acquired if it is
human resources those needs to be
educated and induction needs to be done
about the project and they needs to
become fit into the project so when I
say people it's quite obvious conflict
occurs various different preferences
they come across with they have their
own experience backgrounds and Dynamics
associated with them so close monitoring
is required mentoring is required
demonstration of leadership skills are
required so generally we speak about
three main ways of demonstrating
leadership which involves authoritarian
leadership then lazy Fair leadership and
participative Leadership so
authoritarian is also called as
autocratic which means the project
manager will become hold that Authority
power with that power
the project manager demonstrate this is
how it should be makes the decision so
such power demonstration may be required
when something needs to be influenced
strongly and direction is to be set and
decisions needs to be made but when it
comes to participative leadership when
some problems needs to be resolved When
people's involvement is required that
needs to be encouraged that is very
essential reviewing or creating
solutions that approach leadership style
is required but when it comes to lazy
fare delegative approach so where there
are specific domain experts who will do
it so assign to them and then monitor
review with them that is delegative
approach so these three leadership
styles has to be demonstrated
effectively while doing doing project
resource management
so team will have their own Dynamics so
that needs to be understood and
accordingly dealt with so this knowledge
area has around six processes that is
plan Resource Management estimate
activity resources acquire resources
develop team manage team and control
resources so plan resource management
and estimate activity resources are part
of planning process group acquire
resources develop team and manage team
are part of executing process group
whereas control resource is part of
monitoring and Control process group so
next knowledge area we are going to look
at is Project communication management
so when we say project communication
firstly we need to understand what is
this communication is all about
so communication is used to convey
something to someone
so there should be two parties the
communicator and the one who receives it
means sender and receiver so very
important here is when sender sends
certain message at the receiver's end
how it is received is the meaning what
is actually perceived by a receiver is
same as what is meant by the
communicator means sender so this will
become a big gap if what I told versus
what someone understood if there is a
gap then the communication is not
effective
so it is very essential to understand
this Dynamics communication should be
very effective and based on that
communication there is always a
resultant action so always communication
will have two parties minimum one is
sender and receiver and in the
receiver's perspective one is to
understand who would be the receiver
generally when I say project manager
project manager communicates with
sponsor project manager communicates
with team members project manager
communicates with customers project
manager communicates with other
functions within organization suppliers
who are external to the organization now
each of these communications will have a
specific objective and intention so
project manager should understand that
and what sorts of vocabularies and
jargons which needs to be used while
communicating the words the
communication methods which needs to be
used the communication channel the
language the syntax understanding all of
these will become very important while
doing the communication in the project
so project communication management is
the area that informs the team and
stakeholders about the project
so the communication management system
is determined along with how it is done
and how often it is done how frequently
the communication has to be made so
managing communication should also
involve reviewing how effective the
communication is
and how the regularly the modifications
are being done to ensure the
communication is actually fulfilling the
requirements of communication needs that
needs to be discussed regularly and
looked at is that helping so it is very
essential as the stakeholders are
identified that communication
requirement should also identify and
what communication why is that
communication how often how frequently
the communication has to be made what
channel what template which has to be
used and what language
so all these needs to be understood
signed off so when you go and inform or
sends a message to the sponsor it will
have specific objective of that
communication similarly when you send it
to team member specific objective here
in this two aspect the frequency will
change the language will change the
stakeholders to whom the communication
is made by changes and impact it has to
create in that communication will also
change so that needs to be understood
the project manager should be very
sensitive about it so communication
management plays very important role
whereas 90 of the time project manager
will be spending is effort and time in
communicating if that is not effective
it is difficult to become successful in
project management
now let us look at the processes in
Project communication management
so there are three processes that is
plan communication management
Communications and monitor
Communications
so plan communication management is part
of planning process group manage
communication is part of executing
process group
monitor communication is part of
monitoring and Control process groups
the next knowledge area is Project risk
management
so when we use the term risk it's all
about an uncertainty what we're speaking
about so every assignment we take up
every initiative we do everything
involves risk similarly project also
involves risk so risk which is termed as
an uncertainty of certain occurrence are
both positive as well as negative the
positive risk we call it as
opportunities whereas negative risk we
call it as threats so each of these risk
has to be treated certain way so before
you treat or decide on certain treatment
of the risks identified risks needs to
be analyzed so qualitative analysis
quantitative analysis has to be done and
risk responses has to be planned so the
project risk management is the knowledge
area which will identify how the risks
are itemized categorized and prioritized
in the risk register similarly risks are
prioritized and qualitatively and
quantitative actively analyzed So based
on their impact on the project
the necessary response plan will be
defined so risk has to be controlled by
reviewing the risk register regularly
and removing the risk that no longer
impact the project now the risk once
identified mainly risks are identified
some set of risks are already identified
captured in Project Charter whereas in
detail risks are identified during the
planning associated with many different
aspects of the project the risk related
to scope schedule time cost quality
resources may be procurement
stakeholders so risks are categorized
accordingly and identified now this is
not the list which is made it is not an
exhaustive list which is made in one go
so this access acts as a basic list as
the project progresses all these
identified address needs to be evaluated
on continual basis and also new risks
needs to be identified regularly so that
what are the kinds of risks which comes
up are understood and then response
plans are accordingly taken so this
helps in managing the risks effectively
and efficiently
the processes involved in Risk
Management knowledge area are planned
risk management identify risk perform
qualitative risk analysis perform
quantitative risk analysis and plan risk
response which are part of planning
process group
whereas Implement risk response will be
part of executing process group and
monitor risks this will be part of
monitoring and controlled process group
so when we say identify risk this is
when you identify the riskier and
captured in the risk register and as I
mentioned earlier this is not a list
which is exhaustive so at the moment
whatever the risks are being identified
so these risks are analyzed now as part
of this planning qualitatively as well
as quantitatively but the analysis of
the risk assessing those risks should
continue throughout the Project Life
Cycle because the impact level of the
risk would vary as it progresses
throughout the Project Life Cycle now as
we have a risk response plans defined
and for some it is already implemented
some you cannot Implement you need to
make yourself ready to tackle the
scenario of issues when it occurs when
risk occurs you need to handle those so
have that capability built or having
some contingency plans any of such
actions are taken and projects should be
ready means when risk occurs the impact
occurred and I'm just okay with it that
will not work so project will get
impacted it may escalate the cost it may
delay the project closure many things it
will happen
so proper analysis and then actions in
time right risk response plans can be
implemented so for positive risk for
opportunities generally acceptance or
exploit or taking advantage of that
would be the kind of response we will
see for the negative risk the threats
the kind of responses what we would see
is like avoid or have a contingency plan
or mitigate the risk in terms of having
some measures implemented transfer risk
is another thought which is done so if
someone says avoid risk that behavior is
called as risk hours Behavior someone
who don't even take risk so if I take up
this I have the risk of so much so I
will not even take up that such
behaviors so those are the kinds of risk
responses may come across which needs to
be implemented as part of executing
process group then whatever the plan
whatever the implementation which has
happened that needs to be monitored as
part of monitoring and control so next
knowledge area for us is Project
procurement management
so when we say procurement so every
project involves procuring something
so a main decision which happens here is
make or buy decision so should I make it
myself should I create my myself within
within the organization or should I do
something or purchase something so make
or buy a decision so when I decide I'm
going to buy certain things from outside
because we cannot make everything as
part of our organization because the
direction of the business is totally
different
if I'm a bank and I am doing an IT
project I need not go and sit and start
configuring a server so I need not hire
people who configure and then they come
and sit here and I start managing them
so my entire focus of banking services
which I need to focus on
we'll go for toss I should not do that
so insured instead I'll give to an
experts so procurement of an ID services
from IIT service provider I will do so
to giving it to the experts rather than
doing myself which helps me to have that
expertise coming to me so procurement
management involves in identifying those
resources the products or Services which
needs to be procured to use in my
project so that I need not spend time on
that so this involves identification of
the suppliers having those
subcontractors right so they will have
an engagement through a contract and
monitoring and managing them and
establishing a relationship with them
and engaging with them in appropriate
way that is required it is very
essential to be done in every project so
that way project procure management
would guide in terms of handling all the
procurements what we do from outside
external to the organization so this
knowledge area handles outside
procurements like hiring subcontract
factors outside needs of projects are
identified and how much they are
determined this involves a statement of
work terms of reference request for
proposal and choosing a vendor so to do
this bidder conference happens floating
request for proposals can happen request
for quotation can happen so many such
actions are taken and the processes
involved here are three mainly so plan
procurement management which is part of
planning process group conduct
procurement which is part of executing
process group and control procurement
which is part of monitoring and Control
process group so the next knowledge is
Project stakeholder management so when
we say stakeholder who is the
stakeholder stakeholders are internal
stakeholders are external stakeholders
are the one who influence stakeholders
impact they will get impacted they are
influenced so likewise for every project
every initiative organization takes
there are stakeholders for me for my
project I need to identify all the
stakeholders
so now identification of stakeholder
engaging with stakeholder managing the
stakeholders will become very essential
so as part of this knowledge area after
identification of stakeholders the need
of stakeholders needs to be understood
so not every stakeholders are identified
will have very close to the project they
are not in very close proximity to the
project the distance of the stakeholder
from the project may be far still they
may have an impacted because of this we
need to understand that if I am building
a flyover construction of a flyover is
happening obviously people living in
that region will get impacted but they
have no direct involvement in the
project however their cooperation is
required so likewise as as you identify
the stakeholders we need to understand
what kind of impact or influence that
stakeholder will have
on them or on the project from them this
needs to be analyzed so stakeholders
needs to be identified their concerns
need to be identified and must be
managed some stakeholders would come up
with certain powers authorities so we
need to understand that as well
so each of the stakeholder needs to be
listed out their concerns prioritize
based on their impact on the project
then the stakeholders need to be engaged
and determine if their needs are being
addressed if not what can be done to
rectify those if at all any issues exist
so various stakeholders State also can
exist there is a stakeholder who should
be very supportive in the project
actively involved in the project but the
stakeholder may be in another state so
we may require to engage with a
stakeholder bring that Clarity explain
and then ensure that stakeholder is
supportive to the project some
stakeholders may be resistive some
stakeholder may be neutral some
stakeholder will be very supportive
unaware so various different state of
stakeholders would exist but one needs
to analyze what kind of state that
stakeholder should be in this project
that needs to be discussed understood
and then decide so accordingly
engagement should happen so stakeholder
engagement plan is to be defined very
clearly so now here we have four
processes so one process in initiating
process group that is identify
stakeholder then plan stakeholder
engagement which happens in planning
manage stakeholder engagement which is
executing process group and monitor
stakeholder engagement is monitoring and
Control process group as I mentioned in
Risk Management in stakeholder
management also identification of
stakeholder analyzing the way
stakeholder engagement should happen and
deciding that engagement this is very
Dynamic which has to happen throughout
the Project Life Cycle and this is not
one time register what we create like
stakeholder register if we create it is
not one time register it is dynamic
which gets updated throughout the life
cycle of the project welcome to PMP exam
preparation tutorial from simple learn I
am CMR Chandra Mr a certified project
management professional so as part of
this tutorial we are going to understand
what is PMP who can get PMP certified
PMP exam pattern syllabus and exam
preparation for PMP which involves five
process groups 10 knowledge areas 49
processes and also we will look at
finding of simple on about project
manager salary who is certified PMP
versus who is not certified what is PMP
PMP stands for project management
professional which is one of the most
popular and recognized certificate in
project management so it serves as a
benchmark for project managers all
around the globe so PMP certification
examination is offered by PMI and the
entire subject entire domain area of
project management based on pmbok
released by PMI so PMI is a global
recognized non-profit organization which
provides project management
certifications include PMP so according
to PMI Global survey people with PMP
certification receives 20 percent higher
salary than those without the
certification so who can get PMP
certified so for getting Pap certified
one needs to have relevant experience
and training there are two eligibility
requirements option one one more holds
secondary degree should have 75 and
hours of leading and directing projects
and 35 hours of project management
education provided by registered
education provider like simply learn
option 2 holds four-year degree should
have 4500 hours leading and directing
project and 35 hours of project
management education from education
registered education provider like
simply learn certificate is valid for
the period of three years and it has to
be renewed every three years to renew
the certificate one is to furnish a
proof of 60 professional development
units so professional development units
can be acquired by attending the
training sessions learning and also
volunteering in many PMP initiatives I
mean pmis initiatives on project
management events the examination fee
for project management certification
would be 555 USD for PMI non-members and
that would be 405 USD for those who are
pmis members PMP examination pattern so
PMP exam is closed book exam and it is
based on the pmbok guide released by PMI
exam will have 200 multiple choice
questions out of which only 175
questions are used for scoring and 25
are pre-test questions the duration of
the examination would be 4 hours and
there is no negative marking so PMP
certification exam result is declared
immediately after the examination a
congratulatory email will be sent by PMI
within one to two weeks while a physical
certificate within four to six weeks so
PMP certification is based on the
project management body of knowledge
guide which is a collection of standard
terminologies rules and guidelines for
project management released by PMI so
PMI ensures regular updates to pmpuk
guide to keep it up to date currently
the sixth edition is the latest version
in the market PMP syllabus and exam and
preparation the syllabus of PMP
examination is based on the pmbok guide
as I mentioned earlier and to understand
the syllabus and prepare for the exam
one needs to be familiar with following
terms those are five process groups 10
knowledge areas and 49 processes which
are defined as part of the project
management framework defined in PMP the
examination will be based on the five
domains so it includes initiating
planning execution monitoring and
control and closure accordingly the
percentage of questions from each of the
domain areas are mentioned here so 13
percent from initiation stage 24 from
planning 31 percent from execution 25
from monitoring and control and seven
percent from closing PMP exam is going
to change from 1st July 2020. so
starting first July 2020 the PMP exam
will focus on new exam pattern which in
involves mainly three domains that is
people process and business environment
the number of questions I mean the
percentage of questions in the PMP
examination will be like 50 from the
process 42 percent from the people and
eight percent from the business
environment domain five process groups
the five process groups as defined in
pmbok of PMP is initiation process group
planning process group execution process
group monitoring and controlling process
group and closing process group so the
initiating process group involves the
idea and processes needed to begin the
project the vision of the project and
the steps to achieve it are taken into
consideration let us look at few
questions related to initiation process
Group which of the following is not true
about project Charter Option 1 Project
Charter is written by the project
manager option 2 project Charter defines
the purpose of the project option 3
identify and authorizes the project
manager option 4 project Charter is
authorized by executive management
answer is Project Charter is written by
the project manager because the question
says which of the following is not true
about project Charter so project manager
does not write does not involve while
writing the project Charter that is the
reason project Charter is written by
project manager is the correct answer
for the question 1 question 2 which of
the following tools and techniques
cannot be used to identify stakeholders
stakeholder register is the answer
question 2 which of the following tools
and techniques cannot be used to
identify stakeholders Option 1 expert
judgment option 2 stakeholder register
option 3 meetings option 4 stakeholder
analysis answer is stakeholder register
stakeholder register is the output of
the process identify stakeholder whereas
expert judgment meetings stakeholder
analysis are the tools and techniques
question 3 which of the following is not
true for a project option one projects
are constrained by limited resources
projects are planned executed and
controlled option 3 projects create a
unique product or service projects are
ongoing and repetitive that is option 4.
answer is projects are ongoing and
repetitive so it is true for operation
but not for project question four when a
stakeholder analysis performed option
one when managing communication on your
project option 2 When developing the
project Charter option 3 when creating
the project management plan option 4
when putting changes through Change
Control answer is When developing
project Charter question 5 which of the
following is not included in a project
Charter Option 1 business case option 2
risks and constraints option 3 Resource
Management plan option 4 budget limits
answer is Resource Management plan so
Resource Management plan is created
during the planning process group in a
knowledge area Resource Management
planning the planning process group
defines the vision of the project in
Greater detail the steps to establish
communication between the project team
and the stakeholders throughout the
project are also taken question 1 how
well is the project going if the CPI and
SPI both are greater than one option 1
under Plan cost and ahead of schedule
under planned cost and behind schedule
option 3 or Plan cost and ahead of
schedule option 4 or planned cost and
behind schedule answer is under Plan
cost and ahead of schedule if CPI is one
both cost wise and schedule wise project
will be going as per the plan if CPI and
SPI are lesser than one that indicates
cost wise and shared ideal wise the
project is not doing good cost y it is
over budgeted whereas schedule wise it
is behind the schedule but in the given
a question CPI of project is pay of the
project both are greater than 1 which
means project is ahead of the schedule
and cost wise it is doing very good
means there is some saving question 2
what part of the procurement is the
project manager if he she is in the
middle of creating a request for
proposal RFP Option 1 conduct
procurements option 2 plan procurements
option 3 controlled procurements option
4 close procurements plan procurements
so during plan procurement process
creation of request for proposal could
happen while identifying the supplier
identifying the one who supplies the
bidder or the probable vendor would
happen in execution through conduct
procurements whereas defining RFP
creating RFP would happen as part of
plan procurements question 3 what is the
expected monetary value for the project
if there is a 60 chance of 100
000 profit and forty percent of a US
dollar 100 000 loss question three what
is the expected monetary value for the
project if there is a 60 chance of a one
hundred thousand dollars profit and a
forty percent of a US dollar one hundred
thousand loss answers options are one
hundred thousand dollars profit sixty
thousand dollars loss option two that is
option three twenty thousand dollars
profit option four forty thousand
dollars loss answer is twenty thousand
dollars profit so the way this is
calculated is the sixty percent of one
hundred thousand dollars would be sixty
thousand dollars and whereas forty
percent of one hundred thousand dollars
would be forty thousand dollars so the
profit percentage of sixty thousand
minus 40 percent of loss that is forty
thousand so difference of that would be
twenty thousand dollars so answer is
twenty thousand dollars profit question
four which of the following techniques
is not required to establish a cost
performance Baseline for projects
determine budget process option one cost
aggregation option two bottom-up
estimating option three expert judgment
option four historical relationships
answer is bottom-up estimating question
five what is a work breakdown structure
numbering system do option one determine
the complexity of the project option two
helps in automating the WBS using
appropriate software option 3 provide a
hierarchical structure for each WBS
element option 4 present risks of the
project answer is provide hierarchical
structure for each WBS element so WBS
element helps to understand each levels
of the product breakdown the activities
assigned to it and the efforts required
to accomplish the deliverables as a
result execution the execution process
group involves the members of the team
performing their tasks as planned
although the project plan is finalized
there may be changes in requirements
that come from the stakeholders question
1 which statement in reference to a
desirable communication model is false
option one noise should be at minimum
level receiver must reply to the message
after decoding it option 3 receiver
should first acknowledge and then agree
with the message option 4 receiver
should send a feedback message to the
sender answer is receiver should first
acknowledge and then agree with the
message question 2 which of the
following is not a hygiene Factor
according to herberg's theory answers
options are Option 1 salary option 2
professional growth option 3 security
option 4 recognition answer is
professional growth as per the herberg's
theory the hygiene factors include
salary security and recognition but not
professional growth question 3 which of
the following is not an interpersonal
skill to manage stakeholders
expectations as a project manager
options are building trust resolving
conflict risk-taking and active
listening answer is risk taking risk
taking is a kind of response or a
behavior an organization or an
individual have towards a specific risks
whereas it is not an interpersonal
skills so interpersonal skill includes
building trust resolving conflicts and
active listening question 4 which of the
following should be cooperatively
prepared by both the buyer and the
seller during the team agreement process
options are Option 1 contract option to
contract procurement statement of work
option 3 request for proposal option 4
human resource plan answer is contract
procurement statement of work question 5
there is a software project team of two
analysts for developers and three test
Engineers one new test engineer will
join the team in two weeks what will be
the number of communication channels
option 155 option 250 option 345 and
option 4 36 answer is 45 so to calculate
this we will use the formula n into n
minus 1 divided by 2. so n refers to
number of team members now in the given
question there are totally 10 members
that is to analysts four developers
three test engineers and one new test
engineer who join the team so total it
will be 10 members 10 project team
members so when n is equal to 10 the
total Communication channel should be 45
monitoring and controlling the
monitoring and controlling process group
refers to tracking and reviewing the
progress and performance of the project
the process of monitoring and control is
continually performed throughout the
Project Life Cycle question 1 the
project could not be completed by the
accepted deadline so the project manager
issues a change request what should the
change request authorize Option 1
additional resources using the
contingency fund option 2 escalation
approval to use contingency funding
option 3 team overtime to meet schedule
option 4 corrective actions based on the
causes answer is corrective action based
on causes question 2 an activity has
early start ES of day 3 late start LS of
day 13 and early finish of day 9 and
late finish LF of day 19 the activity
options are is on critical path option 2
has a lag option 3 is progressing well
option 4 is not on the critical path
answer is the activity is not not on the
critical path so if the activity is on
critical path there will be no float the
value of float in critical path will be
zero so in the given scenario the value
of float is 13 minus 3 that is LS minus
es or 19 minus 9 that is LF minus EF
which is equal to 10 so that is the
reason the activity is not on the
critical path question 3 what does
schedule performance index SPI of 0.75
indicate Option 1 Project is over budget
option 2 project is ahead of schedule
option 3 project is progressing at 75
percent of the rate originally planned
option 4 project is progressing at 25
answer is Project is progressing at 75
percent of the rate originally planned
question 4 which of the following is a
conflict resolution technique that may
be used in the project option one with
drawing option 2 to detecting option 3
organizing and option 4 controlling the
answer is withdrawing the config
resolution techniques that may be used
in the given option with the drawing
whereas directing organizing controlling
are not the conflict resolution
techniques question 5 in the process of
monitoring and controlling which of the
following process is equally important
to Monitor and control Option 1 Quality
Control option 2 Change Control option 3
scope control and verification option 4
corrective action answer is Change
Control closing the closing process
group involves assembling a report of
all procedures throughout the Project
Life Cycle the closing process group
marks the formal closure of the project
management implementation question 1
what is the scenario of the project
called when resources are cut from the
project Option 1 extension option 2
addition option 3 integration option 4
starvation answer is starvation question
2 which of the following is performed
when a project is canceled or ends
prematurely it describes the reasons for
cancellation or failure and documents
the deliverables that were completed
Option 1 starvation option 2 close
procurements option 3 postpartum
analysis option 4 post project review
answer is postmortem analysis question 3
during the closing the final project
report communication are based on
options are stakeholder management plan
option 2 communication management plan
option 3 project Charter and option 4
contract answer is communication
management plan during the closing the
final project report Communications are
based on defined communication
management plan question 4 what should
the project manager do among is the
following to complete administrative
closure Option 1 update the records
management plan option 2 satisfy all
exit criteria transfer all deliverables
and store all project documents option 3
transfer project resources and update
the Lessons Learned option 4 review the
scope Baseline answer is satisfy all
exit criteria transfer all deliverables
and store all project management so
these administrative closures has to be
completed while project manager do their
activities as part of project management
while closing a project question 5 the
close project or phase process is not
performed when Option 1 canceling
projects closing projects closing
project phases option 4 reactivating
projects answer is reactivating projects
whereas the close project or phase
process has to be performed while
closing the project canceling the
projects and closing the project phases
whereas reactivating projects at this
point in time the closed project or
phase process is not performed so there
are 10 knowledge areas defined in pmbok
project management framework as part of
PMP so the 10 knowledge areas includes
project integration management project
scope management project cost management
project schedule management project
quality management project Resource
Management project procurement
management project stakeholders
management project risk management
project procurement management and
project stakeholder management so let us
go through those one by one number one
project integration management the
project integration management involves
the coordination of tasks resources
stakeholders and other project elements
the project integration management keeps
track on how one project elements impact
another so this provides a end-to-end
picture of the project and project
manager will perform the very important
processes for project manager for
managing the projects will be there in
integration Management in a way project
manager is also called as project
integrator project scope management
project scope management ensures that a
project includes all the necessary steps
to meet the project objectives and the
project scope statement may change
during Project Life Cycle in case change
in the scope is requested formally so
when we say scope of a project it
involves product scope as well as
project scope which means the features
functionality of the product or a
service or result which is being
produced as part of the project will
have a specific scope to be accomplished
accomplish that you need a specific
resources processes tools techniques so
this itself will have a scope so when
you visualize the scope of approach
project it should be like project scope
what activities resources as well as
products used to produce the result
defining that part of the scope and also
defining the scope of the result the
product service which is an unique
output of a project so scope focus
should be on the both project schedule
management so project schedule
management refers to dividing the
project into several tasks each having
their deadlines and budget project
schedule management defines the order in
which the deliverables must be completed
so which means all the deliverables all
the activities which needs to be done to
deliver that result has to be put in a
specific sequence and order so that
accordingly project executions can
happen project cost management project
cost management includes estimating
managing funding and controlling costs
in the project it focuses on managing
and monitoring the funds regularly to
keep the investors and stakeholders
updated this involves estimate budgeting
and monitoring of the project cost
project quality management so project
quality management refers to the
processes of quality planning quality
control and managing quality throughout
the project the process ensures that the
deliverables achieve the defined quality
criteria in compliance with the defined
processes project Resource Management
project Resource Management involves
planning estimating and acquiring
resources necessary for the project the
process of resource management is a must
for the effective and efficient growth
of the organization so when we say
project resource it involves technology
resource human resources and any tools
any documents which are required as a
resources to be used as part of the
project project communication management
project communication management keeps
the team and stakeholders informed about
the current state of the project so
communication management is also used to
avoid critical failures a project must
have effective communication management
so communication management plays a very
critical role in any project and
wherever there is no proper
communication happening in any part of
the Project Life Cycle that may result
in Failure so communication is very
crucial for the success of any project
mainly project manager spends 90 percent
of the times in the project
communicating so this itself shows the
importance of communication in
delivering projects project risk
management project risk management
refers to the process of identifying the
risk and Performing risk analysis on the
identified risks the risks are optimized
with respect to the amount of impact the
process to the project so risk can be
positive which is called as opportunity
risk can be negative which can be called
as Threat all the risk needs to be
identified and identification of risk
assessing risk and having risk responses
has to happen regularly throughout the
Project Life Cycle it is not the
one-time activity project procurement
management project procurement
management refers to dealing with
outside procurement of projects like
hiring of subcontractors procurement
management impacts the project budget
and the schedule projects take holder
management project stakeholder
management refers to identifying the
stakeholders and finding out what their
concerns are the success of project
depends on the satisfaction of the
stakeholders so the stakeholder list
involves sponsor customer supplier
government agencies the team within the
project management team structure and
anyone and everyone who will influence
influenced impact impacted directly and
indirectly can be called as stakeholders
it is very important to understand who
are the stakeholders what are the
requirements of stakeholders and
accordingly engage with the stakeholders
to ensure the success of the project by
fulfilling the stakeholder requirements
the 49 processes defined in 10 knowledge
areas and five process groups are as
part of project integration management
develop project Charter develop project
management plan direct and manage
Project work manage project knowledge
Monitor and control project work perform
integrated change control and close
project or face scope management
processes would be plan scope management
collect requirements Define scope create
WBS validate scope and control scope the
processes in Project schedule management
are plan schedule management define
activities sequence activities estimate
activity durations develop schedule and
control schedule processes in Project
cost management are Plan cost management
estimate cost determine budget and
control costs the processes in Project
quality management are plan quality
management manage quality and control
quality processes in Project Resource
Management are plan Resource Management
as estimate activity resources acquire
resources develop team manage team and
control resources the processes in
Project communication management are
planned Communications management manage
communication and monitor Communications
the processes in Project risk management
are plan risk management identify risks
perform qualitative risk analysis
perform quantitative risk analysis
monitor risks Implement risk responses
and plan risk responses the processes in
Project procurement management are plan
procurement management conduct
procurements and control procurements
the processes in Project stakeholder
management are identify stakeholders
plans stakeholder engagement manage
stakeholder engagement and monitor
stakeholder engagement now let us look
at project manager salary the salary of
the project manager who does not have
PMP certification that will be around
ninety one thousand dollars whereas the
project manager who who has pre-mp
certification has 20 percent higher
salary compared with the one who does
not have PMP certificate it would be
around 111
000 and today we will learn about PMP
certification before we begin let's have
a look at an incident where two project
managers John and Ted are talking to
each other John is a senior project
manager while Ted is a part of his team
John finds dead to be upset so he asks
him is there anything he can help him
with to which Ted replies that his
project failed Jon further asks him what
could be the possible reason for the
project failure that tells him that it's
because he was not able to manage the
time and budget now John asks him if he
is PMP certified to which debt says he
isn't then John suggested that he must
take the PMP certification which will
not only give his project better
performance but also help him upskill in
his career so today we will discuss
about PMP certification in detail let's
first have a look at all the topics we
will cover we will begin begin with what
is PMP then we will check top 10 reasons
to get PMP certified followed by the
basics of PMP then after we know the PMP
basic concepts we will check who can get
the certification and pattern for the
PMP exam then we will learn about the
pmbok guide which is an integral part to
prepare for the PMP exam finally we will
see the cost and the validity of the
certification so without any further Ado
let's begin with what is PMP PMP or
project management professional is the
world's most renowned project management
certification for project managers this
certification is provided by the project
management Institute now when we know
what is project management professional
or PMP certification let's have a look
at some reasons why you should get PMP
certified today I will give you top 10
reasons to take PMP certification PMP
certification helps you become a better
project manager the process that helps
us acquire the certification goes to
several phases like gaining project
management experience and passing the
PMP exam which helps you in bringing
sanity to the project manager the
process helps project managers to learn
different industry Trends have practical
knowledge and several other project
management constraints the second reason
that we have is project management
certification makes our resume more
valuable as we have discussed earlier
that PMP certification is the most
renowned project management
certification so having it on the resume
will definitely help the interviewer
recognize our skills there are companies
that only accept project managers who
are PMP certified PMP certification not
only helps in switching the job or
finding a new one it helps in
progressing in the current company as
well the third reason that we have is it
provides more job opportunities when one
acquires the PMP certification it proves
that one has expertise in completing the
project effectively and efficiently so
the certification increases the trust
factor of the interviewer in you and
increases your probability of getting
that job the fourth reason that we have
is salary hikes PMP certified project
manager is one of the highest paid jobs
around the globe and this trend will
continue to grow the Global survey by
the project management Institute shows
that PMP certified project managers tend
to get 20 percent more salary than the
non-certified project managers the next
reason that we have is PMP certification
validates your dedication to the job the
certification requires several months of
training it requires several hours of
project management experience and
exposure this experience and exposure
explains the seriousness of a project
manager towards its career path then
sixth we have is PMP certification is
globally acknowledged PMP certification
is the most renowned certification all
over the world it helps project managers
to be a part of different types of
Industries all over the globe PMP
certification is the most renowned
certification all over the world project
managers who are PMP certified may get
jobs in different types of Industries
all over the world PMP certification not
only provides theoretical knowledge but
also helps in gaining practical
knowledge which further helps in
increasing the confidence of a project
manager the next reason that we have is
better project performance PMP certified
project managers tend to deliver better
projects than the non-pmp certified
project managers this is because PMP
certified project managers are well
aware of five process groups 10
knowledge areas and 49 processors which
helps them have a clear picture of
different aspects involved in a project
the eighth reason that we have is it
increases your networking opportunities
there are several communities that one
becomes a part of when they sign up as a
PMI member these communities have
meetings regarding new job opportunities
and this helps in having a professional
Network the ninth reason that we have is
job security job security is a major
reason that a professional thinks of
before opting for a particular
profession today in the world of
recession where companies are drowning
the demand for PMP certified project
managers goes on increasing the last and
the 10th reason we have is expertise in
practical application when one appears
for a PMP exam they need extensive
preparation they need to have thorough
knowledge of process groups and
knowledge areas which help them develop
several essential skills is and move
ahead in their carrier now as we move
further we will look into the PMP basic
concepts the PMP basic concepts are the
five project management steps these
project management steps start from the
day we begin our project to the day we
end our project they begin from
initiation to closure the first step
that we have is initiation planning
execution monitoring and controlling and
closure now let's have a look at each of
them in detail the first step we have is
initiation initiation involves defining
the project scope this is the step where
we explain what our project will have
for whom we are making that project it
helps us to identify our stakeholders
who all will be the part of that project
and determine the project feasibility
after the step of initiation when we
have decided the scope of our project
the Second Step that comes is planning
in the planning phase we Define a flow
to all the activities of a project we
Define this flow keeping in mind all the
constraints of a project like time
resources and risk after we have defined
the flow of these processes it is time
for us to look at the execution in the
execution phase we evaluate the plan and
the sequence of the task we have made we
finally put the plan in action and the
project tends to start after the project
building has started and the process of
execution has started it is time for the
monitoring and the controlling phase in
monitoring and controlling phase the
progress of the project is tracked and
important steps for quality assurance
are taken in monitoring and controlling
phase the work being done is compared
with the work as defined in the project
plan in this phase the progress of the
project is tracked and important steps
for quality assurance are taken finally
we have the closure step in this step
the deliverables are delivered to the
client the documentation of all that
took place during the Project Life Cycle
is done and project is fully evaluated
now when we have seen reasons for
getting PMP certified and we know the
basic concepts of PMP it is time for us
to know who can get PMP certified for
getting PMP certified there can be two
cases the first case is you must have a
secondary degree secondary degree means
high school diploma or an associate
degree or a degree that is globally
equivalent to all of these then you need
to have 7 500 hours of leading and
directing projects and 3 500 hours of
project management education there can
be two cases first case can be you must
have a secondary degree that means a
high school diploma associates degree or
the global equivalent degree then you
must have 7 500 hours of project
management experience and 35 hours of
Education in project management the
second case can be you must have a
four-year degree along with 4 500 hours
of project management experience and 35
hours of Education in project management
now when we know who can get PMP
certified we will see the PMP exam
pattern the exam comprises of 200
questions out of which 175 questions are
used for evaluation one can answer these
questions if they have thorough
knowledge of five process groups and 10
knowledge areas the time provided to
complete the exam is for us the
questions that are asked are of
different types the most common type
being formula based situation based and
knowledge based now when we have
discussed about the exam pattern
discussing about the pmbok guide becomes
very important so the next topic that we
have is pmbok guide pmbok guide or
project management body of knowledge is
a book that comprises of several
processes and different terminologies
needed to crack the PMP exam the whole
syllabus of PMP exam is covered in the
pmbok guide by the project management
and 10 knowledge areas apart from this
there are 49 processes that are divided
amongst five process groups 10 knowledge
areas finally let's have a look at the
cost and validity of the PMP
certification when we talk about the
cost of the certification there can be
two cases the first case can be if we
are not a member of project management
Institute the exam fees is 555 US
Dollars the second case can be if we are
a member of project management Institute
the exam fees is 405 US dollars if we
talk about the validity of the
certification a certificate is valid for
a period of three years after every
three years the certificate needs to be
renewed to renew the certificate when
needs to furnish a proof of 60 ptus or
professional development units after so
much information that thanks John for
his time and Promises to take the PMP
certification at the shortest notice now
let's have a look at the salary trends
of a PMP certified project manager and a
sample resume if we consider the salary
of a non-pmp certified project manager
it is approximately 91 000 while if we
consider the salary of a PMP certified
project manager it is approximately one
hundred eleven thousand dollars which is
approximately 20 percent higher than the
non-certified project manager salary now
let's have a look at the resume of a PMP
certified project manager if you are
somebody with PMP certification and
looking for a project manager or a
senior project manager role your resume
should look something like this the
summary in the beginning would include
how much experience you have and
anything that supports your claim of
being a project manager like air James
Brown has written he has more than 10
years of experience with generating and
building projects then when you talk
about your experience you should put
some something that emphasizes on the
responsibilities that you had your area
of expertise put something that shows
your skill set for the desired post and
also something that you learned from a
former job role this shows that you have
command over your work and also the
determination to skill and upskill
yourself like here James Brown has three
years of experience as an assistant
manager training new Associates and then
more than three years of experience as a
project manager where he not only let
projects but also learn new project
management tools like Trello and
Primavera after this add relevant
information regarding your education
your resume must include skills that you
have or you have gained in your years of
experience like here James Brown has
divided her skills into two parts where
he has written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included a
skill of agile and quality assurance
software as well as he has his knowledge
of different project management tools
then putting your certifications play a
major role this proves that you are up
to date and updated with current market
trends James Brown has his
certifications in C and Java and more
importantly he has his project
management certification project
management professional in this session
we will discuss about project manager
roles and responsibilities let's first
have a look at all the topics we will be
covering today first we will see who is
a project manager then we will check the
rules and responsibilities of a project
manager moving forth we will analyze the
salary of a project manager and the
steps that will help us become a project
manager finally we will see a project
manager's resume so without any further
Ado let's get started with who is a
project manager project manager in
simple words is a professional who
manages the project project manager
plays an integral role from the first
phase of the project lifecycle to the
last phase of Project Life Cycle this
individual is a part of all the
activities that produce the final
deliverables and strive towards the
success of the project now let's
consider some must-have skills of a
project manager first we have is strong
communication skills the communication
skills help the project manager to
communicate the organization's mission
and vision to the team member is in a
clear concise manner these communication
skills help project manager to explain
their thoughts and requirements to
customers and stakeholders the next we
have is effective leadership skills that
helps in forming a team of skilled
professionals and lead them in the best
possible manner the next skill that a
project manager must have is a team
management skill as a project manager it
is very important to know how to manage
your team to achieve a common goal with
complete Harmony a project manager must
have strong negotiation skills as
project managers have to negotiate at
each and every step this negotiation
might be with the customers stakeholders
or team members these negotiation skills
become of utmost importance when project
members get into a fight or an argument
then we have critical thinking this is
what makes a project manager more
effective and efficient in project
management this thinking capability is
needed to take difficult steps talk to
stakeholders and resolve several issues
throughout the course of the project the
last skill that a project manager must
have is risk management skill handling a
project is an important step but what is
equally important is risk management
this is the process required to identify
analyze and respond to the risk factors
throughout the Project Life Cycle now
when we know who a project manager is we
must have a look at the roles and
responsibilities of a project manager
the first and foremost role of a project
manager is to set up a project scope
check its feasibility and determine the
resources that are needed to satisfy the
project scope second rule that a project
manager has is the development of a
project plan according to the project
scope the plan is needed to encourage
the team to hard work with all the
dedication next a project manager is
supposed to set deadlines for the
project deliverables he or she is
supposed to manage time as a priority
and communicate with the team at regular
intervals next important role is to
analyze track and control the budget of
the project project manager has to make
sure that the project does not run out
of budget and is optimized as possible
moving forth effective communication is
one of the most important skill of a
project manager he she is supposed to
maintain communication with all the
stakeholders throughout the project then
we have is the identification and
evaluation of risk in a project project
manager must take steps to minimize the
effect of risk in a project the next
role of a project manager is to track
and control the performance of the team
this helps in yielding the best outputs
with the least number of resources last
role a project manager must have is to
provide reports and documentation of all
the steps involved in project management
this helps in future projects and makes
sure that the mistakes that happened in
the project will not happen again in
ongoing projects now it's time for us to
check the salary of a project manager
the data shows that an average salary of
a project manager in India is
approximately 4 18 lakh rupees per annum
while the average salary of a project
manager in United States is 83 215
dollars per year the next important
thing we must learn is how can we get a
project manager's job there are four
important steps that one must fulfill to
become a project manager the first step
is to have a bachelor's degree it is
important for a person to be a graduate
one can hold a bachelor's degree in any
area of Interest like marketing computer
science or even engineering this
entirely depends on the type of project
manager one wants to be the second
important step is gaining project
management experience this means that a
person must have experience in leading
and directing projects project
management experience helps in taking
different project management
certifications which further help in
having a good paying job the third
essential step is to learn project
management tools there are different
project management tools for different
area of Interest these tools help in
quick and efficient management of work
project management tools are used widely
by organizations now learning these
tools will increase the chances of
getting selected in one of those
organizations the fourth and the last
step is getting project management
certified project management
certifications help an individual to
increase the value of their
certification and validates their
dedication to the job nowadays several
organizations have made it compulsory
for a project manager to be project
management certified there may be
several project management
certifications out of which project
management professional certification or
PMP certification is one of the most
common and widely accepted
certifications the project management
Institute or the PMI predicts that there
will be 22 million new project
management jobs by the year
2027. now it's time for us to know how a
resume of an aspiring project manager
looks like if you are somebody looking
for a project manager role or a senior
project manager role then your resume
should look something like this the
summary in the beginning would include
how much experience you have and
anything that supports your claim of
being a project manager like here James
Brown has written he has more than 10
years of experience with generating and
building projects then when you talk
about your experience you should put
something that emphasizes on the
responsibilities that you had and your
area of expertise put something that
shows your skill set for the desired
post and also something that you learn
from your former job role this shows
that you have command over your work and
also the determination to upskill
yourself like here James Brown has three
years of experience as an assistant
manager where he trained new Associates
and then three years of experience as a
project manager where he not only LED
projects but also learn new project
management tools like Trello and
Primavera after this add relevant
information regarding your education
your resume must include skills that you
have or you have gained in your years of
experience like here James Brown has
divided her skills in two parts where he
has written his technical skills and
non-technical skills he has included his
skill of a child and quality assurance
software as well as he has his knowledge
of different project management tools
like Trello and Primavera then putting
your certifications play a major role
this proves that you are up to date and
updated with current market trends James
Brown has his certifications in C and
Java and more importantly he has his
project management certification in
project management professional or PMB
here as part of this video we are going
to look at few plausible questions which
one would face while going through an
interview this will help them to prepare
for interview and also help to
understand what kind of questions would
come across when they face the interview
in addition to that these questions also
has an Insight towards the role of
project management itself so let us look
at one by one question number one how do
you define a project so as per the pmis
pmbok 6th edition a project is a
temporary Andover undertaken to create a
unique product service or results
the temporary nature of projects
indicates that a project has a definite
beginning and end so when we say this
temporary and over undertaken to create
Unique Products service or results each
project will have a definite start date
and end date once the project team is
formed once the project objectives are
achieved so the team which is formed the
human resources which are onboarded to a
project so those are disseminated sent
backs to their respective functions or
departments and project will be
concluded as complete so project can be
simple or complex and may be managed by
a single person or a group of them so
every project will have a life cycle so
from beginning to end it starts and end
where it acquires lot of resources where
it will divide the Project Life Cycle
into multiple stages or phases where
project is being done and deliverables
will happen through the Milestones
during that live second so projects are
often broken into small tasks to utilize
team strengths and increase productivity
question number two what is a project
Charter so project Charter is a short
document that explains the entire
project so this will become a basic
document which will be given to a
project manager so that a project
manager can understand what is a project
management is all about
so this document would include the
objectives of the project how will they
be carried out who are the stakeholders
identification of risks advantages of
the project and the budget so project
Charter plays an integral while planning
the project as a plan is something that
is used in all the phases of Project
Life Cycle it is very essential because
it provides all the necessary insights a
project manager is needed while taking
up the project
after getting the project Charter the
first job a project manager supposed to
do is to identify the stakeholders even
though project Charter will have a basic
list of stakeholders so project manager
has to contact those stakeholders
establish the list of stakeholders for
the project understand the requirements
in detail and further move towards
planning
what is meant by scope of the project
so project scope is most essential part
of project planning that helps in
determining the list of specific project
goals or deliverables so when we say
this project will have a definite unique
deliverable which has to be created so
this will have a specific description of
the specification as well as the
features functionalities of the
deliverable
so to accomplish that features
functionality of that output what we are
going to create as a result of a project
within a project lot of activities are
done the processes the tools the
resources which are utilized for the
project all falls under this scope
so when we say the term scope it is very
important for us to understand the scope
of a project versus scope of the product
the scope of the project involves all
those processes resources and activities
what we do to accomplish the result
whereas product scope is the one which
we speak about that result itself the
features functionalities of that result
itself so one needs to understand the
difference between this project scope
and product scope and Define accordingly
so this will help in identification of
the Project's output and why that output
is created and how these particular
product or services or results will help
organization or business to accomplish
their objectives this should be the
basic understanding a project manager
should have
so it includes everything that is to be
achieved by the project which means all
those results what needs to be achieved
all those value which has to be created
by the results so we need to keep in
mind the result itself is not the
ultimate objective of an organization it
is not instead the result will help
organization to accomplish their
objectives for example if you take in HR
department if they introduce an intranet
portal for claim processing so the
application what is created as part of
the exercise of initiative where my
employees should submit their claims
through a specific portal now that is to
reduce the time the processing duration
as well as the efficiency and
effectiveness of the processed claim
what is submitted so this is an outcome
so keeping that outcome the objective
this portal is created that portal
itself has the features and
functionalities which project will focus
and create that results so through that
result organization would accomplish
their objectives that should be kept in
mind so understanding the scope is
essential so while understanding the
scope also need to understand how this
particular output the product results is
going to add value to the business what
is the outcome of that that is also very
important to understand one is
understanding the scope ensuring the
project is delivered within that scope
and all that required to be done to
accomplish that scope has to be done and
only that not anything more than that
not anything lesser than that
what is Project Life Cycle as I was
mentioning during The Question three
there is a project scope so project
itself has a life cycle so this project
scope falls under this Project Life
Cycle so Project Life Cycle refers to
the beginning and end of the project
there is a life so you initiate a
project trigger a project project is
actually started and as it starts it
progresses creating the results and then
it ends project can end in various
different scenarios one is by
accomplishing the objective of the
project the ultimate results the
deliverable it creates and then ends our
project may also get closed prematurely
so we are not going to look at the why
the project is going to close
prematurely at the moment
our idea is to understand what is
Project Life Cycle and to visualize that
so this entire span of time the project
spends from the beginning to end it
involves various different stages or
phases whatever the term you want to
call it and in each of these stages or
phases there is a milestone deliverables
which are measured and that will be part
of the ultimate deliverable what is
going to be delivered as a result of a
project
so it involves all the activities all
the processes all the resources which
needs to be acquired managed and then
the results needs to be accomplished
ultimately
so here in a Project Life Cycle
it involves five process groups which
mainly focuses on different different
activities and dynamics of the project
which we call it as the initiation
process group planning process group
execution process group monitoring and
controlling process group and closure
process group
so during initiation process group the
creation of a project Charter
appointment of the project manager and
identification of this key stakeholder
will be done this can be initiation of
the project as a whole or as a part of a
specific stage or a face
now all these process group what I
mentioned initiation planning execution
monitoring closure all of these process
groups can be looked at their
involvement in the entire Project Life
Cycle at the same time it can also be
seen as part of a single fix
so each of the process groups are
applicable like initiation of a project
if I say similarly initiation of a stage
or a face
so the planning process group involves
the process of creating the plan for
achieving the Project's objectives so
this would create the detailed plan for
entire project or a skeleton plan for a
project if it is a agile or rolling wave
project
if that approach is taken Like a Rolling
wave or Progressive elaboration or agile
approaches then the skeleton of the
project plan is created if waterfall
approach is taken it's quite obvious the
comprehensive the detailed project plan
will be created project management plan
is also involved in this
now in addition to this as you progress
in the project for each stage or a phase
there needs to be a plan which is
detailed further compared to the project
plan itself which will become ultimately
part of big plan of a project
the execution process groups involves
the project management processes for
identification allocation and management
of resources required for executing the
project deliverables
so here the actual execution happens
being a project manager the focus should
be on managing the project so many a
time I have seen project manager is
going and doing tasks looking at the
task level transaction level which was
not project management thought so one
needs to ensure the project management
is not about deliverables in terms of
doing the tasks it's about getting the
deliverables from the team
so active involvement in terms of
acquiring the resources checking whether
the accomplishment of results has
happened needs to be done throughout the
Project Life Cycle so it's all about
directing and manage project works and
at the same time managing the knowledge
which is acquired during the Project
Life Cycle
the monitoring and controlling process
groups involves the process for project
manager to monitoring and controlling
the project now this involves reviewing
this involves creation of reports this
involves concluding yes project has
delivered or not delivered
identification of the deviations and
initiating with the change request for
necessary Corrections so monitoring and
control will be done throughout the
Project Life Cycle and only with an
effective monitoring and control we can
see the success in a project
so the closer process group involves the
process which is required for formally
closing the project where everything
including what went wrong and what went
right all through the project is summed
up so here especially in the closing
process group we will not focus on
acceptance of the deliverable instead
we'll focus on sign off capturing
lessons learned all the formalities
which needs to be completed as part of a
closure then where are we going to
accept the deliverables this happens in
monitoring and controlling so while
doing the monitoring and controlling we
will validate validate against what is
planned comparing with what is being
delivered so when we compare both one
would understand what is delivered
versus what actually was planned so
their acceptance happens once the
acceptance happens there only then the
project moves towards closure project or
face either of that so when we say
closure process group it involves the
process for a closure of that phase
whether accomplishment of all the
objectives all the deliverables of the
phase is done or not is checked if it is
a phase if it is a project in the
project perspective if everything is
completely checked and then it moves to
closing process group where the lessons
learned the formal sign of everything
will be done as part of this closing
process group
what is the importance of process groups
so process groups are set of processes
that are applicable to various stages of
the project as I mentioned earlier each
of the processes has a defined set of
inputs and produced defined outputs by
applying a set of tools and techniques
on the input the initiation process
groups involves the processes needed to
initiate the project that is develop
project Charter and identify
stakeholders the two processes the
project Charter will be handed over to
the project manager and formal
Declaration of appointment of the
project manager will be done further
project manager has to identify the key
stakeholders and take forward the
project as per the direction set in the
project Charter so in this group in this
process group initiation process group
it is a formal Declaration of
appointment of project manager to the
project but one needs to remember should
not get confused in real time we see an
individual who is about to become a
project manager for a project sits and
create a project Charter we have seen
that in reality so does it mean that
what is told here is wrong compared to
what is practiced that is not the idea
many organization thinks if we involve
the project manager to be project
manager of a project while creating the
project Charter itself the level of
information the detail that person will
have about a project will be more
compared to a person they will become a
project manager after handing over the
project Charter so there is a difference
the person takes the project Charter and
become aware of the project that is one
scenario the person actively involved in
creating a project Charter and then
become a project manager that is better
scenario where the person will be more
informed But ultimately the
accountability of a project Charter lies
with the sponsor formal Declaration of
appointment of project manager
confirmation of that happens only when
project Charter is approved and handed
over to the person who is to be project
manager so that's where actual
initiation of project happens then
project manager can move at and start
identifying the stakeholders and start
collecting the details of the
stakeholders their requirements and
stakeholders cannot give all the
requirements comes coming to their mind
they need to restrict those project
detailing what needs to be provided the
planning process group defines the
detail plan of the project which
involves the planning for scope time
cost quality resource risk procurement
stakeholders communication and
integration of all the subsidiary plans
each of this plan like scope management
plan schedule management Plan cost
management plan quality management plan
Resource Management plan risk management
plan procurement management plan
stakeholder engagement plan
communication management plan so all
these plans are called as subsidiary
plans so all these plans are integrated
and detailed project management plan
will be created so this involves various
tools and techniques like expert
judgment meetings analogous estimation
parametric estimation decomposition pert
critical path method depending on the
specific area which has been focused on
while planning for example expert
judgment is a common technique used
across all the areas like scope time
cost quality all of these nine areas
knowledge areas which I was mentioning
expert judgment meetings are mostly seen
as a technique used during each of these
planning whereas when it comes to
critical path method so critical path
method is about scheduling so we will
see the technique only in mostly in
schedule management similarly if I speak
about decomposition we see that in scope
management so likewise there are
specific techniques which are specific
to a specific knowledge areas which we
need to identify as we go through the
entire framework itself
similarly there are common techniques
used across the knowledge areas which if
you can identify that common techniques
which are used across knowledge areas it
is easy for us to remember and recall
those similarly specific techniques for
a specific knowledge area
the execution process group involves the
processes to direct and manage the
project works the active involvement of
the members of the team is seen
performing their task to execute the
project Works although the project plan
is finalist there may be changes in
requirements that come from the
stakeholders which are considered for
further modifications so actual
involvement of Team delivering something
acquiring the team onboarding the team
onboarding the supplier identification
of them doing the bidder conference
engaging with stakeholders all this
action should happen sir because the
main focus of execution process group in
project management perspective is
directing and managing Project work and
managing the project knowledge which is
very very important
the monitoring and controlling process
group refers to tracking and reviewing
the progress and performance of the
project the process of monitoring and
controlling is continually performed
throughout the Project Life Cycle so
here I think as I mentioned earlier as
well so it is very essential for us to
understand whether project has delivered
all those required deliverables or not
are the deliverables are fulfilling all
the features and functionality which are
defined during the planning that
validation should happen any deviations
are found change requests arised and
these change requests are approved once
it is approved then it comes to
integrated Change Control process
through which changes are executed then
the closing process group involves
assembling a report of all procedures
throughout the Project Life Cycle the
closing process group marks the formal
closure of the project and completion of
its deliverables now let us move to the
next question
so question number six name 10 knowledge
areas as mentioned in the PM book so the
10 knowledge areas are project
integration management project scope
management project schedule management
project cost management project quality
management project Resource Management
project Communications management
project risk management project
procurement management and project
stakeholder manager the project
integration management basically focuses
on unification and integration of all
the project to manage it in an
integrated way a project manager is also
called as an integrator which means a
project manager should have a end-to-end
visibility of the project so all the
rest of the nine knowledge areas the
plan which is created as part of all the
next 109 knowledge areas those are
Consolidated and a comprehensive project
management plan will be created in
Project integration management so this
is the only knowledge area where we see
the processes in all the process groups
whereas in the rest of the knowledge
areas if you see we don't see any
processes in initiating process group
except stakeholder management
so integration management has one
process similarly stakeholder management
has one process in initiation process
group similarly in closing process group
only integration management has a
process no other knowledge areas has any
processes so this is the only knowledge
area where we find processes in all the
process groups which means it is very
important to look at a project in an
end-to-end view perspective a full view
of a project should be known to the
project management only the project
manager can become successful in doing
the project management the next
knowledge area project scope management
which focuses on ensuring collecting
requirements defining scope creating
work breakdown structures and scope
Baseline so scope management focuses on
ensuring the necessary scope is defined
and provided so that during execution
projects are delivered accordingly and
monitoring controlling of the scope the
validation of the scope will be based on
what is defined in the planning what is
planned as part of scope management
similar to scope Management in schedule
management once that work breakdown
structure is created it is very
essential to understand what it takes in
terms of efforts what it takes in terms
of duration and in what sequence project
deliverables are completed in what
sequence activities are done so schedule
management focuses on that the critical
the important technique what we use when
it comes to schedule management is
critical path method so in a given
project when we establish a network
diagram so we may see multiple paths
from beginning to end of the project so
some paths will be the longest path
which is called as critical path and
that will be the minimum time which is
required to complete the project so
schedule management plan provides us a
detailed schedule of a project along
with sequencing and duration and at the
same time that is considered as a
scheduled Baseline then the cost
management so when we say cost it is
very essential for us to understand it
is an outgoing money outgoing monetary
value so projects incurs cost when I say
project incurs cost their needs an
investment from the organization who is
actually doing this project so the cost
needs to be assessed means an
approximation of the cost needs to be
done a budget has to be allocated to the
project and within that budget the
project needs to be completed it cannot
go beyond that so budget is established
allocation of budget and confirmation of
budget happens and cost perspective
monitoring of the project happens based
on what is that specific budget it has
within that project has to done that
will become a baseline cost Baseline so
to measure the cost and schedule a
technique called earned value management
is used well the terminology like cost
performance index schedule performance
index actual cost earned value planned
value budgeted completion estimate to
complete so these are the terminologies
which are used as part of earned value
management now let us move to Quality
Management project quality management so
so it is very essential for us to ensure
all the processes all the activities all
the templates defined by the project are
complied with that is first thing while
doing the project during the Project
Life Cycle similarly the deliverables
which comes out of a project at the end
of the project or at the end of the
specific phase or specific stage or
specific Milestone so those deliverables
should be according to the
specifications defined and agreed upon
so quality management focuses on
establishing that quality management
approach so that project compliance is
maintained at the same time the results
what is delivered is as per the
specification what is agreed the
resource management focuses on ensuring
all the resources which are required for
the project are acquired configured
installed if it is a technology
resources if it is a human resources the
necessary induction of the project the
brainstorming required for team to
understand what is the project is all
about is given and the necessary skills
and capabilities are there with those
human resources and these team members
execute the task of the project so
project Resource Management plays very
important role and now here when we say
Scope when we say schedule when we say
cost when we call it in each of this in
other knowledge areas as well the
involvement of each of these resources
are essential so what resources gets
into scope management what resources
gets into schedule management what into
cost likewise for each of the knowledge
areas we see various different resources
used when I say in schedule management
effort has to be established while we
establish an effort it is also required
to understand what is the skills and
capabilities required so schedule
management definitely work when you
close with Resource Management similarly
this each of this resource comes with
cost so obviously cost management is
involved then quality yes so who is
going to do the quality management so
roles and responsibilities needs to be
clearly articulated defined if it is a
human resource in Resource Management
coming to communication management so
communication I think plays very
important role as We Know ninety percent
of the time project manager spends on
Communications many times we see project
managers like look only communicating
many team members have told me
mentioning that project manager only
does communication project manager only
ask questions now this impression to the
team gets created because they only see
what project manager is doing is
communication because team comes in when
everything is done everything is set
right so there they see project manager
during the monitoring and control mainly
not during initiation not during
planning not during closure so many team
member comes and goes during the project
they only see project managers reviewing
and asking the questions so because of
this they assume project manager only
communicates project manager only ask
questions but it is very important to
ask questions but there is a prospective
and objective behind it which already
project manager is involved and created
like a plan like signing off
coordinating with stakeholders
understanding requirements many things
as done in all these areas communication
is involved so it plays very vital role
so then project risk management every
initiatives organization Stakes every
investment organization does there is a
risk so already the identified risks are
evaluated and project is taken up by the
organization which means the business
has already understood what is the risk
associated with this particular project
considering that they have taken up a
project but while doing this project
while doing the project management lot
of risk comes across project manager
should keep identifying the risk
assessing the risk analyzing the risks
qualitatively and quantitatively
depending on the level of impact of the
risk so risk means we already know it is
uncertainty of certain occurrence an
outcome it may be positive or negative
positive you can take advantage of that
you'd exploit it you enhance it whereas
negative risk you mitigate you respond
you will have a response plans like
accepting those or transferring It
sharing it transferring means you
Outsource or you take an insurance so
that is negative risk responses next the
project procurement management the
projects would involve certain
procurement so we need to ensure for
this project what is that I am creating
myself and using it what is that I am
going to procure from external suppliers
so whichever we decided in make or buy
decisions whichever we have decided that
we need to procure from elsewhere so
procurement management plays a very
important role here so identification of
what needs to be procured what quantity
we need to procute who would be the best
supplier what are the criterias while
selecting the suppliers you may float an
RFP a proposal request will be a respond
which will come in you may float a bit
when you evaluate the best vendor or
supplier you onboard them then you start
issuing a PO formally for them to supply
and then procurement happens so end to
end management of the supplier right
from automoting the suppliers doing the
bidder conference establishing an
agreement and then engaging with them
for reviewing their performance all
these are involved less part of
procurement management the 10th
knowledge area the projects stakeholder
management so stakeholder means any
entity or individual who involves in the
project directly or indirectly they are
impacted they influence the project and
they get influenced so very importantly
if you think about the stakeholders we
can think about customers we can think
about sponsor we can think about team
members suppliers who plays very vital
role in the success of the project so
engaging with the stakeholders managing
the stakeholders plays very important
roles And if every nine knowledge areas
there is something which You've Done
Right but something wrong done with the
stakeholder management entire project
may go for toss so one is to be very
careful understanding the Dynamics
associated with each of these 10
knowledge areas and then dealt with them
accordingly and integration management
could integrate all of this as I
mentioned earlier so that end-to-end
visibility of the project can be seen so
that is about 10 knowledge areas
mentioned in PMB okay the next question
question number seven why is the project
planning considered as the most
significant step in Project Life Cycle
the project planning is more significant
this will provide all the Baseline plans
like as we saw in the previous question
scope Baseline cost Baseline schedule
Baseline so all the baselines required
which will be referred right each of the
baselines are considered based on these
baselines project needs to be executed
now many deviations to this Baseline
plans need to have a formal approval for
necessary Corrections so already we know
there are nine types of subsidiary plans
for all the nine knowledge areas scope
schedule cost quality resource risk
procurement communication and
stakeholder these are the nine knowledge
areas which will have a subsidiary
replies which will get integrated in
integration management so without having
a clear plan Clear Directions so
execution will not have any specific
direction to take so you cannot measure
the deliverables so what to do when to
do who will do all these are defined as
part of the planning and that plays a
very important thing so if you look at
the entire framework of PMP most of the
processes out of 49 processes we can see
in planning process group almost like 24
processes out of 49 50 of the processes
almost can be sealing planning process
Group which itself indicates how
important the planning process group and
planning activity for a project so why
the project plan is considered most
significant let us look at few more
points so one is it provides visibility
in terms of what project is all about
what is that we are going to deliver and
what kind of results are we going to
create what is that we're aiming for
we'll get a better visibility so next
increases employee satisfaction because
there is no confusion each team member
understand what needs to be delivered
and what is that performance of the team
members how it is measured is also
visible and that is happening in reality
because you cannot deviate on what is
being planned so that should happen in
actual execution as well so obviously
employees are not confused now the team
members are not confused they're
delivering it according to what is
planned and it is easy for them also
because it is a better visibility and
they have a clarity about it next is
quality assurance and control so as we
know quality management is one of the
knowledge areas so doing timely audits
testing all the deliverables compliance
checks so all these in shoots the
approach what we have selected covering
all of this ensures the project is
delivered as we planned then reduces
project risk because all the risks are
identified we have understood what are
the risks are and we keep identifying
the risk and analyzing those and when we
share risk there is one unique nature of
risk where exactly the risk occurs
accordingly the impact of the projects
will be there for example when I start a
project if there is a risk associated
with human resources which I have not
even onboarded non-availability of a
specific resource very less impact but
when I am onboarded a resource and then
project execution is happening and
execution is at Peak now what happens it
is quite obvious risk impact will be
higher compared to the risk which would
have occurred in the beginning of the
project so meaning as we progress in in
the life cycle of a project the
identified risk will have an impact
differently at the different parts of
the life cycle depending on the nature
of the risk and state of the project so
since it is visible to us we have a risk
management knowledge area which
emphasizes on doing all of this so since
we are doing it it will become visible
for us to have an effective risk
management so next question when is
stakeholder analysis performed already
nibino stakeholder means an entity or
individuals who involve directly or
indirectly who get influenced will get
impacted are all called as stakeholders
understanding who are those stakeholders
who are basically straight in terms of
having impact or impacted so we need to
identify them and manage them we may
have a stakeholder like competition to
our organization but do we really manage
them not required we may required to be
sensitive what competition is doing is
this project is unique so that the
details of this project the information
on about this project is not leaked to
the competition is not shared with
competition in that sensitivity you need
to ensure monitoring it you need not
manage the competition here but you need
to monitor what is happening relating to
computation similarly stakeholder like
team member so you are equipped to
manage them you cannot just keep
monitoring you need to manage them so
that there can be the results which is
required to be created has created now
next is customer if you say you need to
engage with them you know to discuss
with them you need to review with them
that customer is getting what customers
asked for right so stakeholder may be
anyone who is affected because of
project stakeholder analysis plays an
important role to identify and analyze
their needs right so the analysis is
generally performed Whenever there is a
need of any clarifications over
quantitative and qualitative data the
clarification helps in understanding the
interest of the stakeholders which plays
a vital role in the success of the
project as I mentioned earlier
so next question for us what is the role
of stakeholder in project management
so stakeholder as we know refers to any
organization or entity that can have any
positive or negative effect due to
project because their interests are most
important their positive impact need to
be kept in mind while any negative
impact need to minimized while planning
for executing any activity during the
project
so it is very important to understand
the stakeholder perspective view next
question what are some essential
features to be kept in mind while
choosing a project management tool so
project management tools basically
assist the project manager and the
project team in doing the project
effectively and I think efficient way of
doing project is also ensured because
many processes are automated and the
transaction will become easier the
collaboration becomes easier creation of
dashboards and reports which will
provide the visibility of the
performance of the project so let us
look at some of the essential features
required by project management tools so
risk management just now we discussed
about risk management and its importance
if a project management tool assist
while identifying and managing risk
because when we identify risk we update
those in a risk register so if tool has
established risk register where we can
keep inputting this particular risks and
keep alerting the specific details about
wave 5S frequency of analyzing the risk
repeatedly the identified risk so
informing us reminding us telling that
this risk calendar is like this you may
require to analyzer that will help in
making it better right risk assessment
as well as updates in terms of managing
the risk or also Lessons Learned earlier
some risks which of similar kind which
are identified or managed like this so
Lessons Learned recalling those coming
to Resource Management so tool can able
to help us in terms of calculating the
expenditures and distribute them among
the tasks so that it is helpful in terms
of better management of resources as
well as the cost associated with that
then dependencies milestones and
critical path
so most of the project management tools
what we have come across minimum they
will have this capability establishing a
Gantt chart helping in terms of
establishing a network diagram which
will provide us a visibility in terms of
what is that the project flow would be
how the project flow would go on and how
the project is going to complete what
are the activities dependent on each
other so what are the relationship
between each of the tasks what are the
Milestone deliverables duration of the
project what are those activities
happening in parallel so visually
graphical representation it would give
so it should also minimize simplify the
tool should have that capability it
should also have a minimal interfaces or
ease of doing things like drag and drop
interfaces so ease functionalities
maintaining smooth maintenance and
support which it can help us in terms of
doing a project management better so
basically tools helps us in terms of
assisting to have efficient and
effective project management
so all the information should be handy
so that it is there with us always so
third party integration like a tool must
be able to help us in terms of
collaborating with other tools which
should help us in sharing information it
would help us in terms of providing
better visibility any other tools which
are there in the organization if I am
speaking about documentation records
sharing or any of the reports or
creation of the dashboards this are the
capabilities which a tool can have and
at the same time this can have an
interface with other tools like Dropbox
Google Drive which will help in have a
better visibility and better
collaboration so agile workflow system
when we say the functions features
functionality of this particular tool
should help us becoming agile so moving
faster means quick inputs and feedbacks
given because when we say agile we are
moving faster when we're moving faster
there should be quick feedbacks which
should be coming back so that necessary
Corrections can be made quickly so to do
this if tool can assist us in providing
those details of increased flexibility
and transparency so that would help in
becoming more productive then dashboards
to manage projects dashboards which will
provide what is complete what is not
complete what is the status of the
project how is the performance so this
would help in having a quick visibility
into the performance of the project and
also the progress of the project to
track them so that what is complete what
is not complete and how it is
progressing is it ahead of schedule
behind schedule is it within budget or
over budget the visibility to that will
always help in terms of getting better
project management done then
customizable workflows so the tool
should be able to adapt to the unique
process to track work progression so
then if it provides a mobile application
integration so better to have team to
know what is the status of it anytime
anywhere so that ease of moving forward
faster in the project management and
making decisions will become easier
because always having right information
in the right time with the right people
is very essential so that decision
making can be more informed and quicker
then collaborate easily the tool should
enable user to share documents files
status timelines and tasks with ease and
quickly with many people then delegating
task easily you should be able to
delegate tasks assign roles and then
ensure they have access to the right
information
so that's all about tools now we'll move
to the next question so what do you
think is the difference between projects
programs and portfolio so this looks
like a very generic question which is
asked by any individuals during the
interview but even though this question
doesn't focus on Project in specific it
is very essential for project manager to
understand the difference between these
three so that whom to ask for what will
be known to the project manager so the
definition of project is like a
temporary Andover it's an activity that
is used to create a unique product
service or results we saw that we
understood already whereas program is a
collection of related projects which are
managed as group to achieve better
Effectiveness and efficiency so when
which you don't get when you manage a
project individually if you group it and
manage you can share resources you can
optimize other resources and cost you
can standardize that you can achieve
through program management so portfolio
management is again group of projects
and programs which may be related
unrelated but strategic objective
accomplishing strategic objectives of
the organization is very essential so
all these projects and programs and
other related works are grouped together
with a common strategic objective
organization so the project manager
versus program manager versus portfolio
managers what do they do so project
manager expects change and implements
processes to manage and control the
project in terms of accomplishing the
project objective whereas program
manager expects changes from inside and
outside the program to provide strategic
benefits as I mentioned earlier like
standardization optimization so
portfolio manager monitors changes in
the overall context of the Strategic
plan of the organization is this
projects or programs or whatever we do
in this organization are they aligned to
strategic objectives are they helping to
accomplish the Strategic objectives so
project managers manages and coordinate
the team to ensure access whereas
program manager manages the program
staff and the project manager providing
leadership and vision the portfolio
manager May coordinate or manage the
portfolio management staff
then monitoring part of it project
manager monitors and controls starts to
produce the products results or Services
of the project whereas program manager
monitors the progress of components to
lead the program to success portfolio
manager manages the aggregated portfolio
performance and value indicators so
planning part of it project manager
develops monitors and controls project
plans throughout the Project Life Cycle
whereas program manager develops the
program plan and performs high level
planning to guide component level
planning whereas portfolio managers
perform plannings at a portfolio level
the scope the project manager will
develop Monitor and control throughout
the life cycle of the project whereas
program manager as a program which has a
wider scope aimed at meeting the
benefits and goals of the organization
whereas portfolio has a scope that
changes with change in the Strategic
plan and goals of the organization so
why the Strategic goals or plans would
change the directions would change that
has various different reasons maybe a
business scenario market conditions Etc
the success of the project is based on
time taken to finish the project the
budget within which it is completed the
scope the customer satisfaction the
quality defines the success whereas the
program success is measured in terms of
benefits it delivered as it expected
from the program then the portfolio
success is the aggregated performance of
all its components programs and projects
question number 12 what are the skills a
project manager must possess
typically a project manager would
require to have effective communication
skills so communication skills help in
terms of establishing better
relationship because it plays a vital
role there what do we communicate when
do we communicate how do we communicate
matters because it's not about just
verbal communication or return
communication there is non herbal
communication through body languages
through Expressions which individuals do
the communication so it is very
essential to have a right method and
right approach towards communication so
the project manager should possess that
skill code leadership skills so many
times the term leadership is confused
with the position of a leader no so
leadership is basically capability of an
individual so if you have specific
individual having that capability can
influence people can Inspire can
motivate project manager having a
leadership skills it's very essential it
is a must required skill only then
project manager can make the people
listen to him people will respect him
because the behavior will be guided
through that capability strong Team
Management skill which requires a an
engagement which requires a
communication and Leadership skills work
very closely with the steam management
skills so understanding the Team
Dynamics ensuring the right education
right skilled individuals are in place
and they are monitored and managed it is
very important so there should be a
little bit of mentoring which needs to
be done to the people regularly so that
team gets what is expected out of them
and they do accordingly then effective
negotiation skills a lot of scenarios
which comes in terms of negotiating in
various different scenarios negotiate to
ensure things are being in place or in
the interest of both the parties
involved in the negotiation it is very
important to involve and make a right
discussion right side of discussion so
that stakeholders are benefited now who
are these roles we are speaking about
who would involve in negotiation we can
think of customers while establishing an
agreement we can think of teams while
having some conflict resolutions which
you take team will have a conflict you
may required to resolve so Supply is
related issues which needs to be
resolved so negotiation is very
important but always
negotiations would be in the interest of
both the involved parties then critical
thinking so critical thinking in the
sense not just seeing what is there it's
about how to set it right how to take it
forward in the right direction so what
could cause visualizing things is very
important risk management skills it's
quite obvious the most ignored area what
which I have seen throughout is risk
management so I don't know what is the
reason risk is ignored many of the
projects what I have seen almost like 80
to 85 percent people don't even look at
the risks so it is very essential to
look at the risk and manage the risk
only then project can become successful
so question 13 what will be involved in
Project scope management so we already
know project scope means it involves
both project scope as well as product
scope now scope management basically
ensures project includes all those
necessary things to be done in terms of
activities in terms of processes in
terms of resources that project
objectives can be accomplished so this
particular process project scope
management describes the project scope
on documents how it will be designed
validated and controlled throughout the
Project Life Cycle so it collects
requirement so collect requirement
process engages with stakeholders
discusses with them to understand what
is the requirement collect the
requirements document the requirements
and establish requirement management
plan then based on this requirement
established scope has to be defined
means the detailed description of the
project and product has to be developed
and a list has to be created that
includes all the requirements then
create getting the WBS work breakdown
structure once the scope is defined so
now the decomposition of that scope
definition what is given has to be taken
into the lowest possible level it has to
be like logically further it cannot be
subdivided right so decomposition
basically helps in terms of breaking
down those ultimate deliverable to
multiple lower level parts for example
if I consider a car I can think about
two broad categories like exteriors and
Interiors now in exteriors I can think
of a body of the car the rear view
mirror the wheel the Bonnet the glass so
I can just decompose like this now until
I decompose to the mirror further I
cannot decompose in the mirror what are
all the things we can think of mirror
cap mirror glass mirror Mount so further
can I subdivide this no so each of the
components involved in all the
perspective in the car perspective
broadly initially decomposed it to the
level interior exteriors and further
down the line we took to the next level
of components further down in the line
we gain decompose it now at the lowest
level we actually look at the effort
estimation activity resource required
all these we look at and we will do
bottom up to consolidate to see what is
the scope so which will help us in
becoming scope Baseline so validate
scope is a process in monitoring and
controlling which involves reviewing the
deliverables with the customer or
sponsor to ensure successful completion
and formal acceptance of the
deliverables so formal acceptance is a
key requirement when we validate the
scope if it is not according to the plan
that is rejected and it is sent back for
Change and Nursery Corrections then
control scope so in this process the
status of the project and product scope
is monitored changes to the scope
Baseline which is actually defined as
part of the planning if anything is seen
in terms of deviation that needs to be
corrected the change request would be
raised
then next question tell us about some
project management tools so some of the
most common and popular management tools
which have come across are listed here
like plutio Basecamp teamwork projects
Zoho projects Asana jira software Trello
I think details of this you may required
to go to individual tool sections and
then review those better if you can able
to create a comparison sheet always
helps in terms of understanding what is
that features function at each of this
tool has so one more tool which is not
mentioned it is Microsoft Project so
which is also another popular tool which
is used and similarly I can mention like
primer wearer so each of this has its
own advantages disadvantages so you may
require to list out what do you exactly
want in terms of when you take up a tool
for a project management and what each
of this tool has if you can able to
create a comparison sheet that would
help you in terms of selecting the right
tool for your organization and projects
question number 15 what is the
significance of monitoring and
controlling in the Project Life Cycle so
as we know monitoring and controlling is
a process group so this involves
tracking the Project's performance
alongside the planned project management
activities this also focuses on
comparing actual and planned performance
so we have defined that in the planning
so what needs to be accomplished how it
has to be accomplished what templates
are to be used what needs to be
delivered we have defined it in planning
so that needs to be compared with actual
thing what is created and what is that
how are we doing this currently what it
is done is it complied with assessing
performance to determine any corrective
actions are identified their status
reported and appropriate responses to
risks are taken so ensuring an accurate
information base providing information
to support status reporting measuring
progress and forecasting adding
forecasts to update cost and current
schedule information making sure
approved changes are being implemented
upon successfully performing monitoring
and control the processes within
monitoring and controlling process group
so the possible outcomes would be like
the change request or performance
reports update to project management
plan and project documents maybe if
everything is okay well for example
validate scope which comes under this
process group so if when we validate if
everything is okay as per the plan then
it is accepted deliverable which will
move towards the closure if it is not
obviously it leads towards change
requests so question number 16 what's
the key difference in the roles of the
project and program manager so project
manager is basically focuses on projects
and its success of the project as we
know already whereas program manager
looks at all those projects which fall
under the program are managed together
and taken forward in the required
Direction so program manager plans
program level activities and the
schedule of projects so program managers
defines terms of reference for projects
the starts stops and monitor progress of
constituent projects manages program
level risks and issues they set up
policies and procedures for projects the
resolve conflicts they determine the
program standards similarly project
manager focuses on planning a Project
based on dependencies and interfaces
given by the project manager so Works
within the defined tar terms of
references given for the projects runs a
project reports to program manager
manage project risks and issues and
escalates them to program manager if
required if at all a project is part of
a program if it is not then that
escalation goes to sponsor so project
manager runs projects according to the
policies and procedures users resources
assigned to project manager and delivers
the products that satisfy the
requirements question number 17 what are
the types of risks involved in the
project so we know that one of the
knowledge areas in the project
management is risk management it is very
essential for us to identify assess and
analyze risk and have the risk response
plans so while doing it it is also very
important for us to understand
categorizing the risks depending on
where exactly what category this risk
falls into but depending on the impacts
for example some of the list which is
given common types of risk the risk
categories you can think of it may be
related to cost schedule performance
technology or technical strategic legal
Market risk risk related external
hazards and it goes on so these are the
minimum set of lists which we can think
of in any project the the kind of risk
are associated with which area so when I
say cost Associated risk it's all about
monetary related where we invest where
we actually monitor the budget involve
that budget incur that cost related to
that schedule in terms of doing it
faster doing it slower doing it as per
the plan so various different details
which are associated with the schedule
likewise each of these types what we
have mentioned will have a risk
accordingly associated with them so
question number 18 what is the
difference between the risk and a issue
in context of project management so when
we say risk is always we look at in the
future so it's an uncertainty of outcome
when we say we are looking at a future
it may be next moment in the future but
it is risk which is focused on the
future so risks may be positive or
negative any risk we identify may have
positive or negative impact whereas risk
response will be in accordance with the
risk response planning and this are
documented in Risk register
so issue is always the one which we have
in front of us to manage so it is
focused on present always negative it
will have negative impacts so response
will be in accordance to the issue work
around provided and these are documented
in the issue register so next question
question number 19 how does project
scheduling help in Project execution
project scheduling makes sure there is a
sequence of how all the tasks will be
performed after the resources are
estimated and plan is made the schedule
plays a very important role because when
to do when it is planned it is very
essential to do accordingly so providing
the sequence what activity has to be
done in what sequence it's also very
important so this must be carried out
first and what should follow needs to be
clearly understood the optimized
scheduling of tasks provides the best
possible output with the allocated
resources and that has to be done within
the schedule time within the deadline
question number 20 what do you
understand by quality control now
quality control refers to activities
needed to evaluate if the project meets
all the requirements with respect to the
scope of the project learning now when
we say a control we should think about
the output of a project the deliverable
it has a specifications so relating to
that specifications the features
functionalities what needs to be
delivered is it delivered accordingly so
project managers defines the standard
that the project must fulfill to be
successful quality control includes
validating the deliverables satisfying
the requirements of the stakeholders
identifying the cause of poor project
quality and taking necessary actions to
eliminate problems all right question
number 21 explain the forming in Team
Dynamics basically when we say Team
Dynamics it involves various different
stages like forming storming norming
performing and adjourning so forming
happens first now this happens when the
team first meets each other so when they
meet each other they get introduced to
each other and get to know their
backgrounds experience and areas of
expertise the team members discuss about
the project discuss the project
objectives and beginning to think their
role in the project they beginning to
understand they know what is this
project is all about so in detail what
is this project is all about will be
understood by them in storming which is
the next stage in the Team Dynamics
question number 22 so what is work
breakdown structure and how does it
affect the work estimates of tasks or
activities work breakdown structure is a
hierarchical replica of all the work in
in the project for example if I take up
a specific object a specific products or
Services which we are bringing out as a
result for example if I take a car so
how will I visualize various different
parts of the car it's very difficult in
one go in in execution perspective and
creation perspective we may require to
know every parts of it in detail so work
breakdown structure is established using
decomposition as a technique which means
for example if I take car as an example
car has a hole when you visualize
broadly I would classify that into
decompose it to the first level like
exteriors and Interiors after exteriors
I can further decompose the exterior
part of it similarly after Interiors I
will decompose it further in exteriors
what are the things I can think of like
exteriors in terms of glass in terms of
body in terms of tires in terms of wheel
Bonnet mirror rear view mirror which is
outside so likewise I love various
different decompositions level that is a
second level of decomposition next third
level of decomposition I can go in each
of these parts what I said I can further
elaborate those if I take the rear view
mirror as an example so I can think
about mirror cap I can think about
mirror glass I can think about mirror
Mount so these are the various different
decomposed levels below mirror similarly
if I come to Interiors we can think
about Entertainment System you can think
about seeds we can think about AC
right so we can think about uh anything
is like dashboards now each of these
components further I can decompose so
the idea of decomposing is I am going to
understand what are the various product
parts are involved to make a bigger
product as a whole so once I
accomplished that I will have a details
at each of these levels and consolidate
upwards as shown in the picture here the
first level Task 1 task 2 task three
before I assign these tasks I will have
the product breakdown structure first
and from bottom level I start adding up
the activities effort estimation and
then I keep consolidating upwards
similarly I will put the cost components
to it I'll estimate the cost involved
the one which is required and then I go
upwards and consult it so WBS helps in
organizing the work in a manageable
sections so this would help in
establishing additional details which
would help in defining tasks helping in
estimation helps in when I say
estimation it is not just specific
estimation it's about cost estimate
Mission schedule estimation effort
estimation and then this will also help
us in terms of sequencing further so
what breakdown structure will also have
something called WBS dictionary which
gives the description of all the WBS
elements next question question number
23 what is meant by the term SPI now SPI
refers to schedule performance index so
schedule performance index is a measure
of schedule efficiency expressed as a
ratio of earned value to the plant value
so when I say earned value earned value
is the actual work which is completed
the value the budgeted value for the
actual work which is completed and
planned value is the budgeted value of
the work which is supposed to be
accomplished as per the plan now this
will help us in understanding how the
project is progressing in schedule
perspective if SPI is lesser than 1
means it is behind schedule SPI is more
than one it is head of schedule if Spa
is one it is as per the plan schedule is
as per the plan question number 24 what
is the significance of agile project
management so when we say agile the
terminology itself refers to Quick
Response flexible moving faster so while
we do Agile project management it is
very essential to look at the various
Dynamics around so it may be a quick
response what you need to give right so
predominantly agile methodologies are
today adopted in various types of
Industries So currently we see more and
more in it and software industry then
product development marketing campaigns
even in constructing companies some of
the reasons that encourage Industries to
take a bagel methodologies are high
product quality High customer
satisfaction reduced risk better and
faster Roi now let us look at the
question number 25 what is the
significance of agile project management
so the agile project management
Frameworks involves continuous planning
and testing so there are various
different Frameworks each of them having
their own unique qualities so it is very
essential for us to understand what are
those various different agile Frameworks
and how they are going to contribute to
become agile so the most popular agile
Frameworks some thoughts which actually
depicts and supports organization to
become agile or one of that is kanban
framework so kanban framework is used to
implement agile software development and
requires real-time communication so work
items are represented on a kanban board
allowing team members to see the state
of each work at any time so this means
on the board so work in progress work
which has to be done and who has to do
it all these details are captured in the
kanban board now very important Point
here is when these are captured is very
essential to understand it is a visual
board so when it is a visual board it's
quite obvious anyone who has actually
have a task against them they don't
hesitate they need to complete it it
forces them since it is visualized
system it works on their Consciousness
so it is also called as pull system so
because people pull the work from that
list whatever is given and then
accomplish it so this will also help in
tracking the progression of a project
how it is progressing so how the project
is progressing how the tasks are being
completed how quickly they are completed
so it is easily visible and that makes
things too more smoother and faster
so scum framework so scrum framework
helps in dealing with complex problems
and making it possible to deliver high
quality products at the same time it
helps in managing complex advanced work
with little emphasis on software
development so it uses a terminologies
like Sprint product backlog Sprint
backlog daily scrum
retrospective meeting so three roles
predominantly we come across that is
product owner scrub master and then
self-organizing team
so next framework is hybrid framework
which you can think of so it is the
combination of agile methods with
non-agile methods hybrid can handle
requirement changes and it can deliver
products in stages so in hybrid model
planning is done using a waterfall
approach while the agile approach
handles execution and delivery so lean
framework so the lean framework works on
the concept of maximizing customer value
with fewer resources and zero waste
hence lean focuses on the flow of
products and services instead of
focusing on separate Technologies
companies can act upon with changing
customer needs and requirements so very
important points to observe here zero
waste means in the flow the way the
processes are connected to each other in
that flow we should identify what are
those which acts as a bottlenecks
resulting in waste so we should
eliminate such bottlenecks so these
elimination of bottlenecks helps in
reduction of waste at the same time
increasing the value to the customers so
in the downstream from the point where
bottleneck you have the entire capacity
will get limited to the downstream
capacity I'm speaking about will get
limited to the bottleneck where that
particular issue exists right that needs
to be resolved elimination of waste
should happen so waste is a result of
anything which is an non-valuating
activity right so we need to identify as
per the lean perspective so the defects
are not allowed to move forward to the
downstream that is the whole idea behind
it so next question 26 why does a
project manager need to be proactive
okay so we always have this question
coming around proactiveness versus
reactiveness when should we be proactive
when should we be reactive that we need
to understand now more proactive in
nature the project manager or any
manager who is more proactive will
basically visualize the future so they
act today so that tomorrow something
negative impact will not happen so a
proactive project manager is actively
able to determine the several
communication needs of the stakeholders
so a proactive project manager is able
to identify the risks in the early stage
of the project it is very essential so
what is that going to happen in future
that needs to be visualized act today so
that that occurrences can be handled
better or eliminated question number 27
what does a critical path method imply
so firstly let us understand what is
critical path means so critical path is
basically a longest path in a given
project Network diagram so that would be
the minimum time required for a project
to complete so any delay in any of the
activities or tasks in critical path
delays the project duration so in
critical path method so it is a crucial
tool for determining the progress of the
project to ensure that project is on
schedule so as I mentioned any delay in
any of the activities or tasks in the
critical path delays the project itself
so monitoring on these activities in a
critical path will become more important
so that project can happen as per the
Lan as per the date what is given so
critical path method helps in
determining the essential or critical
path by finding out the longest stretch
of dependent tasks so that each
dependencies each flow from left to
right from beginning to end as to a
visual realized and monitored very
closely so that project finished it is
not delayed it happens according to the
plan so next question defined planned
value actual cost and earned value so
when we say planned value planned value
is the approved value of the work that
needs to be completed within a given
period it serves as a Baseline and needs
to be calculated before work can be
started it is also known as budgeted
cost of work schedule so formula to
calculate planned values planned
percentage of work completed into
project budget assume your project
budget is 10 000 whatsoever the
currencies let us assume 10 000 is my
project budget so my project duration is
five months each month I have a plan to
complete the work worth of 2000 so which
means that 2000 is my plan value the
work which is supposed to be
accomplished within the end of that
first month is work worth of 2000 so if
I do the work which is lesser than work
worth of maybe lesser than 2000 I am
behind schedule if I complete the work
worth more than 2000 then I'm ahead of
schedule so planned value will become
that reference the 2000 what I mentioned
as a planned value the work worth of
2000 I'm supposed to complete before the
end of the month one if I say any work
which is completed according to the
budgeted value I will make this land
value as a reference to decide whether I
am behind schedule or ahead of schedule
actual cost actual cost refer to the
value of total expenses that you have
incurred for the work done till date for
example in the previous discussion
relating to the plant value at the end
of month one the planned value was 2000
so that is the work worth which we're
supposed to complete now let us assume
that we have completed a work where the
work worth relating to that actual work
completed is around 1800 means I'm
behind schedule for sure but at the same
time to come complete the work worth of
1800 how much I incurred actually so if
I have incurred actual cost also 1800
then cost twice I'm according to the
plan but behind schedule because I have
only completed the work worth of 1800
against the work worth of 2000 which is
a planned value and behind schedule but
to complete it the actual cost I
incurred is 1800 so cost wise I'm
according to the plan if my actual cost
is lesser than 1800 then I'm doing very
good in cost perspective if my actual
cost is more than 1800 then I am using
more money means over budget so actual
cost helps us in relating to plant value
defined whether cost wise how am I doing
so it is also known as actual cost of
work performed so this will be used to
calculate cost variance and cost
performance index earned value earned
value represents the value produced by a
project it is also known as budgeted
cost of work performed in our example
the earned value is 1800. meaning I have
completed the work worth of 1800 that is
the earned value which says behind
schedule when I compare earned value
with the planned value it it will tell
me whether I'm behind schedule ahead of
schedule or according to the plan now
for this earned value of 1800 if I incur
the actual cost of 1800 then cost wise
I'm doing good if my actual cost is
lesser than earned value then cost ways
I'm very good right if I incur more than
earned value for example to complete the
work worth of 1800 I incur the cost of
2000 then I'm not doing good I'm over
budget so the combination of earned
value and planned value helps us to know
the scheduled perspective whether
project is behind or ahead or according
to the plan scheduled perspective
whereas the combination of earned value
and actual cost helps us to understand
whether project is within the budget
over budget or according to the plan
question number 29. what is the purpose
of procurement management plan the
procurement management plan defines the
procurement requirements and how it can
be managed from developing a procurement
documentation through to contract
closure the plan identifies and defines
the items that need to be procured the
contracts that need to be used for
supporting the project how the contract
is approved and criteria for decisions
to be made as to be looked at the plan
also includes other items including
considerations for procurement risks and
procurement risk management deciding how
Cost needs to be determined standard
procurement documentation usage and
constraints to procurement
question number 30 when is postmortem
analysis performed in the project
management a postmortem in a project or
project retrospective refers to process
that's performed at the conclusion of
the phase for a multi-stage project this
aim to help identify process
improvements that can prevent future
risks and to ensure best practices are
repeated
postmortems involve a combination of
quantitative and qualitative data it
also includes qualitative data like end
user stakeholder and team satisfaction
potential for reuse and the quality of
end deliverable that is perceived
question number 31 what is the purpose
of risk register risk register is
basically a tool that is used to
document risks and the actions to handle
each of those risks the management of
risk is an ongoing process that has the
project team raising risks with the risk
manager or a project manager who then
locks the risks and determines an
appropriate course of action to handle
the risk risk register also needs to be
reviewed regularly to ensure the
appropriate actions are performed it
could be reviewed in every project team
meeting or at the end of each phase of
the Project Life Cycle question number
32 when do we use a gun chart so as we
are discussing about critical paths
Network diagram critical path method so
by using a project tools we first
establish a Gantt chart so Gantt chart
is basically a visual view of tasks
scheduled over a period a Gantt chart is
useful for outlining all the tasks
involved in the project along with their
order shown against the time scales so
since it gives the pictorial
representation it helps us in
understanding what tasks will be
completed after which tasks and how the
dependencies of each task will be can be
easily understood it provides an
overview of a project its Associated
tasks and then when they need to be
finished or clearly understood a Gantt
chart is helpful because it provides a
detailed view of all tasks and in shorts
one can create a workable schedule and
the right people are assigned to right
task it can be used to determine the
Practical aspect of the project it
enables to keep the team and sponsors
informed about the progress of the
project
question number 33 what is the
significance of the critical path method
so critical path method or CPM is a tool
that is used to schedule project
activities so CPM is used to create a
model that includes tasks required to
complete the project dependencies
between the tasks the durations required
to complete an activity the critical
path is the longest path in all the
available paths in the project and the
duration of the critical path will be
the minimum time required by the project
to complete it question number 34 what
are some tools required for arriving at
Improvement in processes so process
Improvement comprises a set of actions
implemented by a company to enhance
performance cost reduction increasing
profits Etc so some of the tools some
organization can use to implement a
successful process Improvement strategy
can be comparing and baselining a
project so with this we can get an
overview of how the process is
performing in operation with other
similar processes flowcharting which
helps them segregating the processes
activities events Etc value stream
mapping it helps clearly understand the
workflow and helps organizations
identify waste cause and effect analysis
these help organizations determine the
root cause of any problem hypothesis
testing which helps in testing to
determine whether a hypothesis would be
favorable to the organization or not
question 35 how do you work with three
point estimation method so the three
point estimation method is also called
as pert estimation which is a tool that
can be used to help increase the
accuracy of cost and time estimates
there are three parts with the different
estimates that is optimistic pessimistic
and most likely the optimistic estimate
is the amount of time required to
complete the project assuming everything
in the project goes according to the
plan pessimistic estimation is the
estimation considering the worst case
scenario and is an estimation given in
everything goes wrong that is the
Assumption so most likely estimation so
this is